e
all right it being 0900 hours at this
time I would like to perhaps ask
representative Jones if you would lead
us in the pledge as is our custom here
okay at this time we will get started
and our first measure up today is uh HB
264 FN with a financial note relative to
delegates to an article 5 convention
this is Article 5 day here in state
federal uh this measure this bill makes
it a Class B felony for a delegate to an
article 5 convention uh to support or
approve proposing an amendment not
authorized by by our
legislature Prime sponsor is here
representative Yul
welcome thank you Colonel I appreciate
it uh for the record my name is Jordan
erery uh representing Hillsboro New
Hampshire in Hillsboro 13 I am the
sponsor of HB 264 FN over the
past several years a decade or so I've
been constantly receiving email and
letters and I've been spoken to at the
post office while food shopping uh
dining establishments in town the human
cry is such that my wife could make this
presentation from merely overhearing
these discussions and she doesn't
particularly like
Politics the issue is the lack of
responsiveness of a distant national
government throughout history this has
been the issue of states and Nations the
founding fathers of the United States
however had extraordinary insight into
human nature and saw the danger of a
massive bureaucracy of in a government
and they left us with a constitutional
power as we all know our government uh
nationally rests on a three-legged stool
of people States and a federal
government the people directly elect
representatives electors to elect the
president and the members of the house
and the Senate these two branches then
support the supposedly nonpartisan
devotees to the written law the Supreme
Court judges yes this is a deliberately
inefficient method of government wherein
the people can have a direct say we have
strayed from that again the found
founding fathers were rather sure a
bureaucratic government would exist they
had just fought a war like largely
because of a distant government not
responding remember ta taxes the
Intolerable
Acts after long debate and within our
constitution is the basis for the people
to restrain that government yes we can
elect people to office but sometimes is
necessary to shake the tree as it were
and legally threaten the accumul ated
Power by invoking the right of the
people to tell their federal government
what to do as as opposed to torches and
Pitch pitchforks of the nearby Shay
Rebellion the Constitution allows for
the states remember that the several
sovereign states have co-equal standing
with the people and the federal
government to take action to apply
change to the federal
government that's a paraphrasing of
Jefferson via a constitutional amendment
orig originating not from the
bureaucracy or deep state but from the
incubators of democracy the states
themselves that is Article 5 in a
nutshell an essential
part far too infrequently applied
Congress has an appetite for power it is
up to the states to curb that power
which infringes upon the rights and
privileges of we the people in the bills
before the committee today there is an
attempt to rebuke the will of the people
already passed by this body by this
legislature I bill to assure the State
Legislative control of delegates when an
article 5 convention is called such as
this uh hb26 whatever it is for and
another call for a convention to the
States this letter this speech which I
provided to the clerk can apply to all
three in service testimony on those
bills with regard to an attempt to
reject the will of the people the
1970s in in the 1970s and more recently
Scot scotus decision decisions have
repeatedly stated that when petitioning
the federal government once the petition
is made the goal has been scored and you
can't unmake a
goal there is no recision that can
therefore be valid it is in my
considered an informed op opinion that
such an effort is speculative at best
and certainly move to the entire purpose
of Article 5
itself with regard to delegates by
whatever name known the states have the
absolute right to appoint whomsoever the
state wishes since a cons uh a
Convention of states is a legislative
action no executive involvement is valid
States already um routinely Place
restrictions on Commissioners to
interstate compacts such as the Conn
Connecticut River compact the bill
before you does nothing more than that
among the handouts before you was the
list of states that have already sub uh
submitted petitions uh before the go U
chart even uh Senator Schumer as well as
as never as nearly every responsible
constitutional expert has repeatedly
declared that a petition for a
convention regardless of a topic is
substantially similar to merely a call
for a convention to undertake a specific
action it is up to the states to to
limit what topic their delegates by
whatever name called can vote upon the
Hampshire led the way with this
principle when the constitutional
convention was called by the
Confederation of states in the 1780s our
delegates left Philadelphia to return to
conquered for instructions others
followed St suit I was reminded today
that some didn't even bother to show up
until after New Hampshire came back and
said yeah let's do
this some seem to forget that our
Federal
Constitution has elements that challenge
Federal Primacy some people may Advance
a theory saying the states cannot call a
convention or that the convention will
run away or that the world will
implode some seem to say the
Constitution must be protected by not
following the Constitutional Provisions
available to the
states some seem to think that the
provision in the Bill of Rights which
was adopted largely uh by the insistence
of New Hampshire especially the 9th and
the
10th do not apply
a small vocal Progressive socialist
sounding minority suggests that the
convention will lead to the total
Destruction of a of a constitutional
republic as an aside it is interesting
to note that the founder of one of those
special uh interest groups was a strong
advocate for using Article 5 to control
the Deep state of federal bureaucracy
way back in the
70s I would remind you that a
constitutional convention is is akin to
a Committee hearing such as this it is
important but not the end all rather we
the people must vote on the results of
the convention actions the bar for
changing the Constitution is high as the
discussion of the ongoing erra uh
Congress created Amendment illustrates
it is not the convention one must fear
rather one must examine the motives of
why the rights of the people not to be
able to vote on topics are being
attacked I have provided or I am
providing a copy of uh Utah senator Ken
Ivory's book where is the line I hope
the chairman makes it available to any
who request it but I have requested more
copies uh from uh my friend Ken Ivory
for the the rest of the committee we
need to stop the federal government from
its overreach and interference in the
commission duties of the state
governments we can return the power to
the People by as tip O'Neal suggested
keeping the power local via the states
challenging the
overbearing uh Washington
DC
bureaucracy in this committee you have a
serious obligation to help return power
to the states and their Sury people I
have included in my presentation
handouts from the agency created out of
the 2018 Convention of States held in
Phoenix as a repository of information
on Article 5 and the 10th Amendment I
was a delegate uh to that event
appointed by the speaker uh
representative Bill Omen and several
others were also present the president
of the Senate appointed Senator Dan inis
rules for the operation of the
convention were created and sent to the
various
States the interesting impediment to
their not already having been a call
issued by Congress is that the the
employee of Congress the
archist to whom petitions are addressed
has never reported the petitions to
Congress you may recall that the
longtime AR archist recently retired and
took his pension rather
unexpectedly the Library of Congress to
which petitions are sent for efficient
government filing I say that remembering
the last scene of Raiders of the Lost
Arc um has some 38 to 40 petitions on
file depending upon whether you count
uh several that are different based upon
the information and belief there are a
few members of Congress of both bodies
and both parties who are active
preparing interested Supreme Court
litigation that may happen within this
legislative term to force a publication
and Counting of the sunry petitions thus
this type of legislation is
necessary as you know a deliberative and
measured legislative approach is second
only to the lethargic and waddling pace
of
litigation finally remember this
Congress accumulates power to itself
Congress as an entity abhor power
sharing and the Constitution envisioned
that Congress fears as is illustrated by
the UNC counted petitions the states
exercising their constitutional power to
threaten the status quo New Hampshire
led the way in establishing the
Constitution New Hampshire can maintain
its role as a leader in this nation with
the passage of HB
264 which is a step in that direction
I'd be glad to answer any questions I
will point out that the multi-page final
draft is a uh work product of the
Phoenix correspondence uh commission
called the
PCC uh which is in your packet and there
is a handout talking about the problem
the solution and who PCC is and how you
can get involved uh just as
a uh bit of a prim ofasa information on
it supporting that I've also included
the current national debt which is why I
petitioned for and got the balance
budget amendment established in the
first place which is rising at the rate
7,547 per
second that's an interesting figure uh
you may have seen uh U representative
Massie has a little clock on his lapel
pin that's how fast it's going because
you can hardly count the last four
digits they were rotating over so fastly
and and then there's sometimes been a
question regarding uh faithless delegate
uh
legislation well there were that
question rised was risen in 2020 and
again this year but uh the Supreme Court
decided that decision when they talked
about faithful elector laws an elector
is a delegate of the state elected by
people and they said yep you can control
how people vote on federal issues i' be
happy to answer any questions sir thank
you thank you representative uh thank
you for the wonderful handouts
especially the Article Five convention
legislative progress report uh very uh
useful very helpful so thank you for
that uh a couple quick ones you just
mentioned faithless electors versus
versus Faith faithless delegates so the
Supreme Court ruling on faithless
electors you you say that applies to
faithless delegates as well to Article 5
I would say it does yes because the
electors are elected to do a job for the
state that is to reflect the election of
the individuals states can place
restrictions on individuals saying that
you signed up to do this you advertise
to do this uh you were elected to do
this you have to do this and at the same
time a person who signs up to go to uh
um and or is appointed by the
legislature to be a delegate of the
legislature at a convention which I
signed up to do this I said I'm going to
vote on this topic and this topic only
and that's the only topic I'm going to
vote on same thing as I signed up and
I'm only going to vote on for a or
b okay got got it a similar measure to
this representative has come through
this committee and through the house
before I'm trying to remember I believe
it went to the governor's desk and maybe
was vetoed I'm trying to recollect
you're probably ahead of me in this if
if that's the case if if a similar Meo
if a similar measure was vetoed uh do
you remember what what the rationale for
the veto was uh the to the best of my
recollection um several governors of
veto this and I remember Dan it had put
some legislation in a decade or so ago
along the same lines and it was vetoed
by a Democrat Governor and it was also
vetoed by Republican Governors um say
the argument at the same time was well
it's nice it be a good idea but we
really don't need it we don't need this
to have on the books I would suggest to
this committee and to the entire general
court that uh time is running out uh
once it was discovered that the uh
petitions had not been counted and there
are efforts underway to count those
petitions thank you representative other
beler thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for being here to take my question which
is in the specifics the the the broad
Strokes sound pretty reasonable and good
I'm a little curious about the specifics
particularly when it comes to
definitions under unauthorized Amendment
and legislative instructions where it
says that
um uh an unauthorized Amendment means a
proposed amendment or change to the
United States Constitution that is
outside the scope of the article 5
application and legislative instructions
so then we looked at legislative
instructions it says uh means
instruction given by the general court
to a delegate before or during an
article 5 convention so what is what is
the scope of of that exactly what is and
does not qualify is it a is it a full
vote of the house is it a vote of those
present is it a a vote out of a
committee is it a speaker's
instruction it would probably be a bit
of a combination of both um for let's
take housing for example which is is
discussed in in the uh the fiscal if the
speaker said you cannot stay at a
five-star
hotel then that's an instruction and if
you go to a five-star hotel anything
above 60110 $200 a night it's on you uh
would be my interpretation of that the
other instruction would be something
from the uh joint resolution of the uh
of the body and remember we can call our
own uh body into session at any time for
a special session uh to issue new
instruction C so if uh for example we
were uh the convention was called and
the convention was called for the
purpose of discussing my favorite topic
a balance budget
amendment and somebody brought up an
amendment to appeal the Second
Amendment uh our guys couldn't vote on
that second amendment unless they said
yes vote on it and vote
no uh and while while we're on that one
remember don't would take 13 states the
people of the people or legislators of
13 states to say no to any Amendment and
it's
dead
so it's it's a big hurdle to pass
representative Gagney has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Ry for taking my question
I know the answer you know the answer to
this question then why are you
asking because other people people
around might not know so you'll indulge
me here uh I see the penalty for
violation is a Class B uh
felony uh do you could you tell the
people what a classb felony how many
years that
is 1 to 7even I believe three and a half
to seven 3 and A2 to S three and A2 to S
I suppose Class A is a 7 to 15 7 and2
followup sir followup thank you
um assuming that this bill passes this
committee you are also aware that it'll
probably go to the C&J committee to see
whether or not the uh penalty would be
proper which could slow things down you
aware of that right yes I am aware of
that and uh I'll tell this committee
which will have the obligate if this
committee passes it which will be
presenting it before
C&J
that a penalty sub substantial enough to
get somebody's
attention
works I'll point out that this measure
also has a fiscal note this is HB 264 FN
typically measures with fiscal notes are
looked at by Finance uh possibility of
uh a different committee looking at it
as as well uh is uh is is interesting uh
and thank you gagy for the for the
lesson on felony charges people watching
at home uh always learn from watching
our hearings at uh state state federal
any other questions for the prime
represent
budak uh thank you Mr chairman for the
uh for this opportunity and thank you
for testifying today uh my question is
why is this bill feel necessary when the
Constitution already provides a method
for amendments through Congressional
rectification thank you there are two
methods in Article
5 for
approval this has nothing to do with a
petition
for a um Constitutional Convention a
call of the
states this only regulates the delegates
to that convention if
called what this does is establishes the
authority of the state to prevent
delegates to a constitutional convention
which has nothing to do with Congress
involved under the the second half of
Article
5 this would regulate the conduct and
the voting behavior of the delegates to
that Constitutional Convention now
Congress can amend the Constitution any
time it wants sometimes they've been
successful remember Congress passed the
Volstead Act so we could not
drink they did a good job on that one
one way to get organized crime firmly
embedded in
society um the states have the equal
authority to propose
amendments to the
Constitution and this regulates our
delegates not our Congress Critters but
our state delegates to the
Constitutional Convention so there's two
co-equal
activities One Federal and one
state Article 5 does is silent regarding
the ability of the state to control but
that is because the state is its own
entity that is co-equal in in theory
with the federal government the federal
government is grown to the point where
the states
are being abused
again other questions seeing none uh
on the legislative
instructions thank
you uh are given by the general court to
a delegate before or during Article 5
convention that doesn't mean he has an
independent way of voting he has to vote
the way he's told is that correct it
could be or it could be also just to not
consider remember we have instructions
um when we across the hall we if we're
present we have to vote but we can also
have instructions not to attend and I'm
sure somebody in here has at one time or
another been told that it was probably
time for them to have a smoke break even
if they didn't smoke
so uh that that's what a legislative
instruction is they could be told to
vote yay on this proposed amendment or
vote nay on this proposed amendment
by the general court because the general
court retains the power and they're
obligated I'm sorry
follow yes they would be
obligated thank you other questions
seeing none thank you Mr Prime sponsor
repr some viy okay Sam fieldman is back
uh we saw Sam a number of times last
year Sam has asked or M Mr fieldman has
asked for 2 minutes I think we can do
or okay uh well Mr fman uh you you
back thank you very much uh my name is
Samuel fieldman uh thank you uh chairman
mfet members of the committee um
testifying in support of this uh of this
bill um and last year I testified in
support of uh two other bills to
regulate the Article 5 convention
delegates um I help I participated in uh
drafting one of those bills um and I
this it's an uh area of expertise for me
it's uh I'm one of the top experts on
the Article 5 convention process in the
country um and uh the advantage that
this bill has over the ones last year
although I I certainly support the ones
last year and actually like them better
than this one uh this one is
considerably simpler uh the ones last
year ended up dying in the Senate and as
far as I understood it the reason why
they died in the Senate was largely
because they were um too complicated for
the Senate to deal with in the time that
was available um they didn't see it as a
priority although I certainly view it as
such this one uh is much simpler it just
uh puts on one penalty on onto the um uh
onto delegates who uh who um violate
their Oaths and uh that exact thing has
been upheld by the Supreme Court
unanimously as recently as 2020 um in
the case of uh electors the Electoral
College um representative mfet uh asked
about the comparison between delegates
and electors uh it's important to note
in that case there there's two
comparisons one um uh the uh regulations
over delegates to Article 5 conventions
has a longer history than regulations
over um over uh electricity Electoral
College because the Article 5
ratification conventions that were used
in 1933 to ratify um the uh the 21st
amendment um included regulations in
some of those bills particularly in
Arizona that had a bill virtually
identical to the one uh in New Mexico
that was the subject of that case in the
Supreme Court um and further uh uh Larry
leig who argued um in that in uh the
other side the losing side of that case
in Shalo V Washington um he thought that
the regulations would not apply to the
electoral college but would apply to the
delegates uh to an article 5 convention
uh because the the arguments in favor of
those kinds of regulations applying to
delegates convention uh are
significantly stronger based on uh
various factors in how the Constitution
treats the two I I disagreed I thought
they applied to both and the Supreme
Court ended up agreeing with me that
they do apply to the electors and
there's no reason to think that the same
wouldn't hold true for uh delegates um
always good when the Supreme Court
agrees with you are you yes I mean Larry
Le was uh happy with the decision even
though he lost it he's talked many times
about that being a successful loss um
the the one last thing I want to point
out there uh is a a potential for an
article 5 convention coming up fairly
soon uh based on existing convention
calls that um that passed as of 1979 uh
including New Hampshire um many of those
have since been rescinded but recision
uh is not relevant once you hit the uh
threshold of 34 and the argument there
is that since we've crossed that
threshold as of 1979 the recisions that
happened after that point no longer
matter even though recisions certainly
are valid if they happen before you hit
34 um based on that there could be a
convention coming in the near future now
if you support that idea uh you should
want to pass this uh this regulation if
you oppose that idea you should demand
that you pass this regulation either way
it make sure that the process is safer
and does follow the in addition to the
many other uh safety checks on that
process it adds one more to just ensure
um that the delegates follow what is
asked of them sure ex extra insurance so
to speak uh would you take any questions
after are there any questions uh
representative Lloyd thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I apologize I'm I have a really
bad head cold this week um so are you
not given your background are you not
concerned that this would tie delegates
to a more partisan politics um position
rather than allowing them to engage in a
more independent and in good faith
measure it would tie delegates to the
demands of their particular State um and
that is the way that process is supposed
to work if the states are not able to
come together on a particular um on a
particular uh policy then that policy
should not and cannot be in the
Constitution and that's the way that's
supposed to work followup followup um
thank you uh so are there any
protections that could be allowed for to
make sure that a minority voice can also
be represented especially given that the
penalties of tying delegates are is so
high sure well absolutely um the
delegates are first of all the
Constitution guarantees this is a
substantial majority view in the
literature that the constitution
guarantees um the delegacy to deliberate
uh they have to be able to have some
decision-making process the state can
tie their hands to it to a certain
degree in terms of um like the the
subject matter and procedures um but it
can't prevent deliberation to come
together it can't mandate a specific
language for example um there are also
going to be people from all 50 states
this this is not just for the states
that support a particular uh policy it's
for all all 50 states and in particular
only 34 states have to come together uh
to call the convention to discuss that
policy but you need 38 uh which is four
of the additional 16 a quarter of the
ones that did not call for the
convention still have to come together
as part of the ratification so their
voice has to be heard or else it will
never go through ratification so even
the states if they may want to dominate
it with a particular left-wing or
right-wing policy uh that would not end
up resulting in uh an amendment to the
Constitution it would end up resulting
in nothing which is why I don't fear a
convention even on subject matters where
I disagree because either they will find
language for the Constitution that
passes that enormous threshold and
solves the many hurdles or it won't end
up in the Constitution and it will
become one of several proposals that
that simply uh are not part of the law
understood thank you for that other
questions seeing none uh thank you Mr
Felman thank you uh Bob Hansen from
Salem is Bob here yes he is he's asked
for up to two minutes uh welcome Mr
bill uh thank you for the opportunity
I've lived in Salem for 50 years I voted
in every local and national election for
over 60 years I just want to support the
uh this motion uh I support the
um Article 5 convention I just want to
make sure there's a distinction made
that regardless of any feelings you have
on the Article 5 convention you need to
really look at this independently they
need 34 states to have the convention 19
states have already approved this there
are another three to four states that
are in process in the next few months so
we should reach the 34 states in within
a number of years when that happens New
Hampshire is going to send delegates
regardless of whether or not they
approve of the bill so it's important
that we have the rules in place to be
able to control the delegates and be
able to make sure that they're complying
with the state
requirements thank you for the
opportunity thank you for that
affirmation of what we heard earlier
thank you Mr Hansen uh will you take any
questions if there are any yeah sure uh
are there any questions for Mr
Hansen seeing none uh thank you I just
have one other thought that occurred to
me the speakers before me a couple times
they use the termic
uh a conventional convention or
Constitutional Convention I just want to
make the distinction the Article 5
convention is only to propose amendments
to the existing Constitution a
constitutional convention is usually
interpreted as trying to come up with
the new Constitution and Article 5 is
not trying to do that they don't have
the authority to do that I just want to
make out the distinction for you thank
you thank you again important
distinction in
indeed uh Eric Benitas is Eric here Mr
Benitas it looks like he is in the house
he's asked for three minutes he's in
support of the bill HB
264 welcome Mr Benitas thank you thank
you very much chairman thank you uh uh
committee members uh I will not take
that much time because I did not realize
Sam would be here so I thought I was
going to be uh representing uh Wolfpack
um in this but uh he was here and he is
much more knowledgeable than I am on
Article 5 so I'm I'm grateful for that
uh my name is Eric Benavides I live in
the town of Guilford I am here in
support uh of this uh bill um while
there is lots of evidence uh
peer-reviewed evidence that article 5 uh
conventions State conventions are safe
and uh that the process will work
exactly how we uh Envision it to and it
will not go off the rails let me just
state that right away I do believe that
bills like this um offer greater
protection um for us um and also give
people confidence that this process will
work um so uh I'm in favor of this um
and uh as the gentleman stated um we are
very close to possibly having a
convention so having um these uh bills
in place these regulations would be good
uh I believe 25 of the 50 states have
already passed bills like this faithful
delegate bills um so they are already in
place in those States and I believe New
Hampshire should be the 26th um that is
all I have to say I can take any
questions you you might have thank you
Mr benus are there any questions M uh Mr
representative
bataki so uh hypothetically speaking
let's say 34 states have passed or
adopted this uh Bill what specific
constitutional changes do we do you do
we or hope do you hope to achieve
through an article 5 convention that
cannot be accomplished
through sorry
uh let me find the right questions
uh
response um well let me just State what
wolfpack's mission is who I'm here
representing sure as a volunteer but
still I do represent that
organization um wolfpack's goal is to
get large money out of our political
system the corrupting influence of it
and we support any means necessary to
make that happen anything available to
us in the Constitution whether that is
through Congress whether it is through
bills and legislation within a state
itself or whether it is the Article 5
convention we do not discriminate any
way we can get there we want to get
there um and so uh so that is our goal
um we we do believe that Congress would
have a chance to pass this but being
America everything is divided we do not
set Power in one place that is why we
have two branches uh three branches of
government to separate the powers that's
why there is a senate and a house that's
why there's a governor we separate the
power is to make sure that one body does
not have all the power in Article 5 and
the ability to propose amendments is the
exact same thing we cannot have that
power live in one body alone we need it
to be separated the states have the
right if Congress will not act to
propose for a convention so that we can
propose amendments as well and to put
all of that power into one body or to be
afraid to use our state right to invoke
that power limits us and causes us to
have a corrupt body that is the only
place that can propose amendments and I
do not believe that that America was
designed in that way thank you again and
thank you for confirming the the wolf
pack Mission other questions
representative mandle bomb thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so I just wanted to to clarify
something for the record so I've heard
that 34 states are needed to call a
convention um and 19 States so far have
already passed faithful delegate views
no 25 25 states have passed faithful
delegate bills okay and um one of the
previous speakers mentioned 19 do you
know what or if um it could be that I
don't know records are are different was
he talking about faithful delegate bills
or was he talking about possible states
that passed uh uh convention calls
um con that was convention call so
convention call is separate from a
faithful delegates Bill the faithful
delegates bill that we are looking at
today is not a convention call it is to
put restrictions on a delegate um a a
call to a convention is a totally
different and we have already passed a
balanced budget amendment um call to the
Constitution and I I I I'm afraid that I
don't follow the balance budget
amendment as much as I follow the
campaign Finance Amendment so I'm not
sure what the total is right now you'd
have to refer to one of my balanced
budget amendment colleagues thank you Mr
B when the clerk asks for something for
the record that's that's a good thing we
want to make sure we have the numbers
correct other questions representative
bataki sorry for the previous confusion
I found my question now okay so what
specific constitutional changes do we
hope or do you hope to achieve through
an article five convention that cannot
be accomplished through the traditional
amendment process the sorry the last
part the traditional amendment process
uh there is nothing that can be done if
if Congress wants to do the traditional
if amendment process I would be more
than happy to allow them to do that the
fact is that they are not doing that and
the we our job is to push for an article
5 Amendment because Congress will not
act and that is our
duty other
questions saying none thank you so much
for your testimony yeah I appreciate all
the way down here from Guilford I have
two more cards
um Carol pusit Carol it looks like she's
asked for 56 seconds but maybe I'm not
reading 56 seconds that's a a request we
can definitely honor uh coming here from
Rochester thank you I wanted to make
sure I typed it up so I could be super
fast because I know you have a lot of
people to listen to thank you so much
for having me um New Hampshire should
definitely pass this resolution since
New Hampshire legislature turns over
every two years New Hampshire needs to
have its delegate legislation in place
the New Hampshire legislators that I
have spoken to are not sure how basic
agency law Works they're not lawyers and
they're not required to be lawyers
passing this legislation stops the
confusion on how to proceed when an
article 5 convention is called I would
love for this legislation to include any
Interstate Convention as well thus
protecting New Hampshire even further it
would also be great to include delegate
selection protocols and who is going to
charge them for being guilty of a clasby
felony and who's going to hold the
delegates accountable I thank the
sponsors for their foresight in
protecting New Hampshire and I thank
this committee for passing HB 264 I am
available for questions and I thank you
for that excellent succinct organized
testimony M much appreciated are there
any
questions singan thank you so much for
that our final card here is from uh Joe
trelli from hampt and he's asked for 2
minutes speaking for himself and he's in
trelli it's a wide share thank you
committee um I I want to start with uh
my timer here so I have it I just want
to talk about briefly I'm I'm going to
follow up on several of the other
comments from from other people
providing testimony I'm not going to
read the the book to you uh Belton
suspenders it there safety measures so
people refer to Belton suspenders as
solving one problem if it breaks through
there's a backup to it and so what we
have in the belt and suspenders are
things that Charles Pinkney brought into
the Constitutional Convention in
Philadelphia in March of
1787 there was no option for Congress to
propose amendments with that article
16 that was presented to the to the uh
to the chamber based on the Virginia
Plan it was solely the state legislators
that were going to call a convention to
propose amendments among the several
States at that time
13 so that was put in
place and discussed until it shifted in
June when Congress that was actually
Alexander Hamilton wanted to have well
we need Congress to do
this and it shifted back again so it
included Congress and the letter the
words or and the written testimony that
I sent last night a five-page document I
don't know if any of you saw it I
actually specify the words it says the
Congress whenever two-thirds of both
houses shall deem it necessary shall
propose amendments to this
Constitution and it says this constit
ution twice in Article 5 so that's belt
number one
suspenders there's three topics so this
this bill refers to Article 5 three
topics impose fiscal restraints on the
federal government limit the power and
jurisdiction of the federal government
limit the terms of office for its
officials and members of Congress so any
delegates that are appointed elected by
the states are signing up for those
topics and committing that those are
going to be what those topics are that
they're going to debate at a convention
for proposing amendments and then what
gets forgotten one state one vote so if
50 states go if New York wants to send
one person to object to it they get one
negative vote if they send 50 people
whatever the majority of New York is
they get one vote every state gets one
vote and then when those amendments
Whatever Gets 26 goes back to the States
for
ratification and it takes 3/4 of those
states to ratify so we have belts
suspenders we have velcro double-sided
tape we've got all kinds of things and
all it takes is 13
chambers of 99 bodies because Nebraska
no thank
you any questions from Mr
trelli seeing none at this time before I
close this hearing I want to say
excellent civics lesson today from
everyone who's spoken up on on the
Article Five which I think uh a lot of
folks need to understand
better okay uh that brings us to our
next measure we're almost right on time
uh
hc3 house concurrent resolution
three uh
applying for a Convention of the states
under Article 5 which we've just been
talking about of the US
Constitution the prime sponsor is here
thank you uh representative
for
okay uh we have a lot of pink cards uh
which is great um so I'm going
to run this through I want to let the
prime sponsor fully develop his position
when we get to other folks because of
the many any pink cars we have uh I I do
not want to have to be in a position to
limit testimony so if someone has uh
given some testimony and touched on some
points that you are going to make uh
this is on on YouTube it's being
recorded so uh don't feel the need to
repeat things we're looking for new new
information uh with every new test uh
new testimony so with that uh welcome
representative Bernardi the prime
sponsor thank you chairman MAF and
committee glad to see you all again uh
for the record representative JD
Bernardi Rockingham 36 Hampton Falls uh
kington Southampton Newton and
plastow uh so I'm here to offer hcr3 a
concurrent resolution applying for a
Convention of States under Article Five
of the Constitution to the United States
and uh I know that there are many new
members here and you heard some of
Article 5 uh I guess uh procedures
already but I just want to reprise that
quickly for the committee what is an
article five it's a procedure to amend
the Constitution and there are two
methods congress with the 2third vote
can propose amendments or 2third of the
states can make an application for a
convention to propose amendments and
those would be limited purpose
conventions with specific uniform
applications to amend not redraft the
Constitution those that convention comes
up with the wording of the Amendments
that are then presented either from
Congress or from the convention to three
quarters of the states to ratify well
all the states to ratify in three
quarters in order to for it to actually
be ratified um to become part of the
Constitution now while why was this
two-part process or two mechanism way
adopted so the initial proposal being
discussed at the Constitutional
Convention was that only Congress was
going to propose the Amendments and that
was that was supported by Madison our
the father of our Constitution and
remember he didn't support the first 10
amendments and what became the 27th as
well but led their way to advancement
when he became a congressman in the
first Congress but during that
Constitutional Convention George Mason
stood up and said Congressional role
alone would be excessive exceptional and
dangerous the plan now formed will firm
will will certainly be defective as a
confederation has found on trial to be
amendments therefore will be necessary
and it will be better to provide for
them in an easy regular and
constitutional way than trust to chance
and violence it would be improper to
require the consent of the national
legislature because they may abuse their
power and refused to consent to that
very account so basically Mason stood up
and said
Congress if if there is a need may
decide they don't want to deal with this
issue
Jerry our our urw uh neighbor to the to
the South uh proposed the State
Convention process it was unanimously
adopted on the last day of the
convention Madison then switched his
support to it and spoke to it in
Federalist
43 there was also been great concern
that the actual Constitutional
Convention that dealt with this was not
legitimate in 1786 the Annapolis
convention on trade and commerce
resulted in Virginia's call for devising
And discussing all alterations and
further Provisions as may be necessary
to render the Federal Constitution
adequate to the exigencies of the
Union you had six states then call for a
constitutional con
convention then the actual
conf uh Confederation Congress issued
their
decree and then six other states
followed the only one that didn't was
Rhode
Island Madison speaking about this in a
letter to Jefferson said the
recommendations from the meeting in
Annapolis of the Plenty potenti meaning
we're going to do the whole thing
convention in Philadelphia in May
next has been well received indeed the
evidence of dangerous defects of the
Confederation has been has has at length
prited the most obstinate adversaries to
reform Madison in his diary then wrote
all agreed and owed that the federal
government in its existing shape has
ineff is was inefficient and could be
lost members of the Southern and middle
States seem generally anxious about some
Republic repan organization of a system
which could preserve the union and give
due energy to the government of
it in the handout I provided you uh I
gave you the actual commissions of
those 12 States saying we want to have a
convention to deal with this with the
issues on a plenty potenti
way and I gave you the list of 40 two
documented conventions that have been
held since the the uh Europeans came to
this
continent in no case were these runaways
I give you this information because
there are those that are going to follow
and say if you have an article 5
convention it will be a Runway it can be
a runaway it'll be a disaster I wanted
to put a state through the heart of that
fantasy that is not true you have the
commissions of the states that said we
want to do this we want to have a
revision of the Articles and create a
new government and you have the examples
of conventions that have been held where
there has been no runaway problems
now Article
Five conventions have been tried in the
past and never
uh never happened in the United States
to this
point but they have been drivers of
change and I give you two examples in
1912 29 of the necessary 31 States
pushed for direct election of senators
that caused the Congress to act they
created the 17th amendment in 1983 we
got 32 states of the 34 necessary at
that time to pursue balanced budget
amendment the result was Congress passed
the Graham Redman haulings Provisions
the following two
years so you can see that even if a a
movement for a convention doesn't
actually get there it can be a Spur to
Congress to act as they often times do
not want to take actions against against
uh against their power and authority and
the budget amendment is clear so what is
hcr3
proposing basically controls in three
different areas first to uh discuss
potential uh options for fiscal
restraints on the federal government
right now we have almost a $37 trillion
debt when I spoke on this measure
measure two years ago it was around 32
trillion it is clearly out of control
hence there is a very strong movement
for some kind of balanced budget
amendment and as well as a tax revenue
cap proposal there could be other items
that fall under fiscal constraints but
those seem to be the two most
common second limit the power and
jurisdiction of the federal government
well this comes from the fact that we
have an administrative state that is
ruling far too much of our life we have
a supreme court that has made decisions
uh particularly on the interstate
commerce uh Clause uh where they they
decided that growing wheat on one's own
farm for one's own use was interstate
commerce once they did that the door was
open and and Congress could make law on
anything citing it was compliant with
Article 1 Section 8 of The Constitution
and Article 1 Section 8 if you remember
that's where it lists these are the
powers of congress everything else
that's not here belongs to the states
well they've they've taken that and
they've run with it so we have massive
uh amounts of power that Congress has
acred to itself to make laws that that
we are not in favor of if if from a
state perspective uh or admin create an
administrative state that does the same
so the kinds of things uh that could be
considered and discussed in a
convention
um on this particular item would be
proper definition of the Commerce Clause
or state laws uh uh State opportunity to
abgate laws regulations executive orders
of of uh Court decisions mean a proposal
three4 of the states or two-thirds of
the states if faced with the law that
says all right everybody has to uh uh
Drive EVS by 2050 say no we're not going
to do that if enough of if enough States
decide that they want to uh uh in a
proposal like that if that was a
constitutional amendment that states had
that Authority one could overturn a a uh
inappropriate overreaching of Congress
or the
executive
um reversing the 17th Amendment
restoring State legislatures back to
deciding who is going to be their
Senators so the Senators work for the
states and DEP protect State interests
rather than the the broad um general
public where our state representatives
are supposed to uh take that task
Congressional override of Supreme Court
decisions by a super majority sunsetting
of uh of of agencies Congressional
approval of agency regulations right now
the the Constitution says that the
Congress is the only entity that can
make laws yet we have administrative
agencies making most of our laws
something's wrong with that
equation uh so there there are multiple
areas of discussion for proposals for
Amendment under this broad
topic and finally the third topic is
limitation of terms of office for
officials and for members of
Congress so term limits for
representatives and Senators term limits
for senior federal officials working in
the government term limits for judges
and justices these are all all potential
proposals under this broad rubric uh and
uh that could be discussed in amendments
hence
proposed I'd like to point out that uh
Linda mimel a former member of this
committee and I uh were honored to
participate in a simulated Article 5
Convention of states in August of
20123 uh with legislators from every
state and it was an outstanding success
and I think truly demonstrated the
opportunity that this kind of procedure
could uh could
hold but bottom line you as state
legislators are a nation's last line of
defense against an all powerful
overreaching federal government the
framers preserve this task for you as
your
Birthright you are enabled to reclaim
the people's power power 19 states have
done so I urge you to be the 20th the
issue deserves full consideration in the
house happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr Prime sponsor
representative Bernardi you said the
Article Five was adopted unanimously in
Philadelphia is that article five the
The Proposal of having uh yes both the
Congressional route and the uh State
Route uh and it was it was discussed for
for uh on several rounds and finally um
Colonel Mason was able to convince all
that it was appropriate and necessary
repres
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm looking at the prior Bill and I'm
looking at your bill my understanding is
that you want the same outcome come as
HB 264 for an article 5 convention could
you tell me if any what the difference
between your bill and the other bill
would yours accomplish
more I I don't think so the the the key
language
is uh having the state agree that it
wants to move forward for in the three
areas and the three areas are are the
same
thank you and I would point out that
representative Bernard's measur is an
HCR it's a house concurrent resolution
previous measure was a HB was a house
build so there was a distinction there
uh representative F I'm sure represent
Bernard would love to have a question
from
you thank you and thank you
representative Bernardi I just want to
clarification and I apologize I don't
have your resolution in front of me um
so under in your hand out here you say
um each state gets one vote like in the
Electoral College but I think anyone
who's stayed up all night on Election
night knows that not every state in the
Electoral under the Electoral College
gets one vote can so can you just
clarify is in your resolution is it one
state one vote or is it a situation like
the Electoral
College no it's
uh in a convention each state gets one
vote
is this is yes like that yes
representative
mbom um thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you representative bernardy I have
a followup to representative F's
question so can states determine how
many delegates they send to a convention
but they'd still have one vote Yes
states can can send as many delegates as
they want in the original articles uh of
of uh
Confederation uh you could send as many
you want you needed two to agree or a
majority to agree you needed two at
least to make a a vote if only one
showed up your your state didn't get a
vote you needed at least two uh uh to uh
participate and you have your vote count
but if you had 17 show up you had to
have the a majority opinion and that was
your one vote right thank you uh
followup followup uh thank you Mr
chairman so um first thank you for this
handout I'm finding it very useful as
someone who has not had a civics lesson
on this topic so on this the back side
of the sheet you give some examples of
what these different amendments could be
in a constitutional
convention are delegates or States
typically voted on a package of
amendments or specific things like a
separate amendment that would limit that
would have term limits for
representatives and second amend another
amendment that would have term limits
for
judges okay first it's not a
constitutional convention it's an
articles convention okay uh and but yes
every particular proposal that is
discussed and and I I gave example of
items that could be discussed and
potentially turned into
amendments uh under under those three
topic areas uh every one of those would
be a separate amendment that then would
be proposed to all the states requiring
3ars of them to ratify all right thank
you other questions for the prime
representative
beler thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for bringing us this
bill
I have a question because I I'm a little
bit agnostic on the concept I don't
disagree in the least with your um
intent behind doing this but when I look
at the actual process and how it go how
to go about it and I look at for
instance Amendment one uh a Bridging the
freedom of speech well we've recently
seen a lot of censorship on the internet
that was asked for by federal government
we've see Amendment two shall not be
infringed it's feeling pretty infringed
in a lot of ways Amendment four uh
secure person's houses papers and
effects it seems like the federal
government is spying on just about
everybody all the time article 4 section
4 guarantees to each state a republican
form of government that will be
protected from Invasion so if the
Constitution is really good and I tend
to think it is really good and the
federal government just isn't following
it why does changing the letter of the
Constitution change what the federal
government is
doing well I think it boils down to uh
areas where
the Congress as well as the courts
have allowed
some fuzzy interpretations of what the
Constitution is I mean the Constitution
is what four or five pages printed out
it's it's it's a statement of key
principles uh and those amendments are a
matter of a few lines uh and so what
what do they mean uh uh you can get as I
mentioned uh the interstate commerce
clause for an example where there was a
court case that said growing wheat on
your own land for your own use impacted
interstate commerce well that gave
congress the right to do
anything that is not what was
legitimately meant by addressing
interstate commerce by the same token uh
you're talking about U you know
infringement of of
uh freedom of speech the Second
Amendment rights uh search and seizure
uh censorship I mean these are areas
that are all currently in in the court
system in various arenas
if we get bad decisions
there and and Congress goes along with
them then that could be an area for an
article 5 convention to say hey we need
to turn this back to mean this and be
much more clear and specific so it's an
opportunity to fix where these uh issues
have gone off the
rail other questions for the prime
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here sir um previously we did uh
House Bill
264 and that called for a balanced
budget and in reading your
HR it's it calls for imposed fiscal
restraints would balance budget be
included in that fiscal restraint yes as
as you noted when I on On The Backs side
of my comments I I indicate that that a
balance budget is within that broader
rubric as well as uh tax caps uh or or
other controls on government
spending thank you Mr chair other
questions representative uh buak go
ahead and then representative cber uh
quick clarification so in your next page
you I like all the goals very uh
interesting one thing that I want to
know more about it is sunset agencies
could you talk more about these what are
the agencies that you want to
Sunset these are not my proposals I'm
get what I did was list under the
concept of limit power and jurisdiction
of the federal government what are the
mechanisms that one could potentially
legitimately consider in a Convention as
the convention gets together and says
all right we we need to limit power and
jurisdiction of federal government what
powers and how and how are we going to
do it what what so if your concern is
Runway federal
agencies one of the ways one can
constrain federal agencies are Sunset
Provisions it's just it's just an
example I'm not proposing that I'm not
saying that's what we should do I'm not
saying that's what what New Hampshire
representatives to a convention should
do I'm just saying that is a kind of
thing that one could consider because
remember that convention is a
conversation of the representatives of
all the 50 states or whoever shows up to
that convention you're going to discuss
the issues you're going to thrash them
out and you're going to propose
potential amendments or decide hey
there's nothing here for us to propose
at
all representative cyber ranking
remember yeah I have a question in
regards to um ruling such as citizen
citizens united even with the
application I'm having a very hard time
seeing how we protect this process from
influence from outside entities I mean
one could say I guess that you know here
in the Le you know we we're elected by
the people and so we would be good to go
represent that but you know don't we see
a lot of money flowing around here in
conquered for certain pieces of
legislation or on behalf of certain
legislators to do certain things to
appease those special interests and I'm
talking about you know everybody up here
it's not just one side of the aisle the
other so I guess what are the plans to
protect you know that
further well there there is not a
proposal under the under this particular
uh um resolution to deal with the
federal uh financing of of Elections if
one wanted to propose a an amendment in
that regard and I think uh Wolfpack uh
is pursuing a potential amendment in
that Arena then there's then there's an
opportunity to bring that topic
discussion to a convention if if you
have the requis that two3 States agree
and thrash out an amendment proposal
that would be considered as an Amendment
of the Constitution it's it's not in
this particular
listing followup followup thank you um I
guess what I'm talking about is say a
corporation paying a delegate to you
know put a certain subject or whatever
that would benefit them in the end when
that said delegate goes to attends the
the article convention de delegates from
a state are sent by the legislature so
they're picked by the legislature
whatever process it it uh uh decides is
is appropriate and sent with a
particular point of view so I'll go back
to the Constitutional Convention New
York sent
three delegates they worked in that
convention for a period of time two two
of them decided that uh what was being
discussed was beyond the scope of what
was their remit from the state so they
left and Alexander Hamilton remained the
only one
there he so uh they didn't have the you
know the requisite Authority anymore
with only one delegate so if asking is
would a would the state send a delegate
that is then being paid under the table
by a corporation I mean that that would
seem to me a violation of you know the
the the uh the charter of a of a
commissioner going to the to the
commission other questions for the
prime uh represent Foss
thank you I actually have a followup
from representative belcher's question
um so you use the example of the
Commerce Clause and uh saying that
obviously Congress has passed many laws
based on uh their understanding of the
Commerce Clause uh and the Supreme Court
has held these up as constitutional so
if a convention were to find that
actually Congress doesn't have the
uh authority to I don't know if you if
you'd rather regulate interstate
commerce or regulate it in this manner
isn't this essentially creating a fourth
government no no it's not created it it
if if an example of interstate commerce
uh a convention uh strikes a uh an
amendment that brings the understanding
of what regulating interstate commerce
meant back to what what the original
purpose was back when the Constitution
was
created
uh what it means is this the federal
government is not going to have the
authority to pass laws in that area so
the states then are given that Authority
The Authority comes back to the states
to act on specific items and
concerns follow
up but so that essentially would act on
a check to laws that congress has
already passed Congress US Congress and
that the judicial branch has found
constitutional so this is a check on
them similar to our system of checks and
balances so but you still this would not
create a fourth branch of government
you're saying and I just don't
understand how wouldn't if it has this
check and Balance
power so if you consider the check and
balance being uh judicial legislative
and executive fine but there's another
check and balance which is federalism
federal state local control so if you
take power away from the feds who have
inappropriately taken it and the and the
and the court system said it's okay now
you pass a Constitutional Amendment say
no you don't have that Authority that
Authority
as articulated in the 10th Amendment
goes back and stays with the states so
the state has the authority to act it's
not another branch of government it's
another it's another layer of government
okay one one final
followup uh but wouldn't that be a
violation of the supremacy clause that
the federal government the federal laws
are the law of the
land and the Constitution is the supreme
law of the land and if the amendment
says
that the states have authority in this
area it's not a violation of the
supremacy CLA Clause other questions for
the prime
sponsor uh yes go ahead rep of gagy
thank you for your
Indulgence an article five convention is
that not giving the people back the
right for the laws to be for the People
by the people and of the people instead
of government
overreach absolutely I second the motion
does she hand
up uh representative Lloyd please thank
you I'll try to be brief um
so in this um If This Were to go through
and let's say that that this resolution
does come through and an an article 5
convention is called um how does New
Hampshire currently have a process in
selection I do not believe New Hampshire
has a formalized process in place that
would have to be something the
legislature would would take up and I
would expect that it would be some kind
of discussion between the start with
between the speaker and the president of
the Senate of how we're going to uh
identify who those commissioner
be seeing no further hands I want to
thank the uh Prime sponsor
representative Bernardi a wonderful
Civics discussion here for the folks
here in the room and the hundreds
hundreds watching and who will watch at
home thank you representative thank you
represent plan would you check that sign
up front we're not on U HB
264 where if if if there is an hcr3 sign
uh we can put that up if not uh we
sign by okay at this time uh I do have
uh as I said a good number of uh
speaking requests but I want to go to um
a gentleman who is a former United
States senator from Pennsylvania former
presidential candidate uh Rick santor is
uh in the house uh and our our Uh custom
here is is maybe the case in the US
Senate is is to uh try to avoid uh
Applause uh but I don't object to that
former former Senator San torm does not
object uh you've been to New Hampshire
before I believe Senator welcome back uh
the senator has asked for 15 minutes and
I think given the distance you've
traveled uh we can do that so so welcome
thank you Mr chairman and uh it is truly
an honor to uh to be here before this
committee and uh and uh to be back in
New Hampshire I only wish that uh the
committee treats me Kinder than the
voters of New Hampshire did in 2012 um
we got a lot of support but not not
quite enough uh it was uh it's great to
be here and I I I want to do my best to
try to answer maybe even some of the
questions that have been asked here I
just want to give you a little bit of a
background as to how I got involved I I
and when I was asked asked about this
issue actually it was during the 2012
campaign uh I knew nothing about it uh
I'm a lawyer I was in Congress and the
senate for 16 years and knew nothing
about Article 5 uh and really didn't
even recogn realize that that state
legislatur could propose amendments
because it was not nothing I'd ever
heard before uh and so my initial
reaction was uh as being a conservative
was uh let's just say very skeptical uh
well if it hadn't been done for 240
years why are we thinking about doing it
now and and so I really had the position
of really not being a supporter of it um
and it wasn't until later on and I I
remind the the committee that when I was
running for president in 2011 here in
New Hampshire in 12 uh the federal
deficit was Federal uh uh debt was $14
trillion I mean that doesn't seem that
long ago that I was up here campaigning
and it was 14 trillion it's 30 almost 35
36 trillion doll now every four months
we're adding a trillion
to the national debt I just ask any of
you and I don't care what side of the
Alle you on if we continue this are we
not headed to a fiscal crisis and do you
see any anybody either party I'm both
parties are guilty here do you see
either party doing anything in
Washington DC to stop the accumulation
of debt and the collapse of our
financial system does anyone believe
that's not going to
happen Okay I don't see any hands going
up so here's so when people tell me well
there's a risk if we do a Convention of
States well if the alternative is fiscal
collapse is a certainty what's the
risk if your house across the street is
burning and you have to cross the street
to put the fire out there's a risk of
crossing the
street there is their car could be
coming by it could hit you bad things
can happen if you cross a
street but if your house is burning you
cross the darn Street Ladies and
Gentlemen you know all this you know
this I mean you're the live free to die
State you know that Washington is on a
on a on a crash course whether it's
financially or whether it's the Tyranny
that we're seeing candidly from both
parties when it comes to the uh the
president and the way they wield their
pens and tell you how they're they're
going to change everything and do things
that presidents here to for never
thought they could do this is not
what we signed up for if you will as a
in this constitution people talk about
they pull out their pocket Constitution
say don't change this well it was
perfectly written it was divinely
inspired we don't have any Madison or
Franklin's or Jeffersons left in the
United States well we may not but let's
just be honest this document has been
changed it's been changed 27 times it
may have been a perfect document ment
was a darn good one and I would argue
that most people think most of the
changes are pretty darn good first 10
amendments not too many people disagree
with those right the Amendments after
the Civil War not too many people
disagree with those in fact someone
asked the question well you know we
don't follow the laws now why will we
follow them in the future look at the
Amendments we actually do follow those
we actually follow them pretty darn well
do we not limit presence to two terms
yep we follow that do women have the
right to vote well I look around here I
say the answer is yes we follow those
amendments why do we follow them we
follow them because it is darn near
andoss to pass an amendment to the
Constitution it's the hardest thing any
government any level of government is
required to do to pass anything the
hardest highest bar is to add an
amendment to the Constitution you need
three quarters of the states am imagine
if you had to get 3/4 of the house here
to pass anything oh you'd get you know
you'd name a a a park or two but
anything controversial no way you're
going to get three4 of and here's the
interesting thing someone said well you
don't need 13 states for one leg one
house of legislature to post it that's
wrong you need 13 states and one house
of legislature to do nothing they don't
have to oppose it they don't have to
vote on it what is the easiest thing I
know some of you are new members but let
me assure you the answer to this
question what is the easiest thing for
any legisl to do when it comes to an
issue
nothing right put it in your
drawer all 13 houses of of 13 different
states have to do is put it in their
drawer this is darn near impossible and
so in order to pass
something you need broad consensus if
you look at all the Amendments that have
passed a date they were overwhelming
consensus that this needed to be done
you need 75% of the states my guess is
you need 80 85% of the public to agree
to get 75% of the states to pass you
talk about a runaway
convention a convention simply does one
thing it proposes amendments tomorrow
the Congress could propose an amendment
to eliminate the First Amendment they
can do it tomorrow do you see people
running around saying oh I'm worried the
Congress might propose an amendment
that's going to take my rights away
nobody worries about that why
because it's damn near impossible to
pass anything through the legislature
they knew they wouldn't get something
like that passed do you think folks
after having worked hard to get 34
states to do the three things that
represented bernardy who did by the way
a fabulous job do you think after
working that hard to get a convention
they're going to propose things that
have no chance of passing no they're
going to propose things that have some
chance for states that may not be
excited about the topics that are at
hand would might might see a way to pass
something I use an
example people say well what would that
be would it be a balanced budget
amendment maybe I doubt a balanced
budget amendment candidly will pass 38
State legislatures at this point I doubt
it in fact I greatly doubt it that
doesn't mean we shouldn't try but I I
don't think it will happen do you think
well then what would happen the one
example I use that I still think could
could pass and something that would be
very important for the stability of our
Republic is to limit the Supreme Court
to nine
members that would prohibit either party
from packing the court and trying to do
something which I think would be against
the the interests of our country I know
Democrats might say well you know that's
because you have a majority now well
that hasn't always been the case and let
me assure you it won't always be the
case it will swing back and forth but it
will do so gradually over time and that
is the way stability works for America
and I think 38 State legislatures could
actually pass that would it be worth
doing a Convention of States just to do
that in my opinion absolutely yes for
two reasons three reasons number one the
convention the founders remember had
something in
common and people forget this but it's
true the founders were state
legislators they didn't want the power
in the federal government they knew
there needed to be more power but they
didn't want the power to go to the
federal government they wanted it at the
states so they were state legislators
and they focused on one thing they
focused on checks and balances and
particularly checking the federal
government becoming becoming a tyranical
body because they were afraid of that
they came from that and so they put all
these checks in place to make make make
sure that happened they put two
particular Provisions in that
Constitution to protect the states one
was was mentioned earlier you folks used
to pick United States senators now as
someone who's United States senator from
Pennsylvania who would never have been
picked by my legislature I'm actually
glad that's not the case anymore but the
reality is it was there so you had a
body to check Washington DC from taking
your power the Senate just so you know
most folks don't know this but prior to
the 17th amendment of 1912 in order to P
to bring up a bill in the United States
Senate you know what percentage of
senators had to agree to bring up a bill
just to vote on it
100% you know what the federal deficit
was in 1912 when the 17th amendment was
passed a buck 50 from the Spanish
American
War the federal government Washington DC
was a Backwater town that nobody paid
much attention to 70 Amendment came
changed everything people say don't
touch this constitution ution it has
been touched ladies and gentlemen it has
been touched and it's been fundamentally
changed it's shifted the power away from
you to
Washington and and Washington DC
exploded second thing that happened was
Court decisions during the New Deal
primarily that expanded all of these
provisions on the Federal Constitution
to allow ever expanding role of
government and that
continues this is not the same
Constitution people wave this around if
if you order a constitution from the
general printing office in Washington DC
do you know how big it is it's
2,600 pages that is the Constitution you
live by when people say don't touch it
it's been touched folks this is not
2,600
pages but the Constitution you live by
which is annotated by Supreme Court
decision and amendments is
2,600 Pages do you think we might be
able to touch that you think that might
be a good
idea and so the reason it's important
for you to have this call and to do this
convention is to reassert your Authority
because the second provision is the one
we're talking about was the provision to
allow you to propose amendments
everybody needs a boss everybody needs a
check you are the check to the federal
government and for 250 years you haven't
used it for 150 30 years you didn't need
it you had another check it was the
United States Senate but for the last
100 years you have you have you have not
use the check that was the emergency
check and you can make the argument that
up until the last 20 or so years you
didn't need that either but you do
now you have an obligation because you
have power
Spider-Man
right you're Spider-Man you have great
power you have great
responsibility I know state legislators
you're used to being dumped upon by the
federal government everybody telling you
how to do things how to run
things there's one good way to stop it a
good slap aside the head hey by we're
we're the bower in to new
sheriff we're gonna pass this resolution
we're going to we're going to assert our
Authority rightfully under the
Constitution you're going to be a all
this is all this Con under the Article
Five is part of the
Constitution Article 5 is your Authority
your responsibility to protect this
country don't Sher that responsibility
because I'm afraid of a runaway a
runaway what a runaway convention to
propose
amendments remember Congress can do it
today so this proposes amendments and by
the way as for the Run away because I
know that's an important issue I'm
running around be in South Dakota on
Monday we we're going to probably pass
South Dakota be the 20th estate so New
Hampshire you got to get cooking if you
want to be
20 so South Dakota will probably pass
will pass it next week we already passed
the H the Senate by big margin should
pass the
house we we we have to go around state
by state by state to get 34 states to to
ratify this thing and we're using the it
the language that you have before you is
the same language in South Dakota it was
the same in Georgia which was the first
state to passes and Arizona and Texas
and Florida and a whole bunch of other
states have already passed it it's the
same language well why are we bothering
to do that well because the language
just like when you pass a bill it has to
be the same in the house and the same in
the senate or it doesn't become law same
thing here has to be the same in all 34
states or you don't get a convention
called how do I know that because
there's been 400 calls for a convention
in the history of our country and we've
yet to have a
convention if all you needed was 34
states calling a convention and you can
go and do anything we' already have a
convention but Congress has never called
a convention why because 34 states
haven't agreed on the subject matter
convention I mean it just makes sense if
you need 34 states to agree on what the
convention's about that obvious means
something at the convention they're
limited by what the call of the
convention is
for you had a bill earlier in this
discussion talking about faithful
delegate that's another that's a belt
and suspender as the gentleman
appropriately said that's to make sure
that your state is following what you as
the legislature want which is limiting
to those three topics at least the ones
we're talking about here and maybe other
things that you want to limit to that
they have to vote for this or can't vote
for something of this that's up to you
you control the
process people say well we don't know
what the rules are there's no rules set
well the reality is there's
precedent I don't know about you but
most legislators when they come into
session have to adopt rules you guys
have to adopt rules when you come into
session okay well how do you know what
rules to adopt how do you know what
process to use you have a precedent that
when you come in you do certain things
not in the rules because you don't have
any rules but you have precedent as to
how things are done and you operate by
precedent all the time well as was
mentioned there's been 40 conventions of
states in the history of our country and
they've all run the same way there is
precedent there is one one state one
vote how do we know because we've had 40
of them and they've all been one state
one vote just like you before you adopt
your rules that President will rule
until you have a rules and then you
could you can change that at the rules
good luck there's about three times more
small states and there are big States as
population you think they're going to
give up power to the big States let me
assure you New Hampshire is not going to
do
that neither is South
Dakota I know there's a lot of panic
around this and I get it because with
uncertainty and
unfamiliarity people get nervous and
they feel like oh there's risk I need I
I'm here to try to get you
comfortable that this is not a risky
thing to do and in fact it is an
absolutely necessary thing and it's an
absolute abandonment of your
responsibility as legislators
not to intercede and do an
intervention on both parties in
Washington DC we need you and
particularly New Hampshire it's one of
the reasons I was so excited to come up
here you folks want to be first in the
nation and you are you guys want to lead
you want to you want to be the ones who
have a oversized weight on what's going
on in Washington DC
and here I'm up here pleading with you
to do that
here I would think New Hampshire would
have been first Live Free or Die protect
our rights as the state why aren't you
the first to be out here both
parties I don't get it so educate me be
happy to take your
questions yes thank you Senator uh I do
want to say that New Hampshire was ninth
to uh approve the original Constitution
which put us over the the top so we uh
perhaps we'll put you over the top with
us and time will tell Pia was second but
I'm just saying time will tell and I and
I I do want to say that uh when you did
lose the New Hampshire Primary in 2012
you lost to a gentleman who had a place
on Lake wiip I know very well so
there's that uh so I see represent mle
bomb our clerk uh go ahead thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you senator sorum
for for being here and taking my
question so I'm curious what potential
legal challenges there might be to an
amendment that is passed by by a
convention okay so again prop the
convention proposes amendments we don't
pass they don't pass it and and and all
50 states gather together each state
gets one vote 26 votes are necessary for
a an amendment to be proposed it is then
according to uh to the Constitution sent
to the states for
ratification um all but of the 27
Amendments 26 were done by the state
legislators themselves having to pass it
both houses and in the case Nebraska one
house um and and once it is adopted just
like all the prior 26 uh 27 once it's
adopted it's included in the
Constitution and therefore has the same
Force as any other provision of the
Constitution so I you know the court
will then go ahead and interpret what
that means but if it's
the court is limited to nine members I
there's not much interpretation there I
mean again it depends on the amendment
but um at least the one I'm suggesting
would not leave itself very much open to
interpretation thank you other questions
representative
Foss thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Senator sorum uh I'll Echo uh chairman
Moffet welcome back to New Hampshire and
you should come here when it's not
winter sometime I I have oh good glad to
hear it uh
so the examples that have been talked
about are generally uh or the examples
that have been used limiting uh the
power of the federal government but is
there the check to do something like
expanding the power like I say Chevron
Defence was just
overturned uh which I mean it's been a
minute since I took administrative law
in Pennsylvania uh and seems like kind
of threw the administrative law world
into a tizzy let's say um so what's to
stop a a convention from proposing an
amendment that would reinstate something
like Chevron Defence that administrative
agencies have the power to you know
essentially make laws are we are we the
only the only check there uh no the I
again I mentioned before the language of
the resolution uh would limit what is
eligible to be proposed you know
Wolfpack wants to have campaign Finance
well you can't if there if if that
happens if there's a convention on
campaign Finance limiting the spending
in Washington you can't have an abortion
Amendment be proposed it's non- gerain
and and so uh that would be ruled out of
order uh number one uh number two you
know they uh if if you look at the fact
that these states 34 of them came
together because they wanted to limit
the power of the federal government at
least 34 of those states are probably
going to vote for things that limit the
power of the federal government not
expand it I mean that that would be a
rational thing to say because at the
time that 34 is accomplished 34 states
still have to be controlled by people
who agree with this otherwise like I
know is being considered here you it
would be rescinded and then you wouldn't
get to
34 one
followup thank you uh but there's
nothing to so should this this happen in
an article 5 convention be held there's
nothing to stop me from uh introducing
another resolution that would propose uh
an amendment to enshrine abortion a
affirmative right to abortion in the
Constitution so uh there there's no
there's no stop Gap there that it seems
like this would set quite the
Precedence well any delegate could come
forward and obviously they they have the
right to say anything and propose
anything uh but that doesn't mean that
the I mean you have the right to propose
all sorts of things here in the
legislature and that doesn't mean it's
going to pass and um in this case it it
will not be it will not be considered it
would be considered out of order because
it's not Germaine to the subject matter
of the convention and so it would be it
would be dismissed for that reason I
think it would also probably fail
because there wouldn't be sufficient
votes for it to to happen but but by by
order of the like I said if you need 34
states to come together and agree on the
exact language that language has meaning
and the meaning is that that the
convention is limited to those things
and so anything that is outside the
scope of that would be considered out of
order and not not be eligible to vote
and then we mentioned before and you
have here the faithful delegate bill you
would be an faithful delegate if if New
Hampshire would pass a law that said
that you have to limit the areas of
discussion to the things that are in the
in the call for the convention and you
don't do so then you'd be in violation
of that that's one of the reasons I'm
supporting the faithful delegate bill
and I think mentioned before about half
the states have already passed something
like that because they don't want people
going to these conventions that are
limited to certain things and
introducing other issues they want to
keep it to the subject matter because
that's what they promised the people
they would do when they passed it you
know when you make a vote it's a promise
you're you're you're you're you're
saying to the people of the state this
is what we're going to do we promise
that we will uphold the the the language
the resolution or the or the statute
that we passed and you would be
violating that and you would be subject
to penalties as a result as an
individual delegate the questions uh
representative cyber yeah I just wanted
to go back to your um example there that
you had in regards so like say the topic
is um campaign
Finance Could you actually underneath
that because it is still under campaign
Finance say like as you were like do you
know campaign Finance um for pro-choice
or something like that again I'm not
advocating for campaign finance that oh
no I understand that I'm just so I'm not
an expert on what I don't even know what
their language says specifically so I
really can't answer that question I I
can tell you with respect to the
language we have they're all very clear
as their limiting it's limiting language
it's it's to it's to reduce the power of
the federal government is not to expand
the power of the federal government and
and and uh and so that's that's that's
how that's how our language works I
can't speak to theirs okay thank you any
other questions representative Lloyd
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question thank you um can you
better can you understand a little bit
of my
or can you understand a little bit of my
concern here in that New Hampshire does
not have a defined uh delegate selection
process and how I'm concerned with this
potentially having a very partisan slant
should this be taken up and and come to
pass um to use your example of the
Supreme Court situation um couldn't a
delegate also uh create uh uh or use a
convention to force a hearing for a
Supreme Court to uh uh appointee to
happen in a timely manner propos when
it's proposed by the sitting president I
mean like there are there's a lot of
partisan slant to this and I I guess my
concern would be the delegate selection
process and making sure that every voice
is
represented yeah um about a dozen states
have passed delegate selection uh
procedures and and all of them the
legislators basically determine who the
who the folks are and I would you know
our expectation is I think most people's
expectation is that the legislature
would appoint
legislators uh now there may be some
people outside the legislature that
could be appointed but by and large uh
we suspect that legislators seeing this
as their responsibility would would
would put some of their colleagues
forward and as far as the partisan
breakup I mean every State's going to be
different as to as to how they how they
do that and the numbers some states have
uh have I think seven or eight some have
six some have five I mean there's
they're all over the place as far as the
number is concerned but it's it is the
decision by you and you as as a as a
legislator will have the opportunity to
weigh in on that and try to influence
how that process works again you folks
control the whole
process other questions represent
Jones Thank you Mr chair and
Senator thank you so much for being here
come welcome back to New Hampshire
you're always a we of information thank
you um and mine is a simple question the
one vote concept that's great for New
Hampshire but wouldn't uh California and
New York and and so on say that's not
full
representation well I I just go back I
mean you mentioned California uh
California has been involved with um
with conventions of states in the past
uh the Colorado River compact which
allocates water for the Colorado River
was done through a Convention of States
each state passed a resolution to um to
appoint Commissioners uh all all the
States involved appointed Commissioners
they were sent uh they they they each
had Commissioners come more than one
they all gather together they came up
with an idea and then went back to the
States California didn't complain they
had one vote and Utah had one vote uh
why because if you look at the language
I mean it's a Convention of States it's
not a convention it's not a delegate
convention it's a Convention of States
each state is a sovereign entity and so
they may complain about it but as I
mentioned before the precedent is one
state one vote that's how it would begin
there would be a rules package that we'
be adopted and I maybe at maybe
California and New York would say well
we want you know uh states to be uh
based the votes to be based on
population well there'd be about 38 or
39 states that would say no because they
would be at a disadvantage there are
only a handful of states that have huge
populations and they are not going to I
guarantee you I I None of the small
states are going to give up that that uh
privilege other questions thank you
Senator representative
Bennett thank you for taking my question
um I am I'm kind of new so thank you for
coming here um I'm just curious about
your timetable like um I know you can't
pinpoint who's going to do what but I'm
sure you have a projection of you know
how you think this is going to play out
so I just wondering like are you
thinking a year two years yeah I wish I
wish I was that smart uh I one of the
things I've learned a long time ago is
um projecting how state legislator are
going to behave is really a risky
business I don't think you'll feel see
anybody at Caesars putting odds up on on
things like that at I mean there are
several States I mentioned South Dakota
I mean South Dakota you would have
thought was a state that would have
passed this a long long time ago and um
and you know Wisconsin passed it I mean
Wisconsin's you know a very very purple
State and yet it passed it and some of
the reddest states have not um and so
it's it it is it's a hard thing to
figure um uh the answer is it's not
going to be this in the next couple of
years uh and and unlikely to be the next
three or four years but I I it's going
to take I hate to say it things have to
continue to keep getting as getting
worse and the worse it gets the more
people are saying okay really don't have
a choice here we've got to do something
we need an intervention and um and I I
think we're going to pick up at least
I'm very hopeful we uh we'll pick up
three or four states this year uh and
hopefully that'll build some momentum
any other questions uh representative
cure thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for being here thank you you
made a good case I think I uh I am
somewhat swayed but I do have a little b
a question yeah you made the case that
we're heading for a real fiscal crisis I
don't
disagree you also made the case that
it's very unlikely that a balanced
budget amendment would be able to make
it through given the constraints that
exist under Article 5 I also don't
disagree so given that is there a reason
that we ought to look at the artical 5
process rather than say the process
outlined by Madison nullification and
interposition yeah I look first off
nullification is been been debated and
and lost and we fought a war over it and
it didn't go very well for the
nullifiers uh I don't think that's a
that's a a path that is going to be a
fruitful path for uh uh for resolving
the problems that we have today uh and I
mentioned before one of the biggest
reasons I am personally for this is just
doing it even if nothing happens even if
you don't if you propose amendments none
of them are
ratified what you've done is you've
you've told the Congress and the
president there's a sheriff in town that
you guys actually are willing to use the
power given to you to draw imagine I
think people don't really realze how how
much of a deal this would be we've never
done this in the history of the country
can you imagine the attention nationally
this will get this will be a huge deal
this will be covered wall toall there'll
be all sorts of attention on what
federalism the role of the states when
it comes to the federal government where
power should be allocated where is it
best
placed there'll be movements behind
different
amendments will there be money behind it
sure I'm sure there'll be money behind
but there'll be money behind good things
and probably bad things things you agree
with and things you don't there's always
money involved why because there's power
involved there's power involved money's
going to be involved but it's all going
to be the beauty of this will be out in
the open it'll be a transparent process
there'll be a national debate and you
folks will be at the center of it not
congress not Washington you folks will
be educating the American public about
federalism about what the imagine if our
kids in in school had to actually learn
what the Constitution
said right and and had and we had a
national discussion about what what
Washington should do and what's best
left at the state or what's best left to
the
people that in itself that educational
process and that new sheriff in town
process tells me more than anything else
Washington there is there is absolutely
no governor on what every member of con
I don't care how conservative you are
you get there and you got people in your
office you know this
how many people in your office come here
and say I wish youd do less of this or
don't spend as much money on this nobody
does nobody does in in the in conquered
and let me assure you nobody does in
Washington and they tell and they ask us
to do things that we have no
constitutional authority to do but we
don't want to say
no this changes the game because once
you do it and once every all the fears
are swept away that it runs orderly and
you propose amendments maybe some pass
maybe they don't guess what you can do
Congress gets out of line again or
doesn't start addressing the issues you
address you say you know what we're
coming
back you are supposed to be a player on
enough why because you are closest to
the people there is nobody closer to the
people than you 400 of you immeasurably
close to the
people and we need you
in Washington thank you Senator seeing
no other hands up uh I do want to thank
you again uh former US senator uh we
don't get that many in here our new
governor by the way is a former US
senator oh I know I sered with her yes
and uh I before we lose you uh as a
senator from Pennsylvania uh by the way
she has Pennsylvania ties we're very
proud of that as a Penn stator so she uh
was a a Keystone State resident at one
time as a student
uh as a former US senator from
Pennsylvania did you go to the Steelers
or the Eagles I'm a western Pennsylvania
guy so that should probably answer your
question so
I'm okay but I root for the Eagles
because I represented Philadelphia so
I'm I'm for them to uh for the Super
Bowl well the Eagles did beat the
Patriots one year but we need to move on
thank you so much senator for your time
pleasure okay uh we have 15 cards we're
going to uh let everyone have time to
speak uh we're going to have to uh by
uh by uh the reality of time uh limit
subsequent speakers to two minutes or
less our vice chair represent Rollins
when when you are coming up on two
minutes will'll wave his hat or give you
a signal because we want to let everyone
have a chance to
speak uh seconds before uh 15 seconds
before he'll give you the he some of you
have only asked for a minute and uh and
that's fine so uh we're going to have to
do that to make sure everybody gets a
chance to speak uh so let's go right to
uh representative
ulery is uh representative YY still here
is nowhere near as eloquent and I'll be
much more brief uh in listening to the
testimony thus far there appears to be
some confusion HB 264 regulates the
delegates to a convention for the
purpose of proposing amendments does not
establish or have any other except uh
restriction on who is a delegate
delegate uh also delegate selection is
present is made by the body that is the
general court in New Hampshire it may be
the legislature in Nebraska or Kansas
whichever has a uni camera on one or the
two bodies meeting together in joint
convention in most cases and for most um
application standard State
compacts a Convention of states is not
another form of government it is only a
convention to propose substantially
similar proposals for example you have a
soccer game if you have a soccer game
you could bring a black and white ball
you could bring a yellow and black ball
you could bring a yellow and white ball
but you're bringing a soccer ball you
bring a
football you're not ex unless you're
playing Australian rules and we're not
in
Australia you're not going to be able to
play the foot play in that game because
you brought a football to a soccer game
which is why the purpose of establishing
the convention is is made by the
legislature the miracle of Article 5 is
that there is is a method for congress
big government to propose
amendments and for the other onethird of
the federalism that is the state
governments which are directly elected
by the
people to propose amendments to the
foundation
document thank
you thank you representative I'm not
going to ask if everybody needs wants to
ask a question if any rep or any uh
member of the committee wants to ask a
question go ahead and sound off if you
have a Salient important question uh
please do otherwise uh we will uh try to
let everybody have a chance to to weigh
in uh representative Timothy Horan is
here he opposes the bill uh welcome
representative
Horan he opposes the resolution hcr3
it's not a bill yes um so I'm I'm resent
Timothy Timothy Horan from straford
County District 10 so Senator sanor
that's a hard act to follow I've never
been a US senator or run for president
or been a CNN commentator so uh I'm not
not quite as polished as he is and
probably not even as polished as
represent ery so um I mostly came here
this morning to speak in favor of the
next bill but this is a flip side of the
same thing so I think uh a con you know
an article 5 constitutional convention
is a bad idea I mean it probably doesn't
not as bad given the chaos in Washington
DC you know it's better it's probably
better than trying to amend the
Constitution by uh passing have the
president signing executive orders but
it's it's a bad idea and as written this
this um convention would inevitably
inevitably run away because it's uh
scope is scope is so broad you know just
about everything is related to something
that's in that and we're talking about
uh the delegates selection process
that's actually not for the states to
determine the Congress will pass an
enabling act um they've never needed to
uh send one to the president's desk but
some have been considered in the past
and they've always
uh there's a good possibility they might
have a direct election of of the
delegates and certainly the delegates
would have the same rights as a members
of Congress this convention would have
essentially be a third branch of a third
congression a third chamber of Cong
Congress so they would have the same
rights that US Representative Senators
do and that uh does not extend to the
state being able to recall them if they
vote the wrong way and thank you
representative and we look forward to
hearing you speak to the next measure
yeah uh once we get through this one
yeah I have a hard stop at 12:30 so we
may not get through them all but if
everybody keeps it to two minutes like
I've just failed to do um I guess we'll
be there by about noon so
thank uh honorable Scott Wallace former
representative is in the house welcome
back uh representative Wallace uh who
measure thank you chairman Moffett
members of the committee for the record
my name is Scott Wallace uh representing
myself from the town of
Danville um I'll read a little bit
faster considering the time constraints
hcr3 deserves your support an article 5
convention is the people's way to amend
the US Constitution when a Runway
Congress will not do its constitutional
Duty historically Congress has refused
to heal itself unless and until the
people have made their discontent plane
by aggregating sufficient support for
amening the US Constitution this is most
effectively done by the aggregation of
Article Five petitions from the several
States I suggest that the people of New
Hampshire in the United States spoke
loud and clear of their desires to reign
in a Runway Federal Leviathan by their
choices at the ballot boxes last
November the federal government uses
unfunded mandates to effectively control
State legislatures local governments and
we the people they insert themselves
into America's most personal decisions
and they have destroyed our nation's
fiscal security New Hampshire has a
balanced budget amendment petition
waiting to be acted upon we are all well
aware that the impending debt crisis is
a Sword of Damocles hanging over
taxpayers heads it's time to bring their
tyranny to an end and a Convention of
states is the way to do it we have long
talked about the split between the
establish establishment policy itics and
agitators the agitators unseated former
house Speaker McCarthy by supporting
Mike Johnson given the establishment a
painful lesson agitators will only be
ignored for so long the American voters
have just delivered part two of this
lesson to the dumbstruck political
establishment for both parties part two
is simple the class of agitators is much
larger than you thought we consist of
workingclass Americans across the
Nations and our patience has run
out both parties are scrambling to
figure out what the wave of populism
means for the future and what
adjustments must be made in light of the
new political realities let's be honest
District of Columbia politicians are
more DC politicians than anything else
the chances are extremely high they'll
get it wrong if they get it at all here
amongst the Grassroots is how elected
officials in both the states and the
federal government can get it right and
why we must not get it wrong the
American people want their power back
passing hcr3 would be a step in that
direction Mason had it right when he
included a way for the new PE for the
people to reassert control of the
federal government we know New
Hampshire's people no longer trust their
government at the federal level we want
to govern ourselves again at the state
and local level we are tired of watching
a money gobling District of Columbia
machine crank out policies that don't
work don't help and don't line up with
what the Constitution says the federal
government should and should not be
doing thank you uh Senator Senators
thank you former representative Wallace
uh we need to move on understood I'll be
happy to take any questions as I said
earlier if somebody has a a question
that screams to be asked please do I've
been pushing this for a dozen years and
formerly the prime sponsor of this
resolution and faithful delegate two or
three times historically in the last
decade so I'm pretty well read on this
subject yes for former rep
representative Wallace is a resource
he's been involved with this before he's
been here
before uh okay uh speaking of senators
we have another former Senator uh former
state senator who's asked for one minute
uh welcome back Senator Jim Rubin thank
you Mr chairman and members of the
committee Jim Rubin formerly state
senator from District 5 and also the uh
a board member and War Room director of
the federal fiscal sustainability
Foundation we're the leading uh National
Organization seeking a single subject
fiscal responsibility Amendment to the
US Constitution and we speak uh on on
behalf of of the federal fiscal
sustainability foundation in
wholehearted support of uh this
resolution the cosos resolution just
going to differ with Senator Santorum in
two places modest difference because we
wholeheartedly support this resolution
number one it would likely be uh deemed
germine should a proposal come up to the
floor of an amending convention on the
subject of limitation on federal power a
uh a proposal to limit to allow State
limitations on campaign money I also
serve on the board of American promise
the leading organization seeking a
congressionally drafted uh campaign
money limits bill so again right now the
Supreme Court has ruled that the states
do not have power to limit campaign
money in most places uh except for
direct contributions to candidates uh we
perceive that that would be
U deemed Germain on the floor of an
amending conv vention under the
limitations of federal power second um I
think a uh fiscal responsibility
Amendment would pass it's supported by
super majorities of Voters of all
political Persuasions left and right
everyone knows we've got a fiscal
problem in our government uh the polling
shows this and while a balanced budget
amendment might not pass a more flexible
fiscal responsibility amendment that
allows for the growth of the government
Etc would likely pass thank
you thank you
Senator Sam Felman is still here in the
house uh welcome back uh Sam Mr fieldman
two uh thank you chairman MAF
representative of the Committees I'm
here uh as a volunteer with Wolfpack and
uh I'm testifying neutral on this
resolution um you should pass or or U
reject it based on your view of the
policies that it abdicates uh not based
on the Article 5 convention procedure
itself um I want to offer myself up to
the committee as uh one of the leading
experts in the country on the convention
process uh to help you understand that
aspect of it um there there are multiple
Protections in this process there's
roles to be played with the federalism
and separation of power system designed
by our Founders roles to be played for
the Congress the courts the states and
the delegates um each one of those uh
have uh interplay between them creating
numerous uh protections over this
process uh ones Beyond those that were
originally explicitly written in uh such
as the um the uh ratification of three
quarters um there and specifically as an
example I want to speak to some of the
things that have been brought off by
representative C Burton uh
representative Lloyd um when I in terms
of delegate selection and and
regulations over them um the
when uh when there was a ratif
ratification convention for the 21st
amendment uh none of the states had res
had bills in place to choose their
delegates to those ratification
conventions those were all passed very
quickly the whole process went off very
easily it would be better if states did
that in advance which is why I advocated
for such a bill that this committee and
the house passed last year and I hope
that the full uh body will pass that
soon um but even without that that is
still in place um in addition the
delegates when they're chosen for
specific purpose that does help add an
additional level of protection that they
will serve for that purpose it is an
extra protection when that purpose is
campaign Finance which is uh a
protection that you get with the
resolution that Wolfpack advocates for
which is not in place here then campaign
Finance uh violations tend to hurt those
people rather than help uh but it is
still a protection that it's single
subject and thank you for speaking to
representative cyber representative
Lloyd's uh question uh I have a quick
one for you before you step away uh 21st
Amendment rescinded the 18th Amendment
the prohibition one yes was there a
movement uh for a Convention of the
states uh that led to the 21st amendment
that maybe can you speak to that real
quick or do you know yes yes the there
was a a an effort to um get an article 5
convention for that purpose it was not a
significant part of it but was um it was
I I advocated pretty um uh pretty well
there there was at one point the um the
representative in New York who uh who
got it passed in New York um got a
standing ovation when it was uh when
they voted in favor of it um because the
people were so in favor of it but
ultimately um there was the way that
that got passed was through a massive
organizing effort uh primarily from a
group called women's Organization for
national prohibition reform and Wolfpack
has learned a tremendous amount from
that organization's history in terms of
how we're redesigning our approach and
trying to get the amendment through the
use of the convention process as well as
other tools got it thank you thank you
so much thank you Joshua Skinner from
Farmington is here and he supports the
measure the house concurrent resolution
[Music]
good morning chairman Mett morning
committee uh my name is Joshua Skinner
I'm a proud native of of New Hampshire
and a disabled Army Combat veteran I'm
here today to testify in support of
Article 5 of the convention of States
because I swore an oath to the whole
Constitution and everything in
it uh these words set the standard for
sorry a government instituted among men
deres its Power by the consent of the
people to be governed uh it's a contract
that the government shall preserve and
enforce the rights afforded to we the
people of the United States the
Declaration of Independence clearly
states that whenever any form of
government becomes destructed of these
ends it is the right of the people to
alter abolish it Institute new
government these words set the standard
for Liberty and freedom around the world
these words filled me with a pride and
courage when I shipped off to
Afghanistan to defend the country uh to
defend the nation in the time of need at
the age of 18 it's a circumvention in
disregard for the constitution of
corruption within our government that is
a problem and my concern the American
people deserve better so to the families
of those that gave the ultimate
sacrifice for this nation my brothers
and sisters and the arms that fought and
bled for two decades just to witness the
abomination of the withdrawal from the
Afghanistan we deserve a government that
isn't so out of touch in respond to the
people I support Article 5 convention
States because it gives We the People a
way to stifle this long too encroaching
tyranny it gives more power back to the
States and the people and will be a
direction the authors of our
constitution knew all too well of the
dangers of the government obtaining too
much power and that the people needed a
recourse of action if this should arise
in the future Article 5 was the only
amendment that was unanimously adopted
by the authors some of you served in the
military and I also you also took the
same moth I did to our
constitution so once again do we take an
oath to our constitution with everything
in it or do we just pick and choose what
amendments that we support we the people
that are already aware they understand
and understand Article 5 want it and we
are asking for you to pass this to the
floor for an honest vote we are simply
exercising our constitutional right to
process amendments to this existing
Constitution and that are aimed to
benefit the American people the common
fear-mongering of a Runway convention
are absurd and just can't happen Article
5 is a limited Convention of the states
to only propose amendments to this
existing Constitution at the convention
only the topics that are on the
applications are subject to discussion
anything outside the scope of these
three topics is out of
order thank you for that we need to move
on uh the the points you just made we
we've heard before but thank you for
emphasizing those and also uh thank you
not only for your words but for your
service this is a uh the the house
committee on state federal relations and
veterans Affairs so thank you for being
here and thank you for your service
you Nathan Marston from
welcome my name is Nathan Marston and I
live in the Town of
Chester I'm here today to express my
deep concern for this nation's future
our federal government has gone out of
control and if not corrected will soon
end in Failure Article 5 of the US
Constitution is the only process to fix
this problem Article 5 allows the states
to propose amendments that will limit
government overreach federal debt and
impose term limits on Congress when the
Constitution was written elected
officials were expected to be General
citizens who would represent their
communities over time Congress has
become a place to make a career rather
than to Serve the
People additionally the Constitution was
formed with the idea of many bodies of
government however the federal
government constantly takes power away
from the states furthermore the national
debt has scaled to stagger in 36
trillion climbing at a rate of $1
million every 20 seconds if broken down
by state New Hampshire alone would owe
728 b400
million Daniel Webster stated there's no
Nation on Earth powerful enough to
accomplish our overthrow our destruction
should it come at all will be from
another quarter from the inattention of
the people to the concerns of their
government from their carelessness and
negligence he referred to the government
as the people's government made for the
people made by the people and answerable
to the people it is time that we the
people make Washington answer to us our
founding fathers knew that the federal
government would grow too large and
eventually no longer care about its
residents that is why they gave us
Article 5 so we could prevent it from
becoming
tyrannical thank you so much for that
right on time uh Bob Hansen Mr Hansen
who here earlier he's still is he's he's
still here yes W uh welcome back uh if
you can take a couple minutes uh Mr
Hansen um something large I'll pass this
around for copies afterwards excellent
all
right I I I was going to change I was
going to talk about because I think
there's a big education process that
took place
today the Constitution is very well
organized and the first 4,000 words talk
about the structure of the government
the Senate the house the president the
uh Supreme Court then we get down to
Article Five Article 5 is only one
sentence long it's the only part of the
Constitution where the state legislature
is referred to and I would ask you
people after today go home tonight go
home this weekend find the
Constitution down to Article 5 and put
your finger on it where it talks about
the state legislature you have a duty
you have have you have the authority to
do something that totally bypasses
Congress uh it we're going through the
committee it's expected that this bill
is going to be voted on by the entire
house and by the entire Senate we're
going to have to go through the Senate
also but I just ask you to go through
put your finger on it get your spouse
together get your child get your
children and say look at this the
founding fathers had trust in me I'm I'm
that person on the
Constitution they're putting their trust
and confidence in me that I'm going to
follow through when we have to break the
glass for the Emergency it's time to do
it so i' ask you all to pass this
resolution and take care of your duty
one other thing I'm the Veterans
Coalition
director uh for the convention of states
in New Hampshire Joshua Skinner was up
here earlier he's one of about 1,00
veterans that are also supporting this
movement thank you for your time and
you're a veteran it sounds like yes I I
my father and my grandfather were both
Navy veterans I enlisted in the Navy in
the Vietnam era I took the same oath as
you did in there it said support defend
the Constitution that's why I got
involved I started saying what can I do
I'm really upset with what happened and
went through the Constitution I couldn't
find anything where I could do it as an
individual other didn't vote and the
section on the
uh legislators being able to propose an
amendments opened up my eyes and that's
how I got involved in this
thank you for testimony and thank you
to Carol petus witz is back she'd asked
for 3 minutes and 42 seconds uh she'd
asked for 56 seconds
earlier
uh obviously you've timed yourself out
uh if you can time that down slightly uh
thank you so much we all agree that
Civics education is lacking in America
as you have demonstrated your love of
country when you raised and spent your
own money on your campaign and gave of
your time to knock doors and have
meetings with your constituents to get
elected you now have the opportunity to
live up to your great character by
passing hcr3 you're providing Americans
an opportunity to get caught up with
their civic education once 34
resolutions are passed all citizens
young and old alike will bear witness to
history in the making they will learn
firsthand starting with your leadership
how checks and balances work within our
constit constitutional republic vertical
and horizontal when your constituents
see how much you do care for them that
you are willing to use the most powerful
check and balance Article 5 and you are
willing to defend their unenumerated
inali rights they too will receive that
transfer of civics education they will
know what you knew when you passed HC
cr3 that article 5 is the only way to
return the federal government to its
jurisdictional
Lane I gave you guys a packet and it's
very uh information to help support you
and your constituents feel free to share
it with your seatmates in legislative
Hall and with your Senator friends
across the aisle and if you need any
more don't hesitate to ask the first one
is about the map of the 19 states that
have pass the exact resolution that
you're looking at today it shows the
people that voted and you can see that
it's evidence of the nonpartisan support
this information supports that you what
you are living up to your constituents
expectations shown that the last
presidential election the people don't
want a party they want a political
All-American policy that benefits
everyone next is the double-sided
document showing those 42 Interstate
conventions and it's showing the
evidence of why the founders did not
write the how-tos of all the details of
Article 5 just like they didn't write
the how choose on the trial by juries
they knew how to run Interstate
conventions just like we know how to run
them today there's some court cases so
you can see how that's been all worked
out with how the usage of Article 5 is
and then there of course is the history
of the calls and commissions of the
original Constitutional Convention of
1787 and of course as a bonus I gave you
an outline of the Constitution at a
glance because that's helpful to keep on
hand thank you for always remembering
that United as a New Hampshire
legislator your only function is to
protect and Def defend your constituents
unenumerated inali rights passing HDR 3
is one way to fulfill that mission I
look forward to the fruits of any
proposals returning to the word smithing
convention for your ratification and I'm
grateful that the Hope hcr3 provides
will not only restore the structural
boundaries of the federal government for
me and my posterity but also increase
your power to do greater good for New
Hampshire thank you thank you very much
for that very organized testimony and
for the handouts and I appreciate your
reference to Civics education I think
this whole hearing has been I think a
wonderful civics lesson for for the uh
many people that are watching who and
who will watch okay Margaret
Tully welcome Margaret Miss telly from
Manchester correct correct supporting
the measure yes and today what I'd like
to talk about is the character of the
people today and can it measure up to
the founders and the framers of the
Constitution and the greatest people in
the world have all risen from humble
beginnings and we have Abraham Lincoln
and Abraham Lincoln's father had no idea
that Abraham Lincoln would be Abraham
Lincoln nor did Susan B Anthony's mother
expect her to be Susan B Anthony or
Martin Luther King's father or mother
expect them to be so great so I don't
want anybody to say that the character
of the people today aren't what the
character used to be and the second
thing I'd like to talk about about is
the ultimate sacrifice and when all of
us are stepping up in order to do great
things um one of them is the Veterans
and whenever we pass a grave there's you
know the flags flying over that or you
know placed on that grave and they gave
the ultimate sacrifice and they didn't
pick and choose what part of the
Constitution they were going to endorse
and I think when I think that's a very
um precedent to as go forward and the
other thing that I want to talk about
which is something that just recently um
happened is we don't know who's going to
come into the world and change the world
and I really want to talk about a bishop
um he's an Archbishop um Fulton Sheen
and he died in 1979 and he was a bishop
out of New York and he um had a
television show I don't know if
everybody remembers who he is but I grew
up with him and recently he has been on
his way to his sainthood and with that
you have your first miracle and there's
three Miracles that you have to do to
become a saint so the first miracle was
a baby born in Southern Illinois which
is where he was from and with that the
baby was born still born or the or the
umbilical cord was around her neck
there's a couple of different stories
but the baby was um 61 minutes dead and
it came back to life and so that is what
made him become uh vener going past the
first thing of a saint so I just want to
say and that's in our you know we
remember who he is so I just want to say
we just don't know who's coming down the
path who's going to change the world or
who's going to be the next Saint thank
you thank you very much I think
representative gagy and I rep remember
yes Paul
kery uh go
ahead yeah clarifying question uh from
the clerk thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you Miss Tully could you just
clarify how you spell your first
you and Paul PA L correct correct okay c
y like Drew not Jim Jim has two RS
anyway I appreciate the time here this
morning you've heard a lot of um Civic
uh information and and education which
redacted most of my document but anyway
I'm going to speak on the three items
that are in the HR hdf 3 and that's the
uh number one for me a term limits for
congress and federal employees I'm going
to give three anecdotes real
quick on January 20 on January 3rd 2025
Senator Mitch McConnell was starting his
40th year in the Senate republican from
Kentucky likewise Democrat from
California former Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi was starting her 40th year
in Congress
and not to mention the uh Federal
bureaucracy Dr Anthony fouy joined the
National Institute of allergy and
infectious diseases in
1974 okay he was promoted to director in
1984 might not mean anything to anybody
but seems like there's a lot of
entrenchment in Washington
DC one of the things that
um I tried to do for my local town is we
have C petitions we're in sb2 town in
Sandown is where I live and I I put
forward a petition War an article to
have little town of Sandown urge the
legislature to urge the Congress to
accept the Article 5 Convention of
states and this was before resolution HC
hcr3 was was put forward so it's really
AR propo and tomorrow is our
deliberative session for those that know
about sb2 and so I'm sorry I have to
interrupt you uh Senator Rubin is here
and he's uh sitting right behind you to
your left and I believe he's the uh Prim
mover behind the establishment of SP2 so
if you like it you can thank him okay
and if you don't like it you can talk to
him uh but the the huge ballots are a
problem but you know whatever you know
it is what it is anyway I'll give you
another minute okay we'll have our we'll
have our deliberative session I have a
presentation I also brought these from
the National Organization these are uh
pocket guides to the Article 5 I brought
15 of them if anybody I actually brought
15 but I had Senator Santorum sign one
he's in the book so if anybody wants one
I'd be happy to give one I have a
presentation tomorrow in Sandown but
most of what I have written down was
said uh lastly and you stole my thunder
Mr chairman New Hampshire was the ninth
state to ratify the US Constitution
which made it in force for the first
nine states I'd like New Hampshire to be
a part of this historic
decision which you heard me say to
Senator Santorum correct so you were
listening thank you so
much uh anybody want for your uh
testimony okay I have uh we still have
four more cards
uh Linda Curran from lender Linda
welcome uh has some written testimony
according to your card and she supports
yes my name is Linda Kin I'm the state
um Grassroots coordinator for Convention
of states and um I'm from London during
um most of what I was uh prepared today
has already been covered so I'd just
like to say that I believe that as
Citizens we have a duty to course
correct the shortcomings now observed in
the federal government and as our
Representatives we pass that Duty on to
you we ask that you vote favorably on a
resolution that will allow delegates
from New Hampshire to participate in a
50-state conversation on how we can
amend the Constitution to reign in the
federal government's overreach restrain
it financially and enact term limits
wherever they may be
warranted uh we respectfully request
that you pass hcr3 out of committee for
a full vote of the house and let all the
voices in New Hampshire
heard and we just heard your voice and
thank you so much for coming up here you
for from
loose from the beautiful town of
Hancock Route 202 goes to Hancock is
that close close to there or sorry Route
202 is that yeah it's close definitely
yeah Peterboro that general area yeah
it's a a pleasure to be here an honor to
be here uh thank you chairman Moffett
and everyone present and appreciate your
patience I'm trying uh to avoid
repeating because I'm sure you've been
hearing many of the same uh points over
and over my name is John loose I'm a
volunteer I'm now the director of
Convention of States action in New
Hampshire uh and I do not claim to be an
expert on this topic uh I am pretty
passionate about the topic and I'm
cramming like I'm expecting a big exam
tomorrow to be able to learn more and
more about this this has been a great
Civics uh uh lesson so I want to just uh
Begin by reading what the late Senator
Tom Coburn who was a big supporter of
convention States said um and he by the
way was somebody who reached across the
aisle he had friends on on each side of
the aisle if there's one thing that
Americans have always agreed on it said
government functions best when decisions
are made closest to the people
and he says only through a Convention of
States May the clear unfettered voice of
the people be heard and overreaching
government be reigned in so you all are
the closest to the people and one of the
reasons why I think this is uh to be
past hcr3 is because you actually are
are so close your constituents can
actually meet with you uh they can talk
to you you're interacting with them uh
there's a great deal of advantage to
that and Convention of states is
basically we're a big tent I we're a
Grassroots Movement we have 5 million
people across the across the entire
country uh there's over 16 or excuse me
there about 16,000 petition signers in
New Hampshire alone uh so you can see
the level of support that we've got and
I think that I'm not going to review any
of the stuff that we've gone over uh we
are concerned about the imperial
presidency that's going on uh that's
acred powers and we see all these edicts
that are being issued it doesn't make
any difference whether you're a
Republican or a Democrat we know that in
four years time that can be reversed
very quickly 180 degrees uh so that's
one of the reasons why we need to have
something like a Convention of States
now I passed this out to some of you I'm
not sure if you all have this but there
was a national poll and I think this is
really important for you to understand
uh first of all 68% of Americans back a
meeting of the states to propose
amendments for fiscal responsibility
limits on federal power and term limits
that's
68% 59% of Americans trust state
legislators more than Congress that's
you they trust you because you are close
to them and therefore uh actually I
think Congress only has like a 17% uh uh
uh approval rating 71% of Americans
believe additional limits on federal
power are needed 88% of Americans can
support term limits for career
politicians that's what got me
involved and if you look at the voter
breakdown on this particular poll and I
will be happy to pass this out to you
it's uh 38%
Democrats 37%
Republicans 18%
Independents 7%
unaffiliated so we're a big tent I think
uh we have to try to strive to
meet common ground
and I do request uh that we respectfully
request that you pass this application
out of committee for full vote of the
house we see it as critical for this
committee to not restrict our
constitutional rights without a debate
before the entire house to Simply send
representatives to propose amendments
with other states thank you very
much thank you Mr loose
great uh Madam clerk uh thank you Mr
chairman um I'm sorry excuse me
uh Mr loose would you want to submit a
copy of that document you have there for
the record yes I surely will I'll bring
it up to the you thank you thank you
madam
clerk Gus G Stratton from Brookfield Gus
welcome Mr Mr uh
Stratton from Brookfield supports the
hcr3 hi thank you after so many of my
team members have hit home runs I feel
like Pedro Martinez taking a net bat
in any event uh I'm a retired physician
and uh as a physician we have to take an
oath uh when we graduate it's called the
hypocritic
oath and uh and one of the most
important admonitions of that oath is Do
no
harm and uh the way I've looked at uh
Article Five it's I see it as a tool as
a remedy and it's clear that there are
uh many many signs and symptoms in our
society today in the economy where there
is uh significant males and I see
Article 5 as a uh a remedy and I'm
hoping to appeal to your uh sense of
Ethics because I know you all swear to
the constitution of New Hampshire and to
the United States and uh I'm hoping that
in your decision you
examine uh Article 5 as as its uh tool
function and as a remedial remedy
function in trying to uh help address
these uh males in the economy and in the
society at large and um that's all I can
say thank you thank you who so much and
thank you for the sports
metaphor which we
appreciated okay uh I have the last pink
card in my hand now uh so uh to stay
with sports bat and cleanup after uh 16
or 17 speakers is Joe trelli still
here yes welcome Joe if there's anything
is not yet been said here here's your
book this is hard to get used
to thank you again oh I just lost my
clock thank you again for uh having this
ability to discuss pros and cons on
things and it's part of not only why
we're in New Hampshire but also
America so I have been uh listening
carefully to the previous
testimony um from the various folks that
have been here and I don't really have
much to say just to fill in a couple of
little
gaps first of all representative
belshire you have
10% of all of the Committee Member
constituent petitions
are in your
District okay there are others that are
higher but you have
10% um I don't know I really hope that
when I hit the submit button yesterday
for my five pages that it actually got
to you because the I it came I may have
hit the button twice and the error
message came up saying you've already
submitted and it's like I didn't get
anything that said that I had submitted
except the error that it didn't so if
you do not have the five page
I can easily send a PDF or airdrop it to
a phone there's a lot of really good
information in here that's good for
review between now and executive session
and also to ask subsequent questions
okay so Linda used the term conversation
and I'm thinking maybe we could make it
Article 5 conversation of States because
they use the word convention back in the
1700s to say it's a meeting
and so I like conversation of States um
this is I'm a Undeclared voter in New
Hampshire for a lot of
reasons I feel that this is possibly the
most
nonpartisan effort that could be
hitting the United States because it
solves problems for both sides it it
comes to compromise and anybody that
that goes into a legisl
knows that you really can't get anything
done without
compromise and when I referred to the
previous
uh uh mention of Charles pikney Pinkney
it originally started May 29th the
ascent of the legislature of States
shall be sufficient to invest future
additional powers in Us in
c. do which is in Congress assembled and
shall bind the whole Confederacy so that
was end of May
1787 when we get to June is when
Alexander Hamilton comes in and says no
it's got to be Congress so they added
Congress to it and then they compromised
as part of the debate process leading
into September September 10th is when
George Mason who was twice as old as
James Madison at the time so picture
that James Madison's
26 comes up and says okay well let's put
this in let's put the or and have the
state as part of it so that's a big one
one state one voice I'm sorry one state
one vote 17th amendment I look at needs
to be repealed personally but we what
the original plan was It was supposed to
be the ambassador representing the state
of New Hampshire to the government of
the United States last Point checks and
balances so we have legislative branch
can impeach the executive the executive
can veto to check the legislature and
judici can strike down
legislation and this is absolutely
critical um the the framers and the
ratifiers chose you the state
legislatures to break glass and
emergencies somebody used my term before
James Madison Benjamin Franklin
Alexander Hamilton George Mason and yes
the other George Washington bestowed on
you our state legislator legislators the
power and influence to apply for a
convention for proposing amendments I
hope you vote in favor of H R3 and I
hope we get an ability to share this
with the rest of the body um in the
capital thank you so much for that and
for your submitted testimony I will
point out that I there's been a lot of
email traffic uh this week in our
committee prepping for today and I did
send a message to all the members with a
format so that everybody can have know
how to go online to see uh who who has
submitted online testimoni or comment so
I pushed that out to every Committee
Member M and I'm sure that at some point
uh we all will or should uh go online
and see uh the likes of what you
submitted okay and there's a chart in
there in color it's much nicer than this
that says what the representative is
that's on the committee and how many
petitions were signed in that District
along with a couple other interesting
points and and and notes thank you so
much for your testimony and for what
you've submitted and for being here and
with
that we will call a halt I will call a
halt to the hearing on um hcr3 we have
one more this morning that we want to
jump right into uh the the prime is
here on the
uh OS document the house concurrent
resolution five it it says the prime
sponsor is representative sabber and but
representative you're you're correct
name is uh represent Sabra and Schwaner
if for the for the clerk if
as you introduce yourself and your
measure if you could uh make sure that
she and we and all here absolutely uh
you're uh proper name thank you chairman
MAF and members of the committee I'm
representative sorn D schaner from
Rockham District 30 Madam clerk would
you like me to spell it
out all right cool so introducing today
house concurrent resolution number five
resending house concurrent resolution
number 40 passed by the 2012 New
Hampshire General Court asking that
Congress call and Convention under
Article 5 of the United States
Constitution this bill is a refile of
last year's house concurrent resolution
number n which passed the house we
anticipate that this would pass the
house again this year and we just need
to work onto the Senate uh I would say
that this bill has a little something
for everyone in it if you don't like the
idea of a Convention of States well it's
already built in and if you uh believe
in the idea of a Convention of states of
the
2012 uh resolution was asking for a
balanced budget of Amendment it doesn't
seem to be that it's the strongest of
the uh amendments proposed for the idea
of a Convention of States I personally
believe that a balanced budget amendment
would result in higher taxes for
American citizens um that's pretty much
it
um just wanted to introduce the
Bill thank you for that uh succinct
introduction representative so obviously
from looking at the measure here
acr5 uh calling for resending the
earlier resolutions passed uh about 133
years ago yeah so you if if I if we
understand you correctly you want that
rescinded but you're not opposed to the
Article 5 convention process is that
correct um I I think there's there's
Merit to the idea there's it seems to be
popular uh I'm I don't have strong
feelings one way or the or the other
about it I think it has to do more with
the Amendments that would be proposed
um I would say I'm still I I'm still
haven't fully I don't know but I know
this was for the balanced budget
amendment and that's something I think
that that we don't need to ask
for questions we take questions if there
are any uh yes I'll answer the best that
I can uh any questions for the prime at
this
time seeing none uh thank you
representative I have five I have five
cars and by the way if we get one from
you please uh a p a pink
card uh sure representative uh
representative former Senator uh Jim
rubins is still here welcome back uh
former Senator thank you thank you again
Mr chairman and members of the committee
again introducing myself this is
testimony I'm beh having myself in uh
for the federal fiscal sustainability
Foundation we are the nation's leading
single subject advocate of a single
subject fiscal responsibility Amendment
to the US Constitution I'm going to hand
out materials here that are more dense
than my remarks at the end of my remarks
so I just start with uh one of our board
members our chairman of the board is uh
Dave Walker who former comproller
general of the of America nominated by
three presidents unanimous unanimously
uh supported in the US Senate three
times he's our chairman he knows more
about the federal budget than I think
anyone else I've ever
met um another of our board members is a
fellow named Steve hanky Professor Steve
hanky who's a uh professor ameritus at
John's Hopkins University he's probably
on TV about two times a week uh
interviewed on the issue of economics
and he instructed me about the following
if you look at the history of leading
economies of the world hegemonic
economies whose currency was used uh in
within their own nation and outside the
nation you could start with Rome for
example and you could continue on
through history and you get to Spain and
the Netherlands and then Great Britain
and now the United States We Are The
Keeper of the world's Reserve currency
our currency the US dollar has the
position that these prior dozen uh
leading economies of the world
had and unfortunately we've hit a red
line and if you look at the history
history of these dominant economies and
their currencies when they hit the red
line we're at right now these economies
never recovered and the red line that
we've hit is our debt in the United
States is equal to the size of our
economy our debt to GDP ratio is 100%
now we've hit the red line from which
all the world's prior leading economies
never recovered their preeminent status
in the the past what this is telling us
what economists across the political
Spectrum are now telling us and you can
read this in the newspaper and in trade
journals and economics analysis every
single day people warning us the federal
government is a of control Congress is
addicted to debt they're conflicted
because the handing out of freebies with
printed money uh and gets people
reelected Congress began to get
concerned about this in the 1980s when
the movement to adopt balance budget
amendment uh resolutions by States under
Article 5 began to take root we got to
39 States having uh submitted
applications including New Hampshire in
1979 39 States more than the required 34
at that time and debt in the United
States was under a trillion dollars a
year okay we all know it's now $ 36.1
trillion a year and Congress in response
to the
States uh using their powers under
Article 5 uh adopted the gr Grand Rudman
resolution and Congress breached its
self-restraint under Graham Rudman and
recurrently four more times since then
uh Congress has breached all its own
self-restraint with respect to debt
spending and it's very very clear
Congress cannot control itself the
framers put this power in the
Constitution because when we hit
circumstances like this the framers
understood that when the United States
confronts problem like this problems
like this that Congress will not solve
Congress is not able to not willing to
solve its addiction to debt the states
are allowed to step in and amend the
Constitution by proposing an
amendment
so our constitution is very clear I'll
just talk briefly about this runaway
thing which is the reason that it's been
very very hard to move this process
forward even for congress Congress is
breaching the Constitution and failing
to call the Article 5 Amendment
conention convention with respect to the
balance budget amendment fiscal
responsibility Amendment Congress is so
opposed to the states doing this that
they failed to call uh let's look at the
threat of the runaway Convent first
two-thirds of the states have to agree
on a subject matter in resolutions
adopted like the one that this
legislature adopted in 1979 since
rescinded and reopt it in 2012 so we
have a live New Hampshire has a live
fiscal responsibility BBA resolution on
the books right now making us one of the
states calling for this two-thirds of
the states first have to do this then as
you've heard in prior testimony and the
prior bill you folks here in this room
and the wider legislature you deter
determine who the delegates will be to
the amending convention who will
deliberate and struggle with the very
difficult job of adopting an amendment
to restrain congress's addiction to
debt uh you will select those delegates
you will control those delegates if you
look at uh and and this is reference to
this the Supreme Court's unanimous 2020
chalao versus Washington decision a
unanimous decision by by an
ideologically divided Supreme Court has
made abundantly clear that you folks in
the legislature determine how the
delegates will be selected and you
determine how they'll be governed and
you have the ability to sanction and
remove them even without HB 264 should
they diverge from the application that
New Hampshire has in 2012 our balance
budget application you have complete
Authority ruled unanimously by the
Supreme Court to select and control and
remove these delegates should you should
you see fit to do that and finally the
convention for proposing amendments
those are the words in Article 5 give
this amending convention no power to do
anything whatsoever and you hear people
who oppose this tell you the runaway
convention will shred the
Constitution the amending convention has
no power to do anything other than
propose and this is going to be a
difficult problem on on the Deb limit
question anyway and should they succeed
in
proposing one state one vote vote then
it has to go back in 38 states to ratify
and you heard that 13 states simply by
doing nothing cause that proposed
amendment to go nowhere we have the mo
we have the free world's most difficult
to amend Constitution another point I'd
make with respect to the balanced budget
amendment the amending convention is a
deliberative assembly of delegates in
the same way that Congress uh deals with
proposed amendments uh an amendment
might be proposed by an individual in
Congress it's debated it's amended it's
altered it goes through a lengthy and
and if you look at the the the 27
Amendments that have been ratified to
date all of them have gone through an
arduous process in Congress at reaching
sufficient uh deliberative uh support
even to get back to the States for
ratification so the the deliberative
amending convention may choose to
propose a line item veto for the
president to deal with the spending and
debt problem it may propose a Swiss debt
break that the people of Switzerland
adopted by 83% in in a referendum
adopting their debt limit Amendment the
Swiss debt break uh it may propose a
debt to GDP limit a ratio limit on the
extent to which debt relative to the
size of our economy uh the amending
convention May adopt a uh something like
a tabore a what Colorado has in its
state constitution
so um I would I would conclude just
simply by saying this the opponents who
wish to resend New Hampshire's live BBA
application which we oppose at Federal
fiscal sustainability Foundation please
vote this down please vote this itl
remember you folks have control over
this entire process and and the question
the opponents put to you or the case
they put to you is that you should not
trust yourself you have control over the
delegates you you determin who the
delegates will be you have the ability
to sanction and remove them they're
asking you not to trust yourself I trust
members of this legislature I've been a
member of this legislature and I know I
returned every phone call and I know
when I talk to you folks in the house
here I can talk with you folks on the
street I trust you to do the right thing
to solve this country's problem that
Congress is not solving we've got a fire
red alert fire emergency on debt trust
yourself to guide the process by which
the country is going to resolve this
problem a problem that Congress is not
resolving the opponents are telling you
let's buy this runaway convention risk
let's use that and say let the house let
our fiscal House burn down that's an
absurd proposition please
itl HCR 5 thank you willing to take
questions are there any
questions seeing none thank you Senator
uh one of the co-sponsors is still here
representative Horgan is asked for uh
three
minutes thank you very much I'm resident
of Timothy Oregon from straford County
District 10 the town of Durham although
a long time ago I used to live in
Handover and I was actually one of uh
Senator rubin's constituents back then
but and um this bill is very similar
well this resolution um well first of
all I should thank uh even though he's
not here he had to go to another meeting
representative saberin dwan for
introducing this it's uh not he's a
first term rep and this is a pretty
pretty big topic he took on and I think
uh I congratulate him for doing it and I
hope um
I I hope this will have the same fate
that I had when I was a rookie State Rep
back in 200 10 the second year of my
first term and actually another rookie
State Rep uh resident Comer Timothy
comford from uh I think he was from
Freemont um he he's moved on he's doing
something that pays more than $100 a
year so we we were resending um all
previous uh Article 5 convention calls
um and I think Senator Rubin stated
which I believe is correct that the one
the only one we had outstanding the time
was from 1979 for balance
budget and I mean I could go on about
why a balanced budget uh amendment is a
bad idea especially if you turn it over
to an article 5 convention which is
prone to a run away even though anything
it proposes after a runways has to be
ratified by super majority of the states
so and um so we event to get that pass
with bipartisan bipartisan support I
think it passed both Chambers by a Voice
vote and then ironically the next year
in
2012 we had a we had a resolution
calling for a um Article 5 convention or
a or to have the Senate propose a
constitutional convention on their own
and that
uh and that and that also passed and the
two sponsors that are actually still in
the legislature R erery who's
uh still sitting back to the room and
Senator Sharon Carson who's now the
president of the Senate so I I
um basically I supported this because I
think uh any Article 5 convention is a
bad idea at this time it uh you know I
may be may be necessary someday but it's
not necessarily for necessary um was it
necessary in 2012 it's not necessary now
even though things are worse than in
2012 you know large Southern California
is literally on fire but um they I don't
think the convention could do much about
that and um so and also think the
national the national debt that's a
complicated issue I think uh uh it's
about half of it is the money supply so
we actually tried to pay off the
national debt first of all I'm not sure
how you'd pay off the money supply
except by printing more money and also
it would cause more problems then it
solves will you take any questions if
there are
any are there any questions for one of
the coach
sponsors seeing none uh thank you again
I'll just refer you back to HCR 28 and
2010 which also laid out a very good
case so resent comaford like re sapper
and dhir did a did a very good job
drafting it a me drafting a a resolution
so I hope uh hope it'll meet the same
fate we had in 2010 which is a
bipartisan uh bipartisan majority in
both the house and in the other chamber
that I guess we're not supposed to
mention here but so thank you very much
thank you for uh staying around okay uh
Carol Pusa witz is still here she's
asked for 2 minutes and 45 seconds and I
really appreciate how you time out
obviously you're doing your homework and
T timing out uh your preparation so
thank you for that and welcome back for
the third time thank you um yesterday on
Article 5 library.org they showed 36
current Balan budget resolutions yet as
We Know know 34 is all that's needed for
Congress to set the time in place and I
know the courts are going to work that
out regardless of that New Hampshire
should not resend the 2012 balance
balance budget resolution yes that
legislator that passed that knew the
spending of Congress was out of control
and would bankrupt the nation and today
of course the debt is way worse the
legislature understood it's its duty to
protect New Hampshire and its posterity
someone I know and admire was very
influential when passing that bill in
2012 at that time he was a Senator it
was Senator Fenton groan he continued to
serve in the house for years committing
himself to upholding the Statesman
status and I thank him for his service
this resolution is written portraying
that the sponsors admire the
Constitution except that they feel the
founders made a mistake when they
unanimously agreed to the necessity of
the second part of Article 5 to support
the sponsors that wrote this bill
and anyone who agrees with this
resolution my recommendation is for them
to write a new resolution removing the
second part of Article 5 they can see if
34 States agree that only Congress
should be authorized to make Amendment
proposals the founders understood human
nature and their desire for control and
power and so felt this safety net from
congressional usurpations was absolutely
essential to protect the states and the
people's rights maybe the people of
today think Human Nature Nature has
changed the sponsors certainly are
empowered to write a new resolution and
see if the public if there's any public
support but that's not what we're here
to discuss today the problem back in
2012 is the same Congress is bankrupting
our nation today's Congressional
overspending is eviden that we need to
keep this balanced budget resolution in
good standing New Hampshire's balanced
budget um Amendment resolution is not
plenary it's not open-ended for any
subject matter but rather specific to
just discussing a balanced budget the
last plary application was in
1929 once the nation realized the risks
of plenary resolutions States rescinded
all their applications I don't know of
any state that wants a convention that
is able to discuss any topic I don't
know any none hd40 is bound to only
discuss a balanced budget proposal
without a faithful delegate Bill basic
agency law protects New Hampshire
against delegates who disobey their
instruction Most states avoid confusion
of how to use basic agency laws and
write delegation laws defining how the
delegates will be selected financed and
held accountable if they violate the
state's directives HB 264 Was Heard
earlier today on the subject matter even
though the current Administration is
taking some actions to reverse this
bankruptcy the next Administration can
just undo their efforts only in Article
5 has the ability to make a permanent
change in the structure for lasting
results please vote no on HCR 5 I am
available for questions thank you for
that very well organized testimony much
appreciated
questions Sean thank you
again I have three more cards uh Mr
fieldman Samuel is asked for two minutes
he Oppo also opposes the uh the measure
welcome
back thank you chair mafa thank you
members of the committee um Samuel
fieldman speaking on behalf of Wolfpack
as a volunteer uh wolfpac only opposes
um the parts of this resolution we
oppose the parts that are factually
inaccurate um the uh we have no
objection to resending a call for
balanced budget amendment um we're
single issue focused on the issue of
campaign Finance reform and if this
resolution were limited to the first
Wares clause and the first two resolve
Clauses then we would be neutral on it
we would have no objection um the issue
is that the um the rest of the um
resolution talks about the Declaration
of
Independence um and the uh the right to
uh abolish and replace the government
and just utterly conflates the idea of a
true Constitutional Convention with an
article 5 amending convention uh which
is an easy mistake to make because most
of the scholarly Rec search up until
about 15 years ago or so um used the
term Constitutional Convention and then
used other language to clarify which
type of Constitutional Convention they
meant and because of that confusion more
recent scholarship has uh changed the
the name and specifically called it a
convention for proposing amendments or
an article 5 convention or uh or
something to that effect um but the one
of the reasons I actually like use of
the term Constitutional Convention
unlike most people who who work in this
uh who studied this is that we have good
precedent from various types of
constitutional conventions uh including
the Philadelphia Convention including
the the 40 uh Interstate conventions
that were mentioned by Senator sorum and
others and also which has not been
mentioned uh about 50 uh conventions
held under the US Constitution um about
a dozen under article more than about 14
under article 7 to ratify the US
Constitution
and uh more than 40 under um Article 5
to ratify the 21st amendment um and all
of these as well as the more than 200
State conventions to either amend or
propose uh constitutions give us a
tremendous amount of precedent that help
us understand how this process works um
there have been numerous treatises
written about that going all the way
back to the founding of the Republic um
and I and among just to give you an
example of of the precedent
um here in New Hampshire in uh in
1788 um the convention to ratify the US
Constitution um about half the delegates
were Bound by their constituents and
they were bound specifically to vote
against the US Constitution uh and they
were held um they were held to that they
considered themselves held to it the
convention that was called considered
them held to it and that's why they
adjourned that convention and sent them
back to their constituents uh to argue
with their constituents that they should
have uh they should get broader
Authority um the constituents then uh
enough of the constituents um listened
to the arguments and agreed that the
constitution actually was a good idea uh
to uh to change the minds of enough uh
delegates that were then sent back to a
new convention uh and then ratified the
US Constitution putting it into effect
and specifically in the town of basn um
they uh were the the first to not only
recognize their authority to um bind
their delegates but the authority to um
to re uh to remove their delegate and
send a new one if they uh thought that
that delegate wasn't going to adequately
represent them they ultimately decided
to keep that delegate but there was
another one ready to go and it was a
close vote to replace their existing
delegate with a new one or to to keep
the
thank seeing none we have two more cards
uh Eric benus has asked is still here uh
from U
Guilford is asked for three minutes uh
welcome
back again thank you uh chairman thank
you members of the uh committee um I
will be brief everything has been said
that needs to be said um I am here in
pose of uh of this um a resolution um I
am from sorry my name is Eric Benavides
I am from Guilford um
and like Sam said uh I'm here
representing Wolfpack we are neutral on
the position of of balance budget
amendment we we are a single focused
organization on campaign Finance reform
what we have a problem with is the
inflammatory language about Article 5
that it is a dangerous um uh Pursuit
that is a dangerous method of amending
the Constitution we just do not believe
in that again and that is not just us
talking about it
the majority of leading experts that
make it their career to study the
Constitution and constitutional law
agree that it is a safe process it will
not run away there are multiple reports
that you can peer-reviewed reports from
the from the uh Harvard Law review from
the uh American Bar Association from the
Congressional research report from the
doj under two presidents there's just a
multitude of reports that say it is safe
now there are opinions out there that
say is not safe there are plenty of
opinions and people are entitled to
their opinions but when those opinions
are brought to the experts to review
they are dismissed because in order to
make those opinions you have to ignore
history precedent facts um and and they
are easily disputed so that's all I have
to say on that matter I would like to
correct the record Madam clerk from my
comments earlier um I looked at my notes
it was 25 States have introduced
faithful delegate laws not passed them
and according to my records and
obviously uh Senator Santorum said
something different he said a dozen
under my records there have only been
seven states that have actually passed
and have put in place those laws so but
there are 25 and I I hate giving
misinformation so I wanted to correct
the record on that we're opposed to
misinformation in the official record
thank you for clarifying that and and
and being a being a librarian a
university librarian 10 years I hate
misinformation I like research and I
like good information so um so uh that's
all I have to say uh again um I hope you
will uh vote no on this Madam chair
thank you Mr chairman um so is it 12
that passed that's what senator sorm
says my records show seven okay um but
maybe he has different um uh information
that I don't have as far as I can see
there has been only seven states that
have actually passed and implemented uh
faithful delegate laws thank
you I'm going to recognize Senator Rubin
because I can uh before I go to the last
uh the last speaker uh sen may call
Senator uh go ahead uh you can go to an
organization called path to reform you
can Google it and I think they have a
compendium of states that actually have
on the books delegate limitation laws I
think it's about 14 path to reform
path to reform and you can see which
states aded delegate limitation laws
good good good to know path to
reform.com we just Google that
okay uh thank you again thank
you okay our final card uh Joe trelli is
is back he's asked for a minute uh
batting cleanup he also opposes HCR 5
welcome back Mr trelli thank you very
much and I have one correction from my
previous test
also for Madam clerk I referred to James
Madison as being 26 he was 26 when the
Declaration of
Independence but Mason was 30 years
older or something around that okay so I
don't know if anybody's ever been
involved in a patent anybody any of the
committee members so a patent is where
you describe something so well that
someone outside the knowledge of that
should be able to build
it I look at the Declaration of
Independence as the patent and when I
look at HCR 5 they're referring to the
Declaration of Independence as having
all that's the right of the people yeah
okay and when I look at this I'm
thinking this is
not what we think it is there's a lot of
years between declaration Articles of
Confederation and Constitution Articles
of Confederation failed to have an
amendment cap ability that was used they
never bothered using it so everybody
worked forward to the Constitutional
Convention the actual Constitutional
Convention starting in May of 1787 and
they built the
product and they made the product
successful and it's the Envy of the
world except maybe South
Africa so I just wanted to say that I
think this this HCR 5 is folly and it's
useless because there's been enough case
over the testimonies that we've heard
today and and
provided that an article 5 convention
should happen the recision should not
and this should be put in front of the
full body and we I I ask for your
support any questions for Mr
trelli seeing none uh committee members
before I swing the gavel and close this
hearing and before I lose you because I
know we're a little bit after 12:00 noon
uh we will reconvene on schedule for the
one we have one measure to he this
afternoon at 1: p.m. uh following that
right before we go to Executive session
uh we we'll have a very brief
presentation from a representative from
the new veterans campus in Franklin uh
was not able to be here for orientation
day uh so he's going to speak briefly I
think he has some handouts uh looking
forward to that uh and then we'll go
right into executive session and I'd
like to meet with the members of the red
team you know who you are uh at uh 10
minutes to one uh so if you could plan
your lunch break accordingly so we'll
see the red members in the committee
office room at at 10 minutes to one
we'll see everybody else here at 1 pm.
thank
you ask they C uh represent did you want
to make do you want to yeah yeah sorry
um for the members of The Blue Team um
we will be meeting if you want
to
e
okay at this time at 1307 we're just a
little bit behind um but we're good to
go we have one hearing this afternoon
it's going to be on house joint
resolution one affirming the natural
right of persons and affirming that the
state and federal government are
established for the purpose of upholding
protecting and securing these rights the
prime sponsor is from this committee
representative Belzer uh he's in place
ready to go
uh and Mr Prime sponsor uh have at it
thank you Mr chairman and members uh
this fits rather nicely a lot of
commonality between the things we
discussed this morning and what we'll
find in here I'm not going to read the
whole thing uh front to back for you I
just want to touch on some of the uh big
points in here and what the purpose is
so the purpose of this is to identify
the nature
of Rights the rights that people possess
in our country in our
society and update them just a little
bit so they properly fit in the modern
context compared to where they were
couple hundred years ago before the
internet and such
things so first we have the fact that
rights exist before and after the state
they are not legitimated by the state
nor provided by the state and because of
that the state does not have the
authority to take them from you
either goes on to establish the consent
of the governed is the foundational
principle for legitimating our
government which is effectively what a
republic is the consent of a govern
legitimates a
republic moving on we talk
about
the freedom from the official
establishment of a state Church or
coercion toward certain spiritual
Dogma the freedom of speech and right to
disseminate information in good faith
that shall not be infringed directly by
proxy nor subject to prosecution under
hate crime statutes and the absence of a
crime against persons or property so
let's talk about this one for just a
minute we have seen some very
significant
transgressions against the rights to to
free speech especially at the federal
level in the last perhaps
decade we have seen various federal
agencies going through certain private
companies social media companies
especially to see American citizens
censored and unable to spread whatever
message that they wanted to spread on
social media which is why that's where
the byox part comes in it is an
unfortunate um very unfortunate
situation that the Supreme Court
recently held that it was okay for the
government to censor by proxy to put
pressure on companies like Facebook or
Twitter or others to see American
citizen speech
removed that never should have
happened moving on to the part about the
hate crime
statutes we have a problem in this
state now I'm particular fan of uh
rather terrible white supremacist nazes
groups they're pretty bad their ideology
is pretty bad but because the rights of
free speech don't come from government
they come from a Transcendent source and
they cannot be taken by government even
those people have the right to free
speech and twice in the last few years
the New Hampshire Department of Justice
has gone after one of these uh I forget
the name over the top of my head one of
these groups for speech
crimes simply hanging a banner it said
something horrible but you get to say
something horrible because of free
speech both times the New Hampshire doj
was laughed out of court and the New
Hampshire Supreme Court called the
precedent that they were trying to set
dangerous to free speech
so it's important that we reiterate the
fact that people have the right to say
things even bad things even things we
hear moving
on the right to assemble and to receive
reasonable protection from authorities
against lawlessness and criminality in
such assembly unfortunately this is a
problem we've seen especially on college
campuses where certain times for certain
speakers they have refused to provide
the necessary protection in place to
allow events to go forward and you've
had heckler's vetos where people shut
people down and assaults were committed
because there was not adequate despite
forn knowledge of various protests that
were going to happen there was not
place the right to bear arms and to self
militia in defense of oneself one's
family private property Community State
nation and
Liberties that no Soldier nor any person
whatsoever shall be forcibly or
coercively quartered in any house or
home now that's another important little
update that I'm adding in here because
under the Constitution it's very clear
that there shall not be any Soldier
quartered in a private home without an
act of Congress to do so but what we've
seen recently is something that I don't
think the founders actually anticipated
we've seen places especially places like
Massachusetts and some other places
actually looking to quarter uh various
persons refugees Asylum Seekers illegal
immigrants in private homes without the
permission of the homeowners this is
something that's been moving forward and
it we need to add this protection in
place to make sure that it's clear that
that unreasonable search and seizure by
all government entities by proxy of
government or by any entity Furnishing
such knowledge to
government the fourth amendment was
supposed to be pretty clear and explicit
but unfortunately we've had some
judicial precedence and frankly just
ignoring of the law and you now have
especially the federal
government consistently spying on
American citizens including through the
purchase of meta data from third parties
so that cell phone you have in your
pocket it's collecting data on you and
the federal government is quite likely
buying that data from your cell phone
company in order to compile that data on
you which ought to be viewed as a
rights
here those are the big highlights I
don't want to take up too much time but
as as I look at this and I am trying to
project this forward to if it goes to
the full floor depending upon what we do
next week presumably if we exact this
resolution um I'm seeing it is a little
bit
esoteric um
and I'm anticipating people um saying
what does that mean what do natural
rights mean and I read it and reread it
and I'm and I'm just like I said I'm
trying to anticipate questions for us or
for me
uh what this is about I understand a
little bit better thank you for for
introducing it helped have some specific
examples which you you
provided um so the essence is that a a
natural right is not derived from the
state you you said that
correct and I I wasn't sure how deep
down the particular philosophy roote we
wanted to go here but I'll just touch on
it briefly
so rights are going to be considered
either derived from a Transcendent
Source or an imminent Source if it's a
Transcendent Source we're saying like
our Founders said in the Declaration of
Independence they come from the our
creator they come from God an eminent
Source if you go look at the philosophy
of uh such as German idealist Hegel who
marks built his philosophy off of
considers the state to take that role of
being like God and giving those rights
the problem is when the state takes that
position and it is seen as not merely
affirming and upholding rights but the
originator of Rights well then the state
can change its mind and it can take
those rights and that's a little bit of
the situation that we're finding
ourselves moving toward where our
government are for of government has
been slowly transitioned over an rather
extended period of time away from a
Transcendent natural source of rights
where the rights are inherent to the
person existing separate from the state
versus they exist at the pleasure of the
state thank you for that line eight
refers to our create our creator and
that's language that's in the
Declaration of
Independence again looking forward I'm
wondering if there may be any folks in
the house who if they read this or in
committee who read this who if they are
agnostic or atheistic or whatever are
they going to have a problem with of
course this is a resolution it's not
wording that'll be in
statute uh potentially so the notion of
our creator uh is that anything that you
see as being an issue moving forward um
well that that's a good question it
could be an issue going forward but it's
100% necessary to be there because as I
said going back to the the philosophy of
right the philosophy where rights are
derived from there's really only two
primary tracts there's the tract based
on the American tradition which is a
tradition based off of the Protestant
Reformation and the enlightenment that
says that our rights come from God the
other tradition is the tradition that is
it self actually esoteric it comes from
the ideas of Plato of the ideas of
Aristotle the ideas of Hegel the ideas
of Marx that says that actually this
there is no such thing as rights because
there is no Transcendent source and
therefore the government doesn't have to
respect
them thank you for that the committee is
going to have a week to process and
digest and Ponder uh and we're here just
to listen to you um so so thank you for
taking out a couple of questions
representative Foss thank you thank you
well uh if we can get a little political
philosophical um you said there are two
main tracks but it don't we know from
people like uh RS or nosic or um you
know the whole philosophy of
utilitarianism there's actually a lot of
different ideas of where rights come
from so this would seem to be giving us
a really strong political philosophical
a a state stance rather uh so is that
uh is that not a rather
overreach um so no no it's not an
overreach and it's not an overreach for
no other reason than the language is
taken directly from the founding
documents of America but to your point
about utilitarianism and others yes
there have been numerous over the years
attempts to craft a philosophy to
legitimate the concept of Rights without
a Transcendent source and as nii V very
clearly it's not possible you cannot you
cannot legitimate a source of rights
that is not something that can be taken
Transcendent I think folks watching at
home are Googling nitki Hegel uh
we all know who he's talking about I'm
sure but uh uh I need to do a little bit
of homework myself on some of this uh
this thank you for that question ripson
f f is there a
followup I feel like that would get uh
actually I think I took a whole semester
of political philosophy so uh if you
want to Joint teach a class with h two
different perspectives then uh but I
think it's beyond the uh five minutes we
have scheduled sure uh
so beyond if there's more questions
we'll take them our role here today
really is to listen to you uh if there's
anything that we have a question about
we've already given you a couple uh like
I said we'll have a week to process this
and then in executive session next week
I think some some of the uh thought some
thoughts that may uh Blossom uh once we
process and and reread this and and
maybe even Google a couple of things uh
we'll have a I think be a very
interesting exec session on this house
joint resolution which if it pass the if
it passes the house the way that works
is it would go to the Senate and the
governor is involved in an hjr
correct so uh other questions for the
prime sponsor of this
hjr representative mandal bomb uh thank
you Mr chairman um and thanks for taking
my question representative Belcher so I
know this is a resolution um so it's
kind of a different standard than our
house bills are I'm just curious kind of
how much leeway you see in within these
rights I'm just thinking about um I
think one notable one that's mentioned
is the right to Bel to bear arms and
self militia and defense and we've had
some some bills related to Firearms
recently um and I think there are some
folks who think that
putting um what they see to be
reasonable um like safety regulations
around around Firearms is infringing
upon that right I mean does is there
room within kind of this text from your
perspective to accommodate different
perspectives related to what these
rights are thank you for the question
excuse me thank you for the question I
certainly did not expect this to be
uncontroversial or um universally
supported um as far as your specific
example it would be my uh contention and
based on the history of the Second
Amendment right in the United States
that there are relatively few reasonable
restrictions that can be placed on it
for instance when uh a privateer wrote
Thomas Jefferson for permission to put
cannons on his vessel Thomas Jefferson
wrote back scolding him for even
bothering because the Second Amendment
covered that up until the first world
war every conflict in America was fought
primarily with private arms and and uh
as well as private
artillery uh so there's a long
historical precedent there thank
you follow up um I mean just to to be a
little bit more specific I was thinking
about how um there's recently a bill
that um didn't even make it out of
um on background checks for firearms
and I think some folks do see that as a
infringing upon their rights to bear
arms
and I I'm just
curious like with holding that
perspective or holding the perspective
that you know having a wait time or
running a certain background check is
that is that would that would holding
that view be in contradiction of of this
resolution thank you for the question
those are a little bit more nuanced
they're a little bit more difficult to
to pin down in terms of this resolution
um right off the bat I would say that
historically given the precedents that
exist there is an argument to be made
that background check are not something
that was meant to be in place however
there was also the fact that if you were
considered to be too dangerous to have a
firearm you would have either been kept
in jail or an asylum so there's there's
a bit of a a bit of a push and pull
there as far as that goes so I I can't I
don't think I can say definitely Which
Way those would go under under this
concept
um yeah that's that's the best I could
do on that one than
representative cyber I actually have a
question you might be able but the
chairman might be able to address it as
well as far as I've been in this
committee I don't remember us having an
hjr could you please explain the
difference between that and like the
HCR I could take that if you don't mind
uh so the the big difference is this
goes if it passes this house this would
go to the Senate and if it passes the
Senate it would go to the governor and
unlike a
the resolu other resolutions you've seen
this if going through that whole process
just like a bill would be treated as
having the effect of
law so it's oh sorry um
um so I I mean I get that I'm just say
like so why wouldn't we just call it a
bill
or well to your point representative a
bill would be something that would go
into statute is I think I touched on
that earlier in a resolution does not
become law it's a sense of the body so
we've had uh a number of resolutions uh
some that passed some that don't if it
gets a majority vote uh HR is just the
house HCR goes to the Senate and as we
just talked about hjr involves the
governor so did the force of law I I if
the governor signs an hjr it's it's not
a law but it's it's as the imprimer of
the legislature and the executive branch
is supporting the Notions expressed in
the resolution fear to say it's not a
law it's not a proposed
law followup yeah a quick little
followup I'm just curious so I mean I
get all that I was just curious is it I
guess what I meant is is it enforcable
in any way is it able to like pull it up
as a precedent or be referred to saying
like a court case or
anything I could take that one yes uh
yes it is um it is not it is not a bill
so it is not a law in terms of it would
go into the books in the same way the
law would but under the New Hampshire
Constitution it is treated as having the
effect of
law so next week we will hear a couple
of resolutions uh the Jones act being
one of them that I I'm have been
involved with in we did this last year
you'll recall and that was very specific
we wanted to have this resolution move
forward calling for the Jones act to be
repealed so that's a very narrow
specific uh resolution repeal the Jones
act it passes or doesn't or gets gets
tabled um so this case as I said right
up front it's a little more broader
esoteric and I'm trying to uh
uh understand the intent in the
background and I I need to do some more
reading on it and I may have some more
questions representative beler if this
does move forward will you please be the
one that speaks to it on the house floor
yes I would be happy to okay and I and
if someone wants to speak against it uh
you have plenty of time to uh to work it
up uh repon Foss you have a hand up I do
um sorry to get back to the the theory
of Rights if the this perspective AC IST
that they come from a Transcendent
source is it and but isn't that
inherently contradictory with the free
exercise of religion and if we're saying
that this is the position of the state
as a us as a representative body of the
state that rights come from a
Transcendent Source isn't that
inherently uh putting forth as an
official state position that there is a
Transcendent Source from which our
rights could come so isn't that kind of
an internal contradiction no it's not an
internal contradiction uh no more so
than the founding documents of America
are that cited in the exact same
language the Creator is the source of
these rights um because what you're what
you're effectively saying is that there
is a source of these rights that exists
outside of government and it's not
coming from government so the government
therefore because it didn't create them
it can't take them away either uh but
that said you move on to the right to
the free exercise clause and there's no
contradiction that you can you can have
an affirmative right to the freedom of
exercise of religion and no compulsion
to the exercise of religion under the
standard that there is also a
Transcendent source for that right
too so that's a good question question
that helps to clarify what this is all
about uh it's starting almost to touch
on a little bit of what an executive
session might entail in terms of uh
drilling down into what we want to do or
shouldn't do that's kind of what I'm
sensing here uh but uh representa manal
bomb go go ahead thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you representative for
taking my question
so um a this is more of a request than a
question um but and you know this might
be something I have to do in my own and
I'm not sure if it's reasonable to ask
you but I'd be curious um I mean you say
that these rights are enumerated in part
in the New Hampshire Constitution the
Federal Constitution and the Bill of
Rights and I would just be curious where
these different pieces of the resolution
are coming from um and in what way the
language might differ or are you taking
things directly from say the Bill of
Rights um because I I feel like there's
a difference perhaps
between
um uh kind of reiterating the rights
that
are um that are kind of out there and
using that exact text versus kind of
taking the like the sentiment around the
text yes that that's a very good
question so the source is variable some
of the language is taken directly from a
founding documents the Declaration of
Independence the
Constitutions uh some of it is taken um
either in whole or at least paraphrasing
from The Federalist Papers and other
debates leading up to the Constitutional
Convention and some of it is taken from
the the concept itself so for instance
where we have the idea that where we
have the idea that Free Speech ought to
also prevent government from telling
social media companies to censor you is
going it's not something that is
directly found in the First Amendment as
written in the letter but it is
something that can be reasonably
articulated from the spirit of the First
Amendment or the principle behind
sponsor representative go ahead uh thank
you Mr chairman so representative uh in
your testimony you said people have
right to say whatever message they want
to share whatever messages don't don't
you think if a person calls for violence
wouldn't that be a
problem thank you for the question so
they they have a right to free speech
but there are things that you can say
noises you can make when you move your
mouth that don't technically qualify as
speech uh such exclusions include true
threats incitement to
violence um defamation of character so
these these are some exception
categories that are not free speech
because they're actually um they're
actually a criminal or civil offense
thank you other
questions seeing No Hands uh thank you
Mr Prime sponsor representative would
you please do a pink uh card and give it
to our clerk if you
would and seeing with no pink cards at
all with one coming in there's no one
else here to speak so I will at this
time close the hearing on this hjr and
I'm going to hope that the one of the
gentlemen in the back of the room his
name would be alen aldenberg is alen
here yes all right so folks before we go
to Executive session as I mentioned
earlier we're going to have a a
presentation here from some folks who
were not able to be or were not at the
orientation um and Alan's from um Easter
sales and uh alen I'll let you introduce
your your
Compadre uh and Easter sales has been a
prime mover behind the new veterans
campus in Franklin I was there for the
uh ribbon cutting is has anybody else
been to that campus or seen
it um then I'm then uh
oh great so have some some literature
coming out so alen I'll let you
introduce your your your helper your
Compadre as I put it and um very much
looking forward to uh having everybody
learn what uh is happening there it's uh
it's very exciting so uh alen Al
aldenberg if you want to hit the button
so the red light comes on there you go
welcome thank you sir uh good afternoon
chairman Mofford Vice chair Rollins U
thank you chairman um representative
Rollins for the sacrifices that your
family's made as well I want to
acknowledge
that um so let me first by thanking you
um all of you for your service to the
state of New Hampshire and your
communities I've provided each of you
with a packet that Nick's handing out
now um includes a lot of information
about the map of campus there's a map
included in there frequently asked
questions as well as some um valuable
information about the overall mission of
Easter Seals so like the chairman said
I'm Alan Al mam chief of military and
veteran service is for East of seals in
New Hampshire um I joined east of seals
back in November of 24 after retiring as
a chief of police for the Manchester
police dep department so it's nice to be
back up here in a different capacity um
not so confrontational in some matters
but um this this body has always been
very good to me um I'm also a veteran
and currently serve in the New Hampshire
National Guard as a colonel with over 30
years of service um I'll let Nick Grant
give himself a brief introduction about
uh his military service as well yeah
Nick Grant uh he does need a
mic closer I guess he
does um so yeah Nick Grant with Easter
Seals as well working uh on the the
veterans campus here with Al um I spent
six years in the US Army um did three
tours um so familiar with what veterans
go through when they come back and
transition back into this life and the
challenges that a lot of them face um
and so I'm excited to be a part of this
project and appreciate the time today
thanks for
all right so as the chairman said the
east of seals New Hampshire military and
Veterans campus is going to be situated
in Franklin uh dedicated facility to
provide essential services to Veterans
service members and their families the
endgame is that we will have created a
center of excellence for our veterans
and their families and those currently
serving as well as First Responders in
their families as well we'll focus on
holistic support housing Workforce
Development Behavioral Health
recreational activities substance use
treatment and other social services
in order to ensure long-term stability
and SEC and success for those who have
sacrificed so much for our nation so
current progress Nick if you don't mind
holding that map up I'd appreciate it so
as most of you be aware in Fall of 2022
EA seals received $23 million in state
oper funding to develop and build the
campus on a 15 Acre Site in Franklin
excuse me uh we can see the the uh the
map but if you could hold it right next
to the speaker right next to Al so that
the folks can see get a sense on TV what
what we're talking about and if you can
move it just a little closer to the
speaker so that some of that can get on
the on TV uh thank you go ahead go ahead
thanks Nick all right so phase one of
the project will be completed in June of
this year and by phase one that's going
to be 29 units of permanent affordable
housing for Veterans um of those 29
units five of them will be two bedroom
15 of that 29 will be eligible for the
VA bash program so the the the amount
that the veteran or their family has to
pay will be greatly reduced I think it's
at about a 30% that they'll be
responsible for so 15 of those are um
very very affordable for
veterans um part of that phase two so
that housing will be right here and you
have a map in your packet will be these
two buildings right here that have been
completely rehabbed um gutted right down
um so those are um and this whole
Project's being done by procon
Construction agre partner so that's
those two are phase one for June across
the street on your map you see a hub of
services and a retreat center um and
that's going to have meeting and event
space um the goal here is to have space
for all of our veteran service
organizations to come to the campus um
on a you know we don't we don't expect
all the vsos to live there but the goal
is to have a um a good Rhythm when
veterans not only that live there but
from across the state know that one
particular vsos is are going to be on
site from legal assistance Financial
employment um we also have a um e ofs
has a substance abuse Grant um
outpatient that we're going to have on
site as well um so just a lot of things
that we're going to bring to that Hub of
services um the goal here is to make it
a premier destination for veterans
military nonprofits First Responders and
um and the big another big part of this
Retreat Center is you're going to have
22 Host Hotel style rooms as well um
that will be available to people the
organizations that use the retreat
center hey we want to bring in an
organization we want to do a a camp
resilience let's say Retreat um we're
going to be there for two days we're
bringing in 20 people okay we'll have
lodging available for them um so that's
another great addition that's kind of
another thing that's going to set this
campus is um you know separate us from
other organizations um that on top of
the um the permanent housing for
Veterans which we all know in this state
um and I know from my experience as a
law enforcement officer that
homelessness not only for veterans but
across the straight is across the state
is a major issue um phase two uh where
efforts are currently under under
underway to raise an additional 23
million to fund fund our next uh next
phase and that's phase two which will be
an indoor Aquatics and fitness center so
we're going to have a inground pool four
lanes um we're partnering with swim with
the mission which I'm sure many of you
are familiar with um so that will be
located next to the retreat center
across the street we're going to have a
um these are going to be new builds new
construction um Recreation uh indoor
Recreation climbing wall ecoin facility
um the value of um I can speak from you
know personal experience the value of
ecoin therapy is um very very valuable
and is real we're also going to have a
dog dog C if you will um so we'll have a
k9 program on site we hope to be working
with Delta dog on that um so they've um
they've already committed to to come to
the team so that's going to be extremely
valuable particularly for them because
they're really hitting the the Southern
Tier of the state right now but we we
think we're missing veterans that can't
travel um to the southern part of the
state so that's why they'll have a
facility there as well um we're going to
have an outdoor um challenge course High
challenges low challenges really for all
abilities and at the end of the road
there on your map you'll see what's
called the Burley Cottage that's an
historical building that's being um we
have to maintain that that's being
completely rehabbed um and that will
include where probably we're going to
hang uh veterans count as you all know
is part of Easter Seals and has been
since 2007 um but that's probably what
they land um and also there's you know
there's 59 those are familiar with the
area there's 59 mies of 55 Mi of Trail
uh natural Trail and we're going to try
to take advantage of all the N natural
Recreation that's available in the area
um so we have the equin doyard outdoor
challenge course um and then this Burley
col cottage which I mentioned um we're
seeking approval to an addition off the
back of that um for like that that's
part is going to really Overlook the
river um and that's where we hope to
have art therapy um yoga type style um
you know therapy if you will uh for
veterans and First Responders and their
families um so that's that will bring us
to completion um frankly I think we're
had of schedule um if fundraising goes
as planned um in 2025 we hope to start
construction on phase two with all the
permitting and working with the city of
Franklin who by the way has been U Been
a great partner in this um our goal is
to begin Construction in phase two in
the fall of 201 5 um so we could be
fully complete um sometime you know mid
2026 which I think is um maybe a little
aggressive but um there's really no time
to
wait any other questions on are any
questions on the
map so really the call that you can sit
down Nick if you
want make me nervous behind me like that
um so the call to action you know the
need is dire um in 2021 an average of 17
veterans died by Suicide each day I'm
all I'm sure all of you are familiar
with these statistics in New Hampshire a
veteran takes their life on life every 8
Days um heartbreakingly the US
Department of Housing and urb
Development reported that about s 7 and
a half% increase in veteran homelessness
in
2023 with 20 with close to 36,000
veterans living in shelters cars parks
are on the streets our New Hampshire
service members deserve to come home to
the same support that they had while
they served
there was no wrong door for individuals
seeking assistance in the Easter Seals
in New Hampshire military and Veterans
campus promises to provide the necessary
tools for our veterans and their
families so representative Mr chairman I
hope that met your intent but I'm happy
to take any questions I know you're
crunched for time thank you Alan the
handout folder is fabulous and uh I have
to tell I can't take credit for that uh
that's okay um so I do want to make sure
everybody knows that this is in Franklin
it's a campus it used to be a like a
monastery type thing it was in um it was
an orphanage okay that's right yep they
went back my my history tells me like
late 1800s into the early 1900s um
Easter Seals Came Upon the property um
it was farham North in about 2015 and
then um Co happened and so that
substance abuse treatment facility shut
down so it's been dormant for about 4
years um so it was in the total need of
uh repurposing and really this is where
EA seals and many other organizations in
this probably many in this body and this
stepped up and provided the initial
funding which we're um extremely
grateful for and I think this is going
to be a game Cher um for veterans in the
state of New Hampshire and maybe Beyond
um the goal here sir is that this
becomes a model for the nation that they
look to New Hampshire and say look how
they're doing it um and let's try to
mirror what they're doing that's our
goal it's a big goal I recognize that
but I'm proud to be part of it yes I was
there for the ribbon cutting and I could
see the footprint I could see the
buildings there and at the ribbon
cutting in the presentation and I get a
walk through they showed us their vision
of what these buildings would turn into
so even then before You' even started
any construction it was exciting as
could be to imagine what is going to
happen there and governor sonuna was
there for the ribbon cutting yes he was
and he said what you just said this has
the potential to become uh uh a
prototype a model as you said and as the
governor said for the nation uh so I
just encourage you all to get there
sometime so the middle of next year it
could be completed June we'll probably
also be in office most of us by then and
uh maybe a field trip or something uh
it's amazing what's what's happening
there so that's that's all I want to say
any other questions go ahead rson mle B
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for for sharing the work you've been
doing with Easter Seals and this this
project I think it's really an
incredible plan and I'm very excited to
see how it comes together so I'm looking
at your methodology for Community
engagement I see that you did some site
visits um I'm wondering if you could
share maybe one or two Lessons Learned
From the site visit and how you've
Incorporated those findings into one was
the permanent housing okay um and the
other one was the the need for
recreation okay um and getting people
out um and really those are two big
lessons I wasn't part of that because I
wasn't on board yet but speaking with
the people that did it um that's really
what the big takeaway and that's why you
see the emphasis that we're on um and I
think that's why um you know we've been
able to get swim swim of the mission to
come to the table on the Recreation side
um Aquatics therapy so we're trying to
cover every Recreation angle that we can
um in who knows there may be a phase
three right I'm I'm eating up the 15
Acres pretty quick um but I want to
emphasize that the city of Franklin um
has been really excellent to deal with
particularly the Historical Society
we're sensitive to those things as well
um but I also think this is this is
going to be great for Franklin and
Beyond um I'll be honest with you
represent when I first heard about this
I was like oh Franklin like who's you
know I've been there nice you know it's
a city I think is going to make a
comeback in a lot of ways and probably
already has um but I got in my car and I
drove to Franklin from manchest and I'm
like yeah that's not that bad right if I
was a veteran i' I'd make the trip here
um it's beautiful it has a lot to
offer just you know Recreation natural
Recreation um so to your point
representative maet my business card is
in that folder if any of you want a tour
um please reach out to me directly
between now and whenever and two three
of you will get you up there so you can
get eyes on um because it's come a long
way since that initial ribbon cutting
can only imagine uh other questions uh
represent Foss thank you uh and expect
an email from me because I would love it
toour this looks gorgeous if you if it
has to be a weekend too I we'll
accommodate oh fantastic um I'm a
housing nerd so I'm I'm learning so
affordable is that tied into the uh
median income in Franklin is that the
definition you're using for affordable
that's my understanding yeah yeah um am
I allowed to ask another question uh
yeah so um just the you said permanent
housing so is this the expectation that
it's going to be um people are going to
live there it's not like a transitional
people live there while they y do you
have a plan for uh are you going to use
like a lottery cuz I can imagine there's
probably going to be a huge weight list
or huge demand for being in this housing
yeah right now we um we open the portal
and if you go to the website at the top
of the bar you you can navigate right to
the housing application oh so you're
already taking applications you're
already taking applications and as of um
as of a couple days ago they were up to
about 24 um doesn't mean they've all
qualified um so Easter sales has a whole
housing um Department if you will
residential Department that is handling
that part of the permanent um um but
yeah we we haven't done any paid
advertising yet that's probably the next
step um because we we really got to get
those those numbers up we want to get to
a point where we you know have a
legitimate weight list and maybe we can
then refer those people somewhere else
that we can't accommodate you but
perhaps Harbor care can help and vice
versa so we're all working together
thank you so you mentioned residential
and Recreation is there much potential
for an event uh what kind of events if
any could this uh campus that's where
that's where Nick's going to come in I
brought him on as my marketing
salesperson um he's got a almost you
know close to 20 years of experience
doing that type of work so yeah we're
we're looking at that could this be a
potential wedding venue um could it be
you know a location for corporations to
hold an event um right you know we have
because we have to think sustainability
from a business plan side so you know
veterans and First resp Responders are
the priority but
we have to build a model that allows us
to sustain ourselves over the next 20 to
30 years whatever it is um really what
I'm at with this is all of you know we
live in a volatile world right now um
we've had our deployments um we don't
know what's going to happen in this
world um so as a campus as an
organization we need to be ready um so
should we find ourselves as a nation at
War again I hope not um that should that
happen we're going to have a whole new
batch of veterans and families that are
going to be struggling and those that's
the Fallout we all know that of war um
you know well we had a presentation from
the veterans home uh comendant and
that's for veterans but this is a place
for families uh potentially more than
just a veteran in some cases so that to
me is very
exciting uh thanks so much L and Nick
for this any other questions or anything
for either Al or
neck make a comment um I just wanted to
point out um it really stood out to me
the range of the therapy options that
you have here I think a lot of people
don't always equate you know veterans in
yoga you know but I think that's I tried
it it was ugly I tried it's really
important you know especially if people
have PTSD things like that we need to be
using all the tools we can put in her
toolbox so I really appreciate that and
the other thing we're going to have a um
a playground on site as well so when
families come with children um it's a
military themed playground if you will
but I'm sure all of you probably
familiar with the Elliott Perry
Foundation um they're they'll be um
donating the funds for that so we
Partnerships are being built on a daily
basis so if any of you through your
networks build that there somebody that
we should be partnering with um please
reach out to me and I'll I'll make the
connection We're All in This Together
together excellent anything
else uh yes repr Hemingway Mr aldenberg
I appreciate your uh your service both
of you and I I really think this is a
great idea and and definitely uh we'll
take time to come and see you in the in
the near future thank you sir thank you
appreciate it you're all
welcome thanks again for your time great
work can't wait to see the finished
project and uh carry on I guess carry
thank you ladies and
gentlemen all right folks Let's uh get
right to it uh executive session um the
first item up is uh hb10 which has to do
with transferring statutory Authority
from Department of Education doe to
dmav Department of military and
Veterans uh so I'm looking for to
representative cyber for a motion on
a motion for a to
pass and Madame clerk slow us down
anytime uh
if uh we have a second from
representative
jery
okay uh representative cyber would you
motion yeah um oh
sorry um I believe this is was just a
housekeeping measure um it was requested
of us and if it streamlines and makes
things easier for our um Department of
military and veteran services I'm all
for
it represent JY would you care to speak
second I think is a good project and
also my previous speaker said all of
them thank you representative anyone
else have anything to add or discuss
this is executive session after all
seeing No Hands uh Madame clerk when you
are
ready you can read the role the motion
hb220 the before we read the RO I want
to thank the two subs today is
representative
Raymond yes uh uh subbing on the blue
team and representative Dolan is here on
the red side for representative lungren
thank you both for sitting in and uh
when the clerk is ready we will vote on
so Tom Dolan is subing for uh L Dolan
yeah so you want to make that those two
Corrections
right
morning for the roll call all right uh
Vice chairman Rollins
yes uh representative Dolan
yes representative levit
yes representative Gagney
yes representative
Manion yes representative
beler yes representative
Bennett yes representative Hemingway
yes I representative plant yes
representative
cybert yes representative
Judy we mam representative Lloyd yes
representative Jones yes um clerk Mandel
bam is a yes is that how I should refer
to
myself um representative Buddha thaki
yes
a representative fos yes and uh
representative Raymond yes and chairman
yes 14
Z yes uh repres Jones
thank you very much uh with no objection
we'll put this unanimous uh
recommendation on the consent calendar
there's no fiscal note I don't believe
so uh for for the new reps that means
that uh it'll be part of a package to be
approved if someone wants to pull it off
and bring it to the floor they can uh
but when we have these unanimous or near
unanimous votes uh then we look toh put
them on the consent calendar thank you
representative Jones make the that yes I
was just going to get to that uh
represent cyber as you know is a veteran
lawmaker the person who makes the motion
typically we look to for a committee
report y so I'll chat with you real
quick after the session we'll nail down
all the reports yeah which is very
important uh these reports last forever
in the archives if you write a report
your name will be uh in the archives
forever I'm trying to encourage people
to do reports yes all right so moving
right along hb1 22 next up uh that has
to do with claims against New Hampshire
Army National Guard for training damage
if they run over a mailbox as we heard
in the hearing or
Worse um so I'm going to look to
representative Jones I understand you
may have a
motion thank you Mr chair yeah I would
make a motion to OTP this bill we have a
second second representative F seconds
that
representative uh Jones would you care
to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair uh this is
very simple uh very very minuscule
compared to so many of the other things
we do uh simply the governor and Council
upon the recommendation of the adant
general May pay claims against the state
arising out of accidents occasioned by
the activities of the National Guard or
arising out of claims brought against
the department of military Affairs and V
Affairs and it just raises it
from uh $500 to
$1,000 and it's the simplest fiscal note
I've ever seen since I've been
on yeah uh if you just read it it's it's
a legislation has a total fiscal impact
of less than $10,000 so we're not
talking about them a lot
here thank you abative representative F
would you like to speak to your
second what representative Jones said
thank you for that anyone else have any
uh comments or questions or discussion
on this HB
122 seeing nothing uh M Madam or Madame
Melle
chair Madam chair Madam chair uh
representative uh when you're ready the
122 thank you Mr chairman
um Vice chairman Rollins
yes Representative
lungren no sorry sorry I didn't update
that um representative Dolan yes
representative levit yes representative
Gagney yes representative Manion yes
representative Belcher yes
representative
Bennett yes representative
Hemingway yes representative plant yes
representative cybert
yes representative
Judy we Madame representative Lloyd yes
representative
Jones yes clerk also votes yes
buddasi yes representative Foss yes
representative Raymond yes all right so
it's
180 I would like to vote to Madam chair
I'm so sorry oh chairman M and the the
chair will vote Yes as well all right Mr
chair once again I'd like to recommend
consent if you're okay with that no
objection to consent um Madame chair
will put that that on consent as well
representative Jones you're up for the
committee
report yeah yes is the okay yes and
we'll nail that down before everybody
leaves okay okay excellent moving right
along to our third measure this is
hcr8 house concurrent resolution 8
urging Congress to review the state
boundary in the piscatqua river that's
the boundary uh between Maine and New
Hampshire apparently there is some gray
area some ambiguity some uncertainty uh
that the uh sponsors would like to
request some definition on uh represent
Manion do you have a motion for this one
I do Mr chair I move OTP on hd8 and do
we have a
second second representative Rollins
seconds the OTP motion representative
Manion would you care to speak to that
motion yeah so uh with the ever change I
know that they've made rulings on this
before on like what uh whether the
Portman Port Portsmouth Naval Shipyard
is on our territory and their ter Main's
territory uh and I think with the
everchanging uh landscape at the federal
level it's worth urging the Congress to
take another look at this uh currently
we have a lot of um residents that
currently live on our side that are
being taxed main income tax amongst
other things uh just from crossing the
river um uh as a guy who lives down on
the mass border I'm already experiencing
this kind of Taxation all the time
because I work in Mass uh and I was
taxed even though I wasn't allowed to
set foot in the country in the state in
2020 and that was taxation without
representation I would say thank
you thank you for that uh anything to
add representative
Rollins uh not really um basically I
don't think it I don't think it's right
that that people in New Hampshire have
to pay the taxes I I see this should
should have been right from the
beginning in Portsmouth in New
Hampshire the the shipy should be
located in New Hampshire and we should
have full say
in okay uh sovereignty issue you're
supporting there anything else on on
this uh
HCR uh Madam CL before I ask you to read
the role I know you are from Portsmith
yourself I believe and I know and I
appreciate I could tell you you've done
some due diligence and reached out uh
anything be being that you that is your
District so to speak uh anything that
you want to say to this um just that the
city of Portsmith is neutral on this
resolution um Congressman Chris papis is
also neutral um and the town of
Newington is in support of
it so Newton is forward and the elected
officials are neutral okay um yes
representative gagy thank you Mr
chairman as we all know the state seal
has the ship the Raleigh that's our
state seal so why shouldn't the ship
belongs yes our state flag the ship on
that if you didn't know is the Raleigh
which presumably was built uh I'm
guessing in Portsmouth there certainly a
Portsmouth connection right anything
else a representative Lloyd thank you um
I just wanted to say on on record that
um I believe that this is the proper
procedure to have our federal delegation
figure this out and try to push for this
and and um to push through a resolution
on that piece of of
of of uh
argument sorry thank you representative
Lloyd this resolution does not offer a
prescri of solution to your point I
believe what this does is shine a light
on a situation that we're looking for
better definition presumably because
it's a New Hampshire resolution uh we
want to be treated uh fairly as the as
this definition comes about anything
else representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair um I believe in
what everyone's saying I just think that
timing is off because of uh I think with
po politics in DC right now if it
becomes uh New Hampshire versus Maine
New Hampshire is on the wrong side of
the aisle right now and uh so I don't
think it's the right time to pass
else okay Madame clerk when you are
hcr8 is ought to pass on
the recommendation the resolution to
review the state boundary and the
piscatqua
uh so for the motion ought to pass um
Vice chairman Rollins yes representative
Dolan yes representative levit yes
representative Gagney yes representative
Manion yes representative belshire yes
representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes Representative
cybert
no representative Judy
no representative
Lloyd yes representative Jones
no um clerk votes yes Representative
budak
no representative fos yes representative
Raymond
yeah
134 thir uh 14 to four you said
um
14 yeah 144 so OTP is approved or pass
14 to4 represent a Manion I'm looking to
you for a majority report will there be
a Minority Report
yeah
yeah okay there will be a Minority
Report we'll nail that down before we
all leave today okay okay so there's
four down uh next up on our list is hp64
which deals with hiring preferences for
military person uh military spouses uh
I've been in touch with the ranking
member and there's some interest in
working on a amendment in tweaking some
of the language so we are going to I am
going to postpone executing this measure
until a week from today uh
representative cyber so the uh Amendment
if this one forth coming if that could
be pushed out to the committee as soon
as as soon as it's ready so I I actually
stand corrected with that one is that we
um that other issue wasn't as big that
I'd sent over to you just about the
clarification of that whatever word but
um one thing that was brought up to me
and I wasn't here that day of the
hearing was in regards to the Department
of Labor's request in regards to how do
they defining how they
specify you know if a spouse is really
an active military duty spouse because
they really have nothing to prove that
which I think is an issue that has been
brought up by our veterans affairs um
folks
previously um so it's up to us if or you
know the committee as a whole if we want
to just go ahead and send it over to the
Senate and let them do it there or do we
want to do that within the week yes uh
representative what you just said about
sending it over to the Senate where we
try not to say that especially
sorry I forgot about that I forgot
that're qualified like everywhere but
the uh but your point is well taken the
language is uh is is fairly close uh I I
have spoken to the prime sponsor about
this and that we don't necessarily want
the perfect to be the enemy of the good
I think that uh my sense is that the uh
consensus here is that we support the
notion of of supporting military spouses
were getting uh a chance that maybe they
would not get otherwise at an employment
situation the hearing provided ample
testimony and rationale behind this and
I uh understand it and support it uh we
could exact this today if if there is
not going to be Amendment forthcoming
then we can um I I would make the motion
for OTP if if yeah if you wanted to
second that and then we can um we can
move it
forward right Madam clerk uh I am going
to make the motion for OTP on
hp64 with regard to uh military
spouses and the as I just said the
testimony was very compelling and the
rationale for supporting military
families uh for many reasons is as I
just said is compelling given the
sacrifices that not only the the
military people make M male or female in
and the spouses uh which some of us know
firsthand uh would you like to add is
the second or um no I I completely agree
it's totally straightforward
so makes sense representative cyber did
the second oh yeah second sorry would
would anyone else like to add anything
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman um as many of you may know I
Serv on the child and family law
committee and we had a bill um this week
on a tangental matter um regarding some
um military retirement pay um but there
were a number of military spouses um and
former spouses that came to testify on
our Bell um and they spoke at length at
the difficulty that they had finding
either full-time employment or
employment that offered benefits um
during all of the deployments that they
experienced during their marriage and so
um I was really excited to sub in here
and see this bill because it addresses a
lot of the issues that the spouses were
talking about in our committee
so thank you so much for that repor
Raymond I was involved with the bill the
measure that went to CH children and
family law on that on that issue and and
uh thank you very much for sharing that
I appreciate it we appreciate it any
anything else representative Lloyd thank
you Mr chairman um I just would like to
CLA or add a little bit of um light on
the uh on what the do had suggested as
far as like a potential Amendment um
clarifying how to recognize someone as a
military spouse I'm looking at this as
an end user uh working in HR and payroll
um for over 18 years how do
you they kind of wanted us to kind of
look at some identifying um feature that
they could turn to that would say yes
this is absolutely a military spouse I'm
not a at all opposed to this um this
bill uh in fact I want to see it otpd
and to your I just don't want to I just
want to make sure that we have what we
need in place for the
do thank you representative Lloyd there
is the option of a floor Amendment if if
we if you or if anybody can uh identify
any language tweak that would address
the do piece uh that is an option too um
and then there's the option that
representative cyber mentioned earlier
that we don't want to talk about again
so anything else I represent
Manion yeah so uh during my time when I
was down in Camp L June like he had a
lot of guys 18 19 years old getting
married real young and it's uh a big
commitment to ask your wife to move like
across the country down to these bases
and a lot of times they they're Fish Out
of Water they don't know anybody they
they it could be a huge culture shock
depending on what region of the country
they come from and anything that can
help them along similar here in this
state I think do do a lot of good for
them absolutely totally know what you're
talking about I've seen it a lot myself
anything
else okay seeing no other hands Madam
clerk when you are ready we will we will
vote on hp64
regarding hiring military spouses the
the motion is OTP all right for the
motion of OTP on
hp64 uh Vice chairman Rollins yes
representative Dolan yes representative
lebit yes representative Gagney yes
representative Manion yes representative
Belcher yes representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes representative
cybert
yes representative Judy
we representative Lloyd yes
representative Jones yes uh
representative Mandel bound votes yes
representative budak yes representative
fos yes representative Raymond yes uh
chairman Moffett yes all right final
180 representative
Jones even though it was unanimous vote
I don't think we should put this on
consent agenda because this possibility
of a four Amendment yes excellent point
so this will not be on consent thank you
very much for that
report correct okay HB HB 55 repealing
The Selective Service compliance act
okay I have an amendment we have an
amendment that I'd like to
introduce uh I've emailed everybody the
amendment the uh amendment number Madame
clerk uh you should have a copy
somewhere I have one right here it's a
0174 h for house so it's Amendment 0174
H for
house and uh I need a second before I
can speak to my Amendment I'll second
that okay thank you representative
Rollin seconds the uh amending motion
that I put forward I'll speak to her
right now briefly and the I've sent this
out I've emailed everybody on this
before we've had some back and forth on
it what this amendment does is it
changes the
original
measure which had to do with let me find
the original measure
here the original proposal or Bill hp55
Selective Service it sought to change
and take out from RSA
187-a colon 39 paragraph 1 sections a b
c and d it if you're tracking me the
original sought to remove all those from
statute uh so the concern that came up
that this amendment tries to address is
that uh folks we listen to that I listen
to We all listen to from uh the veteran
Community dmav uh did not support the
measure that had some of the aspects in
it that would be precluded from sections
from that uh paragraph one section c and
d so the amendment uh removes C and
D from the the bill but it keeps in A
and B which is what postsecondary was
hoping for was important to postc
secondary so this compromise Amendment
will satisfy postsecondary in that it
takes out the parts of the selective
service requirements that impact uh the
university in the in the
colleges but it leaves in the part that
DMS wanted to stay in which is uh sub
paragraphs C and D under paragraph one
under 187-a 39 so that is the uh the
amendment
which I hope the committee will support
compromise Amendment and uh R Rollins do
you want to add
anything uh no thank
you anyone else repr Manion yes so the
compromise here is that uh since the
federal government isn't even enforcing
this with their fasta reg regulations
that are going through this year that
they're no longer requiring compliance
with the Selective Service registration
uh it doesn't make any sense for the
state to do it either so removing just
the components that have to do with the
the the SEC postsecondary is puts us in
sync with what the federal government's
doing
already thank you rep representative
Manion who was the Prime sponsor of this
originally anything else representative
for uh yes and just uh to go further on
that uh it's my understanding that this
uh the aspect of the current
postsecondary requirement is very
honorous for the University system of
New Hampshire because they need to do
EXT extra leg work because it's not on
the FAFSA people don't have to check off
whether or not they they uh complied
with the selective service act so the
university system has to uh expend extra
effort to determine whether or not they
did in order to allow them to apply for
a state school and state aid and uh I
know they are strapped for cash right
now so that's if we got rid of this then
that would help them a lot with their
workload and their
budget thank you for amplifying that rep
of Ross rep representative F yes the
university system was very much in favor
of uh of this of this HB anything else
show on
this yes we can before before we go to
represent gagne's idea or suggestion
represent of hening way you had a hand
up thank you Mr chairman I just like to
speak to this uh I appreciate the
amendment uh if it wasn't for this
amendment I'd probably vote no on this
only because I think there is a
requirement to have a ready force in the
backup with the many theaters that
were're on front right now uh I thought
that to take away the right for or the
requirement for Selective Service
registry uh was not a good one but as
long as we keep the requirement to
register but we've taken away the
funding piece for the colleges I'm good
with that thank you representative
Hemingway yes I think the amendment was
something that hopefully will work
because it satisfies postsecondary and
it also satisfies the the military side
anything else represent Jones Thank you
Mr chair I just wanted to tell you yes I
do appreciate the amendment um I didn't
like the amendment that that the was
suggested by the uh General um I thought
that brought us backwards to where we to
the very beginning but uh I think this
this amendment um makes a good
fix thank you representative anything
else okay veteran legislator lawmaker
gagy pointed out that we do have the
option or I have the option of calling
for a a hand vote uh on the amendment
which I'm going to do so if you support
the amendment uh would you please raise
your right hand so that the clerk can
is like everyone has does anyone not
have their hand up right okay the clerk
has
certified that the Amendment passed is
18 to Zer so now that brings us to
another motion that we will need if
we're going to move this forward which
would be uh a motion I'm going to look
would be an
otpa ought to pass as amended motion I'm
going to look to the prime sponsor
representative Manion for a motion thank
hp55 representative JY seconds the
motion represent Manion would you like
to add anything I think we covered the
the issues that a lot of people had with
the original bill and I think this
covers everything here the postsecondary
is Happy the agent General's happy and
we can move on representative
everything any further comment reps and
F thank you um I just wanted to add that
um because I am uh
enthusiastic in general uh I did a lot
of research on other states requirements
and how that correlates with their
Selective Service compliant rates uh New
Hampshire has a
75.1% compliance rate uh but there's not
really a strong correlation with having
uh laws like this in place compliance at
the state level and a higher rate of
compliance for example Connecticut has a
100% compliance but does not have uh a
requirement for State schools or a
requirement for uh State Employment uh
let's see I did um if anything it seems
as though places that automatically
register you when you get your driver's
license or places that have you have to
actively opt out have higher rates of
compliance in New Hampshire you have to
actively opt in uh
but in general it doesn't seem as though
this Le this current legislation uh not
the legisl yes exactly the current law
is really serving its
purpose thank you very much for that we
have a a very good researcher Davis
who's with us in the room but uh thank
you for taking the initiative to do that
that uh is very interesting and helpful
appreciate
that anything
else seeing No Hands madam clerk when
you are ready the current motion is
otpa on hp55 regarding Selective Service
compliance all right on the motion of
otpa on
hp55 um Vice chairman Rollins how do you
yes representative Dolan yes
representative levit yes representative
Gagney yes representative
Manion yes representative Belcher yes
representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes representative
cybert yes representative Judy we Madam
representative Lloyd yes representative
Jones yes um I representative Mandel
bound votes yes representative
budak yes representative fos yes
representative Raymond yes chairman
Moffet yes all right so uh 180
okay I will do the report for that and I
believe it can go on consent uh with the
amendment the uh speaker will ask the
Full House to approve the amendment so
that would be a consent item as well yes
uh can I question that uh go ahead
represent Jones yeah go ahead only uh I
don't know because it was amended after
the public hearing for transparency's
sake should we not put it on the consent
agenda yeah that's an interesting point
that's kind of what I was touching on
because we did amend it uh if it
qualifies for for um for consent and I
think we can uh to be safe we won't put
it on consent Madam
clerk thank you for that
you
okay that brings us to HB 256 that's the
uh recommended proposed us s Liberty
study committee uh that was a motion
that was a measure that was a bill that
came about based on an interim study
recommendation from a similar bill that
we dealt with last term repent Manion
was the Prime sponsor ranion I'm going
to look to you for a motion here cor I
wasn't the prime but uh yeah I'm so my
motion here is to
retain and uh a second we need a second
for that I'll second that represent
Rollins seconds that uh okay so
represent Manion if you would speak to
your
motion absolutely
so I fully I I support the underlying uh
committee that we should be doing I
think we need time to kind of come I
think as a committee uh perhaps find the
best solution forward for these men uh
the committee is a great idea there's
also another potential idea coming
forward uh but we need more time uh that
we put over
over the summer we can come back to this
in the fall and then really give these
men something uh anything to help
them representative Rollins thank you Mr
chair in the 13 years I've been here I
have never had a bill that I've been
more passionate about than getting
something done with this bill in EN
closure for these men that were on that
ship I'm very
pro-israel don't have a problem with
that but to me I put I put our men and
women in the service first before
anything else these men and women signed
on the dotted line up to and including
their own lives okay they did not sign
that dotted line to be a sacrificial
lamb we have got to get to the get down
to this I'm praying next year we get on
it to give these men on that ship and
their family's closure on this issue
okay and I understand that this may be a
quicker way to do it than a study
committee because it would probably take
longer we can have this have a fall
meeting on this we can get it first on
the first on the list for voting next
year so it may be a quicker solution to
the problem but we've got to we got to
stand by this we've got to stick to this
we've got to do something for these men
and women my my heart bleeds for every
one of these guys I think the stories
that we heard in the testimonies the
first guy that spoke it was the first
time that he's ever spoke to anyone
about what his experiences were on this
closure thank you very much
representative Rollins I'll say that the
testimony we received last term in this
term was very very emotional there's a
New Hampshire connection to the there
New Hampshire people on the ship a lot
of new englanders were on the ship the
uh I think it was the intelligence
officer died not that long ago from
coldbrook so there is a New Hampshire
connection of
course and as the vice chair just
touched on to to do a committee uh would
certainly maybe
hopefully end up with something out of
that that would move this situation
forward so that some light can be shined
where it needs to be shined for these
men who came from uh different parts of
the country last term and this term
looking to be
heard so what can happen with this being
retained we'll come back to it we will
have to come back to it in some fashion
but one of the things that we're we've
talked about doing is putting in an hjr
we talked about an hjr earlier today on
a different matter house joint
resolution which we could put in in
September in some fashion submit it for
the next uh for next year and house Jr
would maybe do what a committee would
have recommended anyway which should
which may have been to do uh NH hjr we
can just go ahead and and work one up
put something together submit it in
September and of course as we said
earlier a house joint resolution
involves the house if it goes forward
from the house it goes to the Senate and
then it also involves the governor uh
perhaps there could be a proclamation
it's a touchy issue for those of you
watching remotely or are aware of the
the hearing that we had this year and
last
term what happened in 1967 the USS
liberity was a US Naval vessel that was
attacked by the Israeli armed forces and
almost sunk uh many men were killed many
more were injured the captain got a
medal of honor but it was covered up
frankly uh it was uh hush hushed it was
covered up the men were
threatened not to talk about it and uh I
was I'm old enough to remember that
incident and the survivors were told not
to talk about it and most of them lot of
them were gone but some of the ones who
took the time to come and look to us
here in New Hampshire for whatever
reason however that first came up the
survivors are begging
literally for some answers that still
have not been forthcoming so if if our
body if our committee if our house our
legislature possibly even the Govern
govern if this goes to an hjr can shine
a light and maybe get some answers maybe
get some things Declassified so that the
men while they're still around can get
some answers and hopefully as
representative Rowan said some closure
so that's our intent so by retaining
this it's not that we are not going to
take immediate action we are looking to
cyber uh do you mind Mr chairman if I is
that okay yes please representative
Lloyd um so sorry um so I have I
appreciate um your suggestion of putting
through a resolution to this uh or for
this especially because I feel like if
this had been brought to us as a
resolution I think it would have been
across the board OTP immediately my I
guess my concern with retain and I have
no objection to retaining this is is it
going to prolong the length of time that
we have to wait do we need to itl it
first and
then put through the
resolution I understand your
point by not passing it the option was a
of doing a committee the thought was
that's going to take a lot of time and
is it is that the best use of our time
when we have another option which would
be an HDR
if but if we I if we itl it it's done of
course we would go to the house and the
house would have to approve our
committee recommendation if we retain it
it gives us the option of coming back to
it which we will have to in in the fall
and then the first session in January
the retain motions will be uh attended
to so I get your point it's a good point
I think I think retention works because
it gives us in a sense two btes at the
Apple if you're tracking me
other comments represent gagy Naval
chairman if any of you survivors in um
siblings of
survivors uh you have not been abandoned
I want you to know I'm supposed to be a
tough guy I was a martial arts
instructor back in the last
century I was a kickboxer it's Etc
supposed to be a tough guy but I'm
having a hard time because listen to you
guys testifying here I'm a tint Can
Sailor so I know that when you're on
board ship there's no place to hide when
the stuff starts coming in there's no
place to hide if you're if you're above
deck then you get shrapnel if you're
below deck you take an incoming and
drown anyway
you have not been abandoned this whole
the whole reason why we're retaining
this so we can get some more clout so
you guys can be heard before it's over
listen to me those of you are listening
to me today on
TV call your elected officials call your
Congressional
Delegation because my understanding I
get a lot of email from uh congressman
papis Pro
veteran things will happen if they get
involved with this my problem was why
was that ship moved from the west coast
of Africa which was its stomping grounds
ordered to go just barely beyond the
statues of limitation the the U the
boundaries the 12 mile boundary of
Israel and why was it covered up when
the Jets were coming they were told to
stand down something happened there
that's not right you're not
abandoned thank you for that
representative gagy anything
else representative Rollins thank you Mr
chairman um for the sake of those from
you from the USS Liberty that are
watching this today I would like to ask
with your permission Mr chairman I show
a hands for
everyone on this committee that support
you and want to get you guys closure
would you mind if I did that this is an
unofficial straw pole uh who who
supports uh represent to your question
uh so go ahead
representative thank you Mr chairman you
men have not been forgotten you won't be
forgotten um a number of us have really
toiled on this one
bad it's really hard
I want you guys to have
closure and we're going to be here we
haven't given up on you and we're coming
back next year I hope with all guns
firing and I think all of us will be on
board with that and and we can get with
you what you've asked for answerers to
your questions in
closure meantime love you guys thank you
representative Rollins represent Lloyd
thank you Mr chairman um so this is more
of a a rules question I suppose but is
there any way that we could come
together as a committee to try to come
up with some other workarounds that
might actually help these veterans in
the meantime while we're waiting for
some type of resolution to
this sure represent thank you for your
question and comment uh to your point of
course uh we're all of us to some degree
are invested and in and care about this
is we spent a lot of time on it last
term and this term uh my my response
would be that if we're going to put in a
resolution hjr which needs to be
submitted September not that far off we
we can use this time to put together a
njr worded in such a fashion that could
site some new information to your point
to make that uh a more powerful
meaningful
substantive uh resolution does that
touch on your your point yes thank you
Mr chairman um I'm just wondering if
there's anything outside of the
legislative process that we could look
into as a as a group to try to get these
veterans some relief um in the meantime
as far as um working with veteran
services or or something along those
lines yes I think that's a very great
idea and that's something as you said uh
off I'm trying to think of the right
term um offline or whatever not formally
or officially but I think that those of
us who are invested in this can
certainly we let's talk later uh not not
right here about some things that we can
look at doing to to make a difference
and move this forward I I
agree anything else representa
Jones um I'm sorry M Mr chair but can I
ask you or the motion maker just to once
again tell me the benefit of retaining
the motion to retain I I'll speak to it
and then uh ranion or anybody else can
can add to
this and the concern was doing a
committee and committees are not
necessarily popular with with everybody
for a combination of reasons one of
which being the the the Personnel
demands who's going to be in the
committee when are they going to
meet and also the time Factor
if a committee meets and then they
recommend action we can't take any
action until September uh or next year
anyway uh at least in terms of
legislative action so if the committee
is going to take all this time and
recommend uh which I would anticipate
they would do maybe a series of actions
Beyond a resolution that to
representative Lloyd's point I think we
can look at some of those alternative
actions on our own to support the uh the
survivors but to do a committee that's
going to recommend a resolution we can
just do the resolution without going
through all that's involved with with
getting a committee approved by the Full
House which we don't know that would
would necessarily happen so so that's
hopefully answers your question some
whatat representative Manion do can you
amplify that I think that's kind of like
the discussion we've been having is
that's probably the best course of
action that's a very good answer thank
you anything
else seeing no other hands the motion on
the floor is to retain HB 256 with
regard to a USS Liberty study committee
when you're ready Madame chair that is
the motion
retain on the motion to retain HB
256 um how do you vote Vice chairman
Rollins yes
representative Dolan yes representative
levit yes representative Gagney yes
representative uh Manion yes
representative beler yes representative
Bennett yes representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes representative
cybert yes representative Judy we Madam
representative Lloyd yes representative
Jones yes um representative mandal bam
votes yes representative Buddha th
yes representative fos yes
representative Raymond yes chairman
Moffett yes all right 180 18 to zero on
retain all right we'll move along now to
hcr9 hcr9 that is with regard to raising
awareness through Congress concerning
the brutality ongoing in
Bangladesh uh the prime sponsor is here
welcome representative Khan uh you're
here and uh if we have any questions
appreciate you being around in case
something comes up we want to ask the
prime sponsor someone was uh the number
you said hcr9 uh I believe that's is
that the right
11 right if I said nine I believe it
should be HCR 11 not nine thank
you with regard to raising awareness
through Congress concerning the
brutality in Bangladesh we had a
extended hearing on that we had uh some
uh folks who spoke at Great length I did
not realize what was going on but before
I speak uh we need a uh a motion in
represent Manion uh do you have a motion
thank you Mr chair I motion OTP on
hcr1 and a second is from
whoes represent gagy seconds represent
manions OTP motion on
hcr1 representative Manion to your
motion yeah so uh we heard a great
amount of testimony from people that
have lived there know first or
secondhand what's going on uh I'm
personally very interested in US foreign
policy and I like to know what's going
on with the inter workings of other
countries where we have Investments um
and from the sounds of this uh I mean I
don't want to make too many judgment
calls but it sounds an awful lot like
this could have been an external uh
Force came into this country and as uh
fomenting Rebellion it could be an
adversary to the United States could be
linked to Al-Qaeda an enemy of the
United States States uh and I would so I
urge Congress to investigate
this R
gagy all that the representative said
and
also to boil it all down to one sentence
save Bangladesh and its people from
Injustice thank you representative I'll
just say which I started to say before I
did not realize what was going on there
and I do try to stay somewhat AB breast
of what's going on in the world and I
did not know until this
resolution came forward uh exactly how
bad it sounds like what has happened in
Bangladesh formerly East Pakistan so we
had a good uh history lesson during the
hearing very passionate testimony from
the prime sponsor and from other uh
people from his his Circle so uh I want
to thank the prime sponsor for helping
shine a light on something that people
need to know about and so I think this
resolution can help with that if it
moves forward to raise awareness and
shine a light on something that needs to
be that people need to be more aware of
thoughts uh representative cyber I would
just like to say that U on top of this
measure which I fully agree with um I
also just want to add that um I condemn
any religious persecution or or
oppression anywhere in the world by any
other
religion and and I definitely even more
so and for a separation of church and
state that's what causes a lot of these
problems that certainly ties into the
greater issue
here anything
else representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair when we were
discussing this I tried the word Smith
and I I recommended uh changing the word
allegations incidents but I think we're
better off sticking with allegations the
way it is so I just want to say I'm not
going to
change thank you for
that anything
else seeing No Hands the motion is to
OTP the motion is ought to pass on acr1
raising awareness through Congress
concerning the brutality ongoing in
Bangladesh madame chair Madame clerk
Madam clerk when you're ready all right
on the motion of OTP hcr1 how do you
vote chairman Rollins yes representative
Dolan yes representative levit yes
representative Gagney yes representative
Manion yes representative Belcher yes
representative Bennett yes
representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes representative
cybert yes representative Judy we Madam
representative lyd yes representative
Jones yes representative Mandel bamb
votes yes representative budak yes
representative Foss yes representative
Raymond yes chairman Moffet yes all
right
180 180 it is R man I'll talk to you
about uh a committee report afterwards
figure out how that works okay we have
I I would not put this on the regular
calendar because I would want someone to
speak to it on the
floor right so this will not be a
consent item even though it was
unanimous so good question no not on
consent it will go to the floor for a
vote
okay we have two more to go uh which uh
we'll get to right
here right when I said
hcr9 uh I miss I spoke to ear that was
hcr1 hcr9 is what we're up to now and
that has to do with rejecting compliance
with the European unions
csdd and we need a that was the the uh
HCR brought in by representative
Bernardi so I need a motion I Look to uh
maybe representative Belzer here for a
motion on
hcr9 thank you Mr chairman I would move
a to
pass and do we have a
second rep some Manion seconds okay uh
representative Bela would you care to
speak to your OTP motion yes thank you
Mr
chairman so the EU corporate syst
stainability due diligence directive
represents an attempt to inflict on the
United States extr territorially a host
of rather awful measures that were just
recently resoundingly defeated in
America at The Ballot Box what is
happening here is
Insidious these measures would reduce
the quality of life by promoting
degrowth of energy and economics and
Institute ideological nepotism Via entri
de EI
policies if these corporations got
together of their own accord and schemed
behind closed doors to adopt these
policies we would call that a crime
under anti-competitive laws it
represents cartel activity it goes
against the New Hampshire Constitution
Article
83 when a government partners with or
coerces corporations into the same
behavior we have something worse than a
criminal cartel
by usurping the freedoms of speech and
Association of these private companies
the governments in compelling these
corporations effectively turned them
into an arm of government itself and
they utilize these quasi private quasi
public entities to circumvent laws meant
to limit
government let me make the point via a
couple brief historic
quotes the first quote that is relevant
here relates to government efforts to
require social activism via Private
Business everything within the state
nothing outside the state nothing
against the
state that quote is attributable to
Italian fascist dictator Bonito musolini
further making this point musolini can
be quoted as saying fascism should more
properly be called corporatism because
it is a merger of state and corporate
power this is precisely what this EU
measure is trying to inflict it is a
fascistic means to implement an
ideological agenda that was rejected by
the American people now what is the
agenda itself as I already noted the
foundation of so-called sustainability
according to the United Nations and the
EU is the concept of degrowth simply put
it is the destruction of economic
activity the reduction of human
population the strict limiting of energy
production travel restrictions and much
more where can we learn about this model
of degrowth
for that we look to the work of
prominent German educated Japanese
philosopher kohi Saito and his book
marks in the anthropos scene toward the
idea of degrowth
Communism should you doubt this is real
I would encourage you to look up the
plans already formulated in the EU EU
under this policy to shutter the
majority of airports in the coming
decades to reserve air travel solely for
privileged
Elites to Germany's historically crazy
energy policy that produced a massive
recession in their economy the
censorship regime enacted across the EU
along the construct of hate speech and
toward the importation of a foreign
horde into Europe in exactly the manner
described by Aristotle over two
Millennia
ago these policies are nothing short of
civilizational suicide on the same scale
as mau's Great Leap Forward and Stalin's
like lysen coist plant
science the Soviet ties don't end there
either as the Soviets under linen
established the world's first Dei
program called
Corin
corinia in Russian and this EU mandate
includes these same inspired Dei
programs the attempt by the EU to force
these policies on the American people
from across the Atlantic should be seen
as nothing short of a hostile act
against the United States of America and
it should be dealt with that way by our
federal government so I will be
supporting this thank you thank you for
speaking to you motion representative uh
second or was representative Manion do
you want to add yeah everything he said
was brilliant uh the one thing I was
like like during that uh testimony we
were talking about how all the
downstream smaller corporations are now
going to be afflicted with this uh
burdensome regulations coming across the
seas and it could uh filter down they
were talking about I think it was
automotives we were saying like every
little knob in your vehicle if it's part
of the manufacturing process that goes
up to a company that trades in Europe is
going to have to be compliant with these
all the way down there's no way this
isn't going to raise costs like
exponentially worse than it is now and
like I can't stand for
it thank you other other thoughts
represent
Ross Yes um well I'm sure that all of my
colleagues read the uh CS DDD uh but
just for the folks at home I think that
they has been a characterization that if
you did not actually read the
EU uh regulation uh it might be a little
um not intentionally but misleading uh
the due diligence aspect the requirement
is that corporations not all of the
American people but corporations who
wish of their own valtion to do business
above a certain threshold in Europe use
due dilig to assess risk of Human Rights
abuses and negative climate impact this
is related to standards if you read the
the law and you look at the annex these
are related to standards especially the
human rights uh related aspects that
were passed by the United Nations I know
that representative Bernardi uh alluded
to things passed by the United Nations
as being uh more democratic than just
the EU and and these regulations are
based on what was passed by the United
Nations uh but getting back to do
diligence at risk
analysis uh it's not a mandate that you
absolutely have to shut down if your uh
one of your suppliers is using slave
labor which is one of the the aspects
that is that that people are supposed to
watch for they're supposed to assess the
a risk of one of their suppliers using
slave labor and if it
overburdensome then they're allowed to
make a a executive decision so it it's
not quite as Draconian as I think that
someone who actually hasn't read the law
might might think from the um maybe just
the way that we are are discussing it in
addition if your supplier does violate
any of these uh you as a company any of
these regulations then uh the larger
company that uses the supplier can't be
held uh held respon reliable for that so
that's just um some pieces on the the
ideological aspect but what I think it's
important to look at this absent the
ideolog iCal aspect and the precedent
that it sets because at its heart the
ability of a body to regulate who does
commerce within their
borders I I am shocked that my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle would want to put the government
in the Affairs of a foreign State and
private businesses private businesses
have the ability to choose not to sell
in the EU above a thir certain threshold
where's the the place of the government
to say no this is a private relationship
that the American government should not
be getting involved in uh furthermore if
there was any enforcement mechanisms I
believe tariffs were involved that would
potentially get us into a trade war and
tariffs would certainly raise prices for
the American Consumer and just finally
the hypocrisy of us saying no you are
not allowed to make not even allowed we
can't tell them that they're not allowed
this already passed and we don't have
any ability to unpass it on behalf of
the European Union we don't have any
control over what law uh laws or
regulations they pass for themselves but
let's say the uh us was was going
to reject compliance and I suppose
enforce tariffs as a
retaliation for a law that Europe passed
about what's allowed to go on within its
borders that is substantively or
procedurally absolutely no different
than what the United States just did
with Tik Tock we said we don't want the
we believe that there is a compelling
interest a national security interest
which there was not any proof of that
but people the lawmakers felt that there
was a compelling interest in uh making
sure that you do not have access to US
citizens data he said you are
fully Tik Tok is allowed to operate in
this country if you divest and sell to
American company bite Dan said bite
dance continues to say no we are not
going to do that as they have the a
right to the law was passed by Congress
it was upheld as constitutional by the
United States Supreme Court and as
chairman Moffet said earlier it's a good
thing to have the Supreme Court on your
side so the Supreme Court essentially
has uh endorsed the idea that a body has
ability to set their own regulations on
who does trade within their borders so
the idea that just because of an
ideological difference we can use our
power to politically influence another
state is horrifying honestly who are we
to say that you are our politics are
worthy to be inflicted on another state
what's to prevent anyone from doing that
to us the the political
coercion is just staggering If This Were
if the government were to actually try
and penalize the European Union for
passing their own
laws so I wholeheartedly hope that my
Ju Just a comment uh both representative
Belzer and representative F I thought
were wonderfully articulate and I just
want to say that when represent
representative Bernardi
introduced
hcr9 uh I thought that the questions
that were directed at him and his
answers were very
interesting fact I went home that night
believe it or not and I watched it on
YouTube again because I thought it was
such a good back and forth that's just a
comment um other positions thoughts
questions
on hcr9 representative
so excuse
me so the the CD or the CSD DD is
started out basically as you got to
comply with certain standards of
environment social economics and and
governance and how you run your your
businesses ESG is the same thing and
it's right there in the CD or
csdd that ESG is part of
it CSG is active in up and running not
only will that happen it is happening
and and and businesses within the United
States are being evaluated and ranked
csdd any smaller as as I said as it
progresses down to 28 you're going to
look at $50 million and 50 million euros
and X number of employees are going to
follow into this this standard so any
small organization or company that has a
cash flow problem of being able to put
in a solar field uh uh wind turbines and
everything to bring down their um green
uh uh their carbon use uh will not be
able to participate in
this and when they ship that off to the
next higher level and they're doing
business with the
EU that company will have to take the
risk and will get docked those points
and lower their rating to be able to do
uh trade within the EU and this is going
to happen across the world as I said uh
right now in the in Asia they're already
using ESG on on the public so if you are
not doing environmental social and
governance
within your your household you can't get
a you can't get a loan at a bank uh they
look at that they look at your your all
your posts your you know what you're
doing how you're living and making sure
that you're it in a proper it's going to
come down to more than just the
companies so I think we need to make a
stand and
say we don't
want to deal with this because we've
already we already get rid of the new
green deal we got rid of
Dei and if you look at the csdd it's the
same thing that's in there they had the
green deal it's not the green new green
deal but it's a green deal and that's
basically what it is it's saying that
you have to do this to be able to work
or or produce something and trade in in
Europe we got rid of it in new in the in
the United States and I I don't think
that we should put our companies through
that if they want to put that out
there thank you very much represent
Hemingway uh representative mandal bomb
can I ask a question of one of the
sponsors sure the exact session ask one
of the
the not not representative Bernardi
sorry of
um beler who made the motion would that
be okay sure that's why this why what we
do in executive session is is is
challenge each other or discuss so
represent uh beler will you take a
question from representative mandle bomb
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative beler so I believe that
you mentioned
that what this bill is asking is not
allowed in the New Hampshire
Constitution I heard something about the
New Hampshire Constitution and just
wanted to clarify I yes I'd be happy to
okay so um the New Hampshire
Constitution was amended I think it was
roughly 1950 but you have to look that
up uh to add under article 83 a section
in our constitution against
anti-competitive Behavior against
monopoly laws uh so what happens is when
companies the example I was giving when
companies go come together and they
decide to manipulate the market in a way
that limits choice in the market
or creates in this instance a set of uh
social uh activist conditions that all
players in the market are agreeing to do
simultaneously it's it's a manipulation
of the free market that's not allowable
under the Constitution it's also uh
against federal law and the whole
Monopoly busting uh
stuff that happened in the early 20th
century um it was a point to make that
these these companies would be in
violation of if they were doing this on
their own it would be
criminal but because they're actually
being manipulated by a government into
doing this it's actually worse than that
so that was the point I was making and
followup does
that when we talk about being
manipulated by government is does that
refer ref to governments outside of the
us as
well yes that that was the exact point
the EU in this in making this uh law is
saying that any government operate or
I'm sorry any Corporation over a certain
measure even American corporation that
operates in Europe has to implement
these uh
procedures but they don't just have to
implement them in Europe they have to
implement them companywide including
implementing them on Americans in
America even though it's an it's
American company thank you
yes represent cyber I was just going to
say like you know first of all we're
making very good points about you know
this being not the US who is doing this
I mean that's the big point and our
companies here can choose to opt out we
really don't have a say in what the EU
wants to do they're in a also in a
totally different situation you know
it's totally understandable that they
have a mindset that they're like a lot
of different countries but they're all
tied together so what one does can
directly affect the other and actually
does a lot of the time so it's a way of
them keeping themselves in check and
it's a policy they want to
implement and so you know opt out of it
if you don't like it I mean it's as
simple as that and quite honestly if
it's better and we have cleaner air I
mean we're the biggest tourist State and
one of the biggest ones in the nation
like why would we not want to start
things representative
Foss well I just want to again emphasize
that this is not first of all it's not a
mandate because companies are fully able
to choose not to do business in the EU
but it's also requiring them to do due
diligence to make sure that they are not
committing human rights
abuses and if they find that potentially
there is a conflict of interest there to
do risk
assessment but it's they have the choice
if anything inserting the government in
there is a form of government overreach
but also we we're talking on an
ideological level as though we have the
ability to repeal a regulation that the
European Union has already passed we
don't have the ability to go and say
that they are not able to enact these
especially when as I said we have just
done something very similar with Tik Tok
and I think there's a misconception that
uh there has been some sort of extension
when the executive branch can't
unilaterally overrule a law that was
passed by the Legislative and upheld by
the judicial
branch but we have just done exactly the
same thing and I I know in our other in
hearing we've discussed and I anticipate
that it will come up in 104 uh forever
Wars and the problems that happen when
the United States goes and it interferes
with uh the government or the political
system of another state so how if we are
imposing our political ideology on the
European
Union then that's the same as Iran in
the 70s or Afghanistan or Iraq
the principle is the same so if you
divorce it from any ideological points
that you do or do not agree with the
stand uh hold that for just a moment if
you would repres Manion represent you
just uh use the Expression imposing
ideology and I'm not sure if I see us
necessarily as is imposing ideology I
see us as maybe trying to
influence
Commerce um but I don't know that we're
NE necessarily trying to impose ideology
I think we'd maybe like to see some EU
countries have different
systems but I think there's a long
history of Nations and countries and
organizations trying to influence
commercial situations to their advantage
that do you do you really think that
we're trying to impose ideology here
well I think that the discussion that
we've been having since it comes from
such an ideological lens um you know the
terms Dei has been thrown around and uh
you know for reference uh hiring
preferences for veterans military
spouses and active duty service members
is a Dei effort so I suppose we're all
not in compliance but it's the way we're
discussing it from whether or not these
are right or these are wrong it is an
ideological imposition because that is
seems to be the basis upon which we are
uh the uh folks who are arguing for this
OTP are are saying that it should pass
because the majority of Americans uh are
inferred to have rejected this so we are
uh if it's being rejected on ideological
grounds because as as I said and as I
believe the European Union right has the
right
to make their own regulations around who
is allowed to do business within their
borders furthermore the uh it's not a
mom and pop shop doing business in the
EU who is going to be so financially
burdened by these regulations
everything is owned by Nestle and
Unilever and Johnson and Johnson so it's
not as though you know this small
struggling company is going to be uh
effectively shut down completely shut
out of business in the European Union
but it just the the discussion that
we've been having does make it seem like
it's being uh argued against from an
ideological standpoint so I do see it as
imposing an ideology on the people of a
foreign
State thank you for that representative
Manion I just want to say that
everything that we did in the 21st
century as far as conflicts was
absolutely abhorent so I don't support
that whatsoever so I don't think that
the the comparison is fair because I I I
wouldn't say that uh because we did
these awful things it's okay for the EU
to do this to us uh I also want to kind
of speak from a pers uh perspective of
somebody who's really uh Upstream of
like a manufacturers so I work in
automotive cameras like we build
Automotive cameras but we make the
machines that build the cameras that go
to the auto manufacturers so for example
if we were sell uh Ford were to sell C
these cars uh in the European Union we
are Upstream from that so my business
would be directly affected uh we're not
a mama pop shop but we definitely
started with like 20 people and we would
be subject to these EU regulations
because we are Upstream from
Ford thank you for personalizing that
that
wayos play any other hands okay uh R
rips and F go ahead but when you look at
the law to respond to that it um has
recourse for these small suppliers
they're very large um folks to whom they
provide these can help them as part of
their due diligence and risk assessment
so it doesn't leave people out to dry
but again I I really can't emphasize
enough that this is at asking large
assessment rep Manion first and then uh
Representative mandal Bob just I mean I
know this is anecdotal from my
experience but I know that for example
in a competitive market where we're a
small supplier if we are now uh if if
our buyers our customers like which are
like the companies that sell to Ford now
look at us and say oh well they're not
EU compliant but this other business
over here is EU compliant we will just
lose business based off this mandate
from
Europe representative Mandel bom thank
you Mr chairman
so this question I think is coming about
a little bit because I did not
thoroughly read through the um
csdd um but I'm wondering when it the
term due diligence seems really broad to
me and I'm wondering if representative
fost or or any of of the rest to be on
this committee have a kind of a more
tangible understanding of what that
means because how you know my business
might Define that might not be how
representative manion's business defines
that um you know or I don't even know
how the the EU is
um is um is is thinking of that so I'm
just curious if you have any thoughts
about that or if anyone else
does are you directing a question to
representative Foss or to anyone large I
think to anyone but I think
representative f is probably like the
primary target uh representative F
you're the primary target
here uh I'm flattered uh due diligence
is extremely Broad and uh up for a a lot
of interpretation so if if you want to
hold that against this regulation then
you know I think that's worthy of
another conversation but what it says is
that these cor large corporations doing
business in the European Union are
supposed to look at their supply chain
and their processes and the the the way
in which they do business to make sure
that they are not uh involved in human
trafficking for example is specifically
mentioned in the regulation or slave
labor or um you know anti-
uh anti-human rights and anti what we
consider very basic labor protections
that we have in this country so they are
uh supposed to investigate their
processes and their wide
operations to make sure that they are
not to their knowledge due diligence
again it it is extremely broad uh and to
uh look that that make sure that they're
not supporting that if they do find that
there is a risk that possibly one of
their suppliers is you know using uh
trafficed labor then they should
assess whether or not there's a
certainty or how that would affect their
business and if there are potentially
multiple risks then they are allowed to
assess which is the larger risk it
leaves a lot of room for the
corporations to adapt it to their
business
practices anything else uh from anybody
no I'd like to move the vote Mr chairman
okay we have a request to move the vote
the motion the motion
is on hcr9 rejecting compliance with the
European Union's
csdd motion is
OTP uh so Madame clerk when you're ready
you can uh call the
role
OTP thank you on the motion to OTP hcr9
how do you vote Vice chairman Rollins
yes representative Dolan yes
representative levit yes representative
gagy yes representative Manion yes
representative beler yes representative
Bennett yes representative Hemingway yes
representative plant yes representative
cybert
Madam uh representative Lloyd no
representative Jones no representative
Mandel bam votes yes representative
Buddha thaki no representative Foss no
representative Raymond no um chairman
Moffett
six 12 to 12 to six
yeah
okay the uh motion carries 12 to6 uh
representative Belcher I'm going to look
to you for a majority
report uh will there be a Minority
Report representative F I look forward
to your Minority Report thank you all
right that brings us to our final motion
or our fin motion yes final measure
which is HB 104 the defend the guard
measure uh I'm going to look to the
prime sponsor ripson Manion for a motion
thank you Mr chair reluctant reluctantly
I move
retain motion to retain from the prime
sponsor is there a
second second thank you representative
Bel seconding it uh represent man uh
please speak to your motion if you would
awesome so
what we noticed uh as always in all the
different states that this thing gets
filed is uh they roll in a bunch of
generals uh to oppose uh their key
argument is always funding and it's
never we we will lose X it is it puts X
at risk and we're seeing this all in a
bunch of states that this has been filed
in already we saw I've been watching the
testimonies in all the different states
it's almost as if they were handed a
script from somewhere Department of
Defense that says these are your talking
points deliver on these and they they've
changed over from the last time we heard
this thing a little bit but they're
still unanimous like a uniform across
all the different states so part of the
funding question here is so are we part
of a big a defensive Network are all
guard units part of a defensive Network
or not if they are why would they defund
us for the other functionalities that
the guard use at they have three
missions repel Invasion quell uh quell
upright and execute the laws of the
nation so if the threat here is that the
federal government is going to
completely defund the guard that
undermines the Constitutional Authority
and the the missions that these guard
units have by default the Constitutional
role then then they argue about peas uh
peas is not just a military base it's
also a civilian air base it's it has a
hybrid role so there's no way they're's
going to close an Airfield uh secondly
we have a strategic location of peas
being near near the North Atlantic with
a long enough Runway to accommodate
these just saying they're going to close
it seems crazy to me uh we have
Congressman on record Paul gosar uh from
Arizona Thomas Massie from Kentucky oh
yes from Kentucky senator Paul from
Kentucky saying that no act of Congress
will be done to defund the guard and not
only that they walked around and they
asked all their compatriots at the State
House would any of you file a bill to
defund any state guard should this
legislation pass none there's a house
resolution from gosar saying saying such
so during the testimony we heard quotes
um on our side in in favor of the bill
we had Daniel Webster quoted that it is
the duty of the state to interpose
itself between an overzealous federal
government and its militia to protect
them from at the time they were familiar
with the Kings sending their the Kings
from Europe sending their men off to
these useless Wars to die for nothing
and it is the job of the the state
legislature to interpose between their
men and the overzealous uh warmongers in
DC then we had two times medal of hon uh
Medal of Honor winners Smedley Butler
from the United States Marine Corps
wrote a very short little essay about
the war is a racket that still applies
to this day in my opinion uh we then
were had a quote from President
Eisenhower about the the Fe the the
potential problem of the
military-industrial complex that we have
not that he he waren then but we are
very familiar with today um what was not
addressed on the opposition side was
there was a lot of talk about this
patriotic propaganda word of the
mission can anybody Define to me what
the mission
is like Ser like I would like to know
because as a guy that had joined the
Marine Corps I went to go fight the
enemies of the United States including
Al-Qaeda specifically I went to go find
Bin Laden and kill Bin Laden bin Laden
died in uh 2012 and uh we stayed in
Afghanistan for another 10 years uh my
understanding is that the CIA was aware
that uh Bin Laden wasn't in Afghanistan
as early as November 2001 and we
remained there for two decades the 2001
aumf was specifically crafted for this
purpose to go destroy the enemies of the
United States that attacked us on 911
and the countries that harbored them
fast forward to this past December when
we helped Al-Qaeda I am not kidding you
all need to go look up Abu Muhammad Al
jolani that name write it down look it
up that dude is now in charge of Syria
he helped al-Qaeda in Iraq we he shot at
guys like me he was detained for an EXT
ex long time till we released him then
he went to go form alosra front then
which was an offshoot of al-Qaeda and
Syria joined Isis for a little bit of
time then went back to his Al-Qaeda
offet we have handed the country of
Syria to that man and the people that
work with him all under this 2001 aumf
we have people there are National
Guardsmen in the beginning of the Syrian
conflict made up less than 5% of the the
boots on the ground there it is now over
50% the tower 22 base in Jordan Northern
Jordan it borders the corner between
Syria and Iraq this area has been used
for to there's a main Supply route that
goes from uh Iran through Iraq into
Syria our job at that Tower was to
basically infiltrate any type of Iranian
supplies that may be going to the Bashar
al-assad regime That Base came under
attack because the Iraqis are pissed off
that we're still sitting in their
goddamn country right now and that came
under sorry language representative uh
uh roll I back would you please my my
apologies GD uh we're still in their
country since the Isis has been
basically defanged destroyed we are
still in Iraq under the pretenses that
we are protecting them from Isis which
would not have existed if we didn't
invade that country under a lie behead
their entire uh government dismantle
their army so they couldn't defend
themselves and then bomb their country
and cause all kinds of Martyrs and
people who have nothing left to live for
so they went to go join a terrorist
organiz a because they had nothing left
to
lose yeah it is add in but I think it
also goes a bit further back just to
kind of add to that on the Charlie
Wilson's War and all that fun oh yes
yeah I mean I'm really back to
partitioning of the British I agree yes
I I will not argue that whatsoever but I
would say that the United States like
directly in our lifetime this has
occurred um so back to so all that so
Tower 22 I want to go back to this so
Tower 22 came under attack last year
about one year ago today and uh it
killed three it became under a drone
attack from Iraqi militia they always
use the damn phrase uh Iranian backed
because they want to provoke us into
conflict with Iran for the record Iran
is bigger than Afghanistan and Iraq
combined with the population bigger than
that combined it has the worst features
of both and we lost both the Iraq and
Afghanistan Wars so anybody who's trying
to push us to attack Iran like I want to
know what you're smoking um the so the
tower 22 came under attack by these
militia and it killed three uh Georgia
reservists and it Def and it wounded
over 40 National Guardsmen from across
four different states the kicker the
United the New Hampshire National Guard
had just left that Airbase two weeks
prior it could have been our guys coming
back in critical wound and for what like
this goes back to the mission we kept
hearing the mission like there was like
four different people up there saying
like the American interest the interest
the the mission overseas what's the
mission help all alqaeda take Syria help
al-Qaeda in Yemen help al-Qaeda in Libya
to get rid of Gaddafi for what
purpose anyway so the good news about
this bill this week it has passed the
Virginia House committee 200 bipartisan
passed today came out of their house
committee Senate uh committee uh in
South Dakota 3-1 passed out of that
committee Wyoming house bipartisan 90
passed out of this committee this is all
progress this week on this bill
everybody is getting fed up on it we'll
retain it for now but get get ready for
me to be really angry in in September
and God forbid somebody comes home from
the New Hampshire National Guard in a
box between now and then thank
you thank you for speaking to your
motion representative Manion uh other
other thoughts on the retain motion uh
represent Bel you did the second
representative cyber yeah so I don't
mind you know honestly retaining this
but I would like to look at it further I
feel like it's a little
oversimplified in what it could cost the
state not just in that but there's a lot
of people and I talked to a fellow
representative um who's actually new
he's the new Pat long is what we call
him Patrick long he's a new repres ative
this year and um he served two tours um
in Afghanistan through the National
Guard and you know he's a lawyer now he
was able to go to college um he would
otherwise not have been afforded those
opportunities and to be able to buy a
home and you know these we're kind of
not listening to the actual people that
are out there right now that want to
leave after their four years and just
get those four years done and then be
able to you know go on with their life
and this is the way that they've chosen
to do it and so I just to me that's
really hard to reconcile is the people
here thank you repres
cyber representative
Jones thank you if I just may throw out
a kudos to representative Manion uh I
just wanted to say uh you you came over
and reminded me that I asked a question
of a presenter and and they skirted my
question and I just wanted to thank you
for reminding me of that would would you
care to say what your question was
because it's pretty
important I mean I can I can reiterate
what your question was it was the
difference between recruiting for
National Guard and recruiting for the
military yeah and I think it was
specifically if when they recruit these
teenagers out of high school if they
tell them when they're joining the
National Guard that they may be sent to
other comments
questions represent
Bennett thank you for taking my question
um yes sorry um I just I have gotten a
lot of um response to vote for
this and I'm hearing that I did hear
something about the funding actually I
know somebody um close to the family
that is in the National Guard and I
asked them if they knew about this
situation and what they would think
about it and this was a young person and
definitely you know did their time and
got some education has a good job and
everything um and that was the thing
they pointed out was the funding but I
didn't really completely understand that
um but I think the people that want this
situation
um are concern not for the people who
come back but the people that might not
come back you know sending your person
over there they might not come back and
we can help the people that did come
back but we can't bring back the people
that gave their lives and I think that's
what who we want to
protect and I think that we can't lose
sight of that you know that's what I
thought of when I had the choice at that
age to go into the military was I might
have to go to war and when I was in
college actually people that signed up
went to like Saudi Arabia and stuff and
they were surprised because they didn't
they didn't sign up for that you know
but I'm thinking that's why I didn't
sign up you know um but I do have a son
who went into the military and you know
every day you're wondering I wonder if
they'll come back or not and some of it
their friends don't come back so I just
think we should keep that in mind and I
don't understand all the process if
retain means that we can still pursue
this I think that's what I'm hearing so
that's where I would go but I was going
to vote for it but I appreciate your
comments to your question about
retention representative Bennett what
will happen here is that we'll sit
basically retain or sit on it in the
first year of a term and the second year
we have an option of interim study which
we don't have here so if if we do vote
to retain this is which is the motion in
the floor we would come back to it in
the fall and U and vote on what to do
with the retained motion and the
there'll be several choices and then the
first session first house session in
January uh whatever we decide will go to
the floor uh at that point so this gives
us uh some time uh repres man shared
some breaking news and that's part of
the value of retention is sometimes
circumstances change one way or the
other uh from what uh the the prime
sponsor just shared uh I didn't know
that that that's significant we always
look at what other states do to see if
it works it doesn't work whatever it
matters it's a federal system so uh we
we'll come back to this and then I don't
know what will happen when we come back
to it it may depend on uh other things
that develop who knows but uh we have
time in months months and months of time
representative man just to clarify so
like the retain is I think to put some
people who are on the edge like whether
or not they're going to support or not
because we have had buy off from the
current Secretary of Defense Pete hget
that he supports this bill he said it on
Fox and Friends he said it in a closed
door meeting with the people who who
wrote this bill when he met with them
and I I want him to do something that
comes straight out and says it honestly
I supported this bill last year before
Pete Heth was even a name I knew uh when
I supported this cuz I don't believe
that the funding thing is true uh one
thing I do want to mention about like
the guys that go down range like uh some
of them won do it for um they they there
was one uh representative testified and
they he was describing what I kind of P
you know pejoratively call ribbon
chasing where it's like I want to deploy
because I want ribbons uh I served under
officers that put men's lives at risk
because they were ribbon chasing which
is the equivalent of like we had a
captain our C company Commander my
second uh deployment would take uh foot
patrols of 12 men into an area that was
unn unsafe that the Iraqi Army that were
in charge of who are notoriously
unreliable so he would take men on foot
patrols because he really wanted that
Combat Action ribbon so You' take our
guys that were in his charge into an
area that was unsafe so I I consider
that ribbon chasing and I think it's not
great I understand that some people want
experience they want deployments etc etc
they uh you know I can't that's what
they want but our job isn't to just like
allow that thing to happen our job as as
the government is to be as the the
legislature to over to provide oversight
for uh the executive that may be taking
advantage of these young men uh for
example uh when I was recruited uh I was
told the Iraq war is probably going to
be over by the time you get there like I
didn't understand the Iraq War it's like
you're going to go fight al-Qaeda in in
Afghanistan I was lied to they didn't
necessarily know but you know it's our
job as the legislature to step in where
the executive will take advant advantage
of our citizens we should be the people
uh defending them we shouldn't just like
CU When a general comes up in a we
shouldn't just bow to his his uh
knowledge and be like oh well he's a
general we should listen to him as a
low-level enlisted man I know that
generals don't always make the best
decisions uh represent
floss uh thank you and I am very glad of
the opportunity to retain this because I
I myself have been very conflicted uh on
I have been uh asking everyone I know
who was in the guard to the point of at
my favorite bagel place I saw that
someone had a national guard license
plate in the parking lot and I went and
interrupted their breakfast and asked
them what they thought um so I uh
wholeheartedly would appreciate this
opportunity because I while I am
cautious uh of the fiscal note I I mean
I don't want
to it it's people's livelihoods that we
are you know rolling the dice on here
it's I'm very conscious of my father's
family when he was growing up the they
had one income and it was from my
grandfather working on PE air Fort space
and were people to lose their jobs uh I
I don't feel like I could go to my
constituents and say well I thought it
wouldn't really happen and I I certainly
can't summon the ghost of Daniel Webster
to quote at them and say this is why uh
I your representative should have voted
for that but at the same time I'm
someone who you know the when 911
happened I had just turned 11 so for my
entire adult life there have been people
in the Middle East and if people signed
up for the guard when I was turning 18 I
couldn't myself because I'm disabled uh
they knew that they were going overseas
uh I had a friend who his father was in
the guard and served in Iraq and then
when we graduated from high school he
went and served in the Middle East and I
used to check his Facebook every once in
a while to make sure he was still
alive uh he was and he's doing very well
uh so I am definitely sensitive to both
aspects and I I very much appreciate the
opportunity for more study on this so we
hadn't have the home strats going to
vote soon and I'm going to go right to
represent cyber in a moment uh to your
point uh this has come up and it's been
called the game of chicken many people
have said that uh the folks that rban is
talking about said they would never dare
defund this uh and I kind of think he
may be right but I'm not sure and uh and
the folks we heard much testimony that
uh they'll move asset so defund us uh
that nobody can guarantee either way and
and so it is a an uncertain game of
chicken and and that's not a nice way to
put it but that's the essence of it uh
real you mentioned uh being 11 when 911
hit that remind when I was growing up
Vietnam was hanging over our heads every
single day year after year that was a
more intense conflict than what happened
in the Middle East like represent like
representative Manion after 911 uh I was
I was a reservist I put a uniform on it
they went to Central Command uh where
they ran the War uh I work for General
Franks uh in at sencom in mcdill and the
focus was Afghanistan as representative
Manion said a lot of people joined up
after 911 as it sounds like he did I put
a uniform on the same thing but the
focus was Afghanistan Afghanistan
Afghanistan I was there for quite a
while and it shifted to Iraq and I we
don't need to get
into why that happen or the merits of it
except that that did happen and and so I
listening to the to folks like R of
Manion who or Pat Tilman who joined up
he was a NFL star Arizona Cardinal and
he joined up like we did put a uniform
on after 911 to go to Afghanistan they
sent him to Iraq and ironically he
eventually did get to Afghanistan where
he was killed by friendly fire but uh I
just wanted to personalize that a little
bit and and thank you for for
personalizing it as well I think that's
important that it matters as we finish
up representative cyber you had your
hand
up I think we shouldn't mention all this
without mentioning what happened
recently with the what like two days ago
with the training exercise crash I found
out one of the kids on that that was on
the helicopter actually went to my high
school he was in the ROC somebody was
passing that around he went to Parkview
High School
in Lilburn Georgia which is right
outside of Atlanta um Ryan O'Hara um but
I guess I kind of wanted to point out
that unfortunately like all too often
people also die in training exercises um
just as a point of that um yeah so it's
not just going overseas where you know
people give their lives I felt like it's
fair to mention
that representa mle bum
so I'm going to Echo what representative
F said about just being appreciative
that we are retaining this bill and not
necessarily voting on a or not voting on
a motion to OTP today um I agree with
the spirit of the bill but um P's uh
International Guard is in my district
and I felt that as written with what we
being told um by some of the military
officials that I just couldn't support
it just because of the unknowns about
what it could mean for the people um
working at PE so um I I think the motion
to retain is a good
one anything
else can I ask a straw pole say again
can I ask a straw poll I'm just curious
about like potential
amendments uh you this is executive
session I believe in free speech
representative uh ask whatever you want
okay so I've been kicking around an idea
and even the guys who the bill aren't
like too hot on it however what if let's
say we amend it to put a trigger clause
in place that says if uh five states or
some percentage of the population pass
effect representative I very interesting
thought uh the wheels are turning I
think it's putting folks on the spot a
little bit to to to commit to anything
without doing maybe not a straw po it's
just something I've been mulling over
myself because I understand the fears
here with like funding and they move
might move stuff somewhere else but if
like there's nowhere to move it to
because we all passed this bill or like
10% of the country passed the bill we we
can amend this uh this fall uh we can do
a number of things with it and the
landscape will be different then we'll
know more the the defense secretary hegi
piece I'm very interested in uh if if he
says something one way or the other way
that matters of course it matters
uh so somebody uh so I don't want to
squal your straw pole except that that's
UHA uh any other I I responded to
anybody else uh representative Lloyd
thank you Mr chairman um yes I in
response to that question specifically I
think that that is a holding point for
me in particular because there are so
many unknowns of whether or not this
would have repercussions and I would
just like to remind the committee and
those watching online um that even
though we're arguing about potential
fiscal impacts and dollar signs and
assets and things like that in my mind
that also equates to saving lives
because if I'm going to ask anybody to
send their child overseas or if I'm
going to ask anybody to fight on my
behalf overseas I want to ensure that
they have the the most advanced
equipment the most defense possible for
their own lives and the and the safety
of their families um so I think that
it's not as easy and cut and dry as uh
this has this much fiscal note impact I
think for me it's it's the peas Air
Force Base aspect of things that's over
10,000 civilian jobs if that were to
shut down and several hundred businesses
um and that would have a huge impact
here in New Hampshire Alone um in
addition to that losing any of the
assets sets or any of the um the
equipment or just even the funding for
the proper equipment um would also
impact lives as well and so the other
piece of it is just even being able to
allow our guard to more easily respond
should our troops already overseas have
an
have an adversary or an adversarial
interaction having yet another who to
jump through um in order to get them the
the relief that they might need is also
a concern for me so it's it's those
types of things but I do think that
retaining it would allow hopefully if
another state passes this or other
states have passed this and there are no
are no repercussions coming down from
like the national level um I would feel
a little more comfortable with
that thank you for that other other
hands repres Hemingway who is a a a
Guardsman correct a retired Guardsman
yes Mr so please thank you Mr chairman
um and just want to speak on that and
I'll be brief because uh I know we're
we're running on time but uh you said it
to amend if five or more States or 10%
of the states uh did that um I would say
if that would happen within this year I
probably still would not vote for it
only because you still don't know what
the ramifications are they already have
their funding and the funding won't
happen again until next year and we can
say the congressman and and
congresswomen uh wouldn't cut the
funding but the funding goes to NGB NGB
would be the one na the Guard Bureau
would be the one that would say divvy
out the funds uh one other thing is a
peas was shut down and a Brack and is
now an air guard unit so it is no longer
an Air Force unit uh it was shut down
with Brack and Brack is federal because
Brack's not going to come in and grab a
a National Guard unit and pull it away
so Brack was the base realignment en
Clos your committee when they could
never close any bases they I think it
was a good idea they created a
commission to separately take the
politics out of it largely and
separately recommend base closures and P
was one of the ones that was deemed as
less necessary is an Air Force Base but
very good point it's now a a New
Hampshire guard asset it's not a Air
Force asset very good important point to
Brack uh other hands uh before
we close
out uh uh Prime sponsor yes and the last
thing just remember all this goes away
if if Congress just declares war that's
all we're actually asking so this entire
debate is moot if we could just get
Congress actually put their name on the
here okay the motion on our final
measure of the day HB 104 FN defend the
guard motion is to retain uh so Madam
clerk when you're ready uh you can call
the role all right on the motion to
retain HB 104 how do you vote Vice
chairman Rollins
yes representative Dolan yes
representative levit yes representative
Gagney a reluctant yes representative uh
Manion same reluctance yes
representative beler yes representative
Bennett yes representative
Hemingway yes representative plant
no representative
cybert yeah representative Judy we mam
representative
yes representative Jones yes uh
representative Mandel bound votes yes
representative budak yes representative
Foss yes representative Raymond yes
chairman
Moffett yes all right so it passes 17
to1 17 to1 to retain that was our final
motion of the day uh thank you for your
time it's a long day hopefully it was a
good day uh we are going to come
together again a week from today uh and
at that time we will hear the last three
hearings that we still have and then
we'll have an exact session in the
afternoon uh be prepared we may or may
not be able to do this but if we if we
can we'll try to exact those three
measures uh next Friday if it works out
if it does we'll be done if if it
doesn't work out we'll we'll come back
again as necessary folks who are doing
uh committee reports if I if I could get
those uh this is Friday uh Sunday Sunday
night uh by 2000 by 8 p.m. uh so on
Monday we can get our reports in to uh
the clerk Etc and uh that's all I got
we'll see everybody next week thank
thank you much uh
okay